Thank you.
Scholastic Audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 2, The Lost Air, by 2 E T Sutherland
Read by Shannon McManus.
The Dragonette Prophecy.
When the war has lasted 20 years, the
dragonettes will come, when the land is
soaked in blood and tears.
The dragonettes will come.
Find the sea wing egg of deepest blue.
Wings of night shall come to you.
The largest egg and mountain high will
give to you the wings of sky.
For wings of earth, search through the
mud, for an egg the color of dragon
blood.
And hidden alone from the rival queens
the sand wing egg awaits unseen.
Of three queens who blister and blaze and
burn, two shall die, and one shall learn
if she bows to a fate that is stronger
and higher, she'll have the power of
wings of fire.
Five eggs to hatch on brightest night
five dragons born to end the fight.
Darkness will rise to bring the light.
The dragonettes.
Are coming.
Prologue.
Underwater, Webbs couldn't hear the
screams of dying dragons.
Underwater.
The battle was as far away as the 3
moons.
Fire couldn't touch him.
Talons couldn't scar him.
The blood washed away from his claws.
Underwater.
He was safe.
Safe, and a coward.
Still better than loyal, brave, and
dead.
Webbs shuddered awake.
A catfish was staring at him blankly.
Its whisky tendrils drifted in the
current.
The expression on its face said, Why is
there a dragon sleeping on my river
stones?
Webbs ate it.
And that made him feel a little better.
The talons of peace must know what's
happened to the dragonets by now, he
thought.
They have spies in the Skywing Palace.
They don't need to hear it from me.
The other talons did not need him to
stand up in front of them and say, we
failed.
But where could he go?
He was already hiding from his own tribe
the sea wings.
Did he have to hide from the talons of
peace for the rest of his life as well?
Webbs paddled to the surface of the river
and cautiously poked his head out.
It was dark, with the claws of the clouds
mountains blocking most of the moonlight
like vast shadowy teeth.
He'd been swimming down river for days.
The Sky Kingdom was far away now.
The sky kingdom.
And the 5 dragonettes he'd sworn to
protect.
Webbs dragged his long, aching body out
of the water, and took three steps into
the forest before he noticed the dark
shapes waiting for him.
He spun around, but a new dragon loomed
out of the river to block his escape.
Black spiral patterns marked his green
scales, and his teeth gleamed in the
moonlight.
Webbs, said the other Sea Wing, in a
pleasant voice.
I thought you would never wake up.
Webb drew his talent through the
riverbank mud.
Nautilus, he said.
He hated the tremble of fear in his
voice.
I have important news for the talent.
You don't say, said Nautilus.
I suppose you got lost on your way to the
usual meeting place.
So we thought we'd come find you, said
one of the dark figures, in a voice like
icicles dripping.
Siri, Webb's thought.
It was never a good sign when Sirius the
ice wing appeared.
The Skywings found our cave Web said.
Just tell the truth.
It's not your fault.
And Queen Scarlet took the dragonette.
Yes, said Nautilus dryly.
We gathered that much from how she's
practically been standing on the tallest
mountain shouting, I have the dragonettes
of destiny.
They're all mine.
Tell us everything.
Cyrus hissed.
How did they find you?
Well, Webbs said slowly.
It started when 2 of the dragonets tried
to run away.
Maybe three.
He wasn't sure where glory had been on
the night he could only find Starlight
and Sunny, but he knew she couldn't have
gone into the river with tsunami and
clay.
Why would they run away?
Nautilus asked sharply.
What did you do to them?
Webbs felt his gills flare.
We kept them alive, he snarled.
And trapped them underground.
And chained tsunami.
And planned to kill glory because she
wasn't part of the prophecy.
But what choice did we have?
Surely you call it the runaways and
brought them back, said a voice in the
shadows.
Webbs recognized crocodile, a mudwing new
to the talents of peace.
His hopes rose.
In his few meetings with her, she'd been
sympathetic.
Perhaps he had one ally here.
Er Webb said, no, not exactly.
They kind of came back on their own to
get the others.
He cleared his throat.
We weren't expecting that.
Kestrel thought they'd be long gone.
As soon as they hit the sky.
It sounds as if they felt like
prisoners.
Nautilus said in a soft hiss.
You told us to keep them underground.
Webbs protested.
That was a decision made by all the
talents.
But we wanted them agreeable, not
rebellious, said Nautilus.
That was the entire point, wasn't it?
A murmur went around the circle of
dragons.
There were 7, including Nautilus, as far
as Webbs could tell.
He wondered if he could fight his way
past 7 dragons.
It wasn't our fault, he muttered.
Maybe there's something wrong with them.
What does this have to do with the sky
wings?
Sirius hissed.
The Skywings followed Clay and Tsunami
back to the cave.
Webbs explained.
That's how Queen Scarlet found us.
We tried to fight back, but she killed
Dune, and took Kestrel along with the
dragonettes.
Will she make them fight in her arena?
asked Crocodile.
Can they win?
They're only dragonettes.
Cerrus growled.
Of course they won't survive the arena.
Surely she'll spare the sky wing, at
least, Crocodile said.
Webb flinched.
He had never been brave enough to confess
to the talons of peace, that they'd lost
their Sky Wing Dragonette, and replaced
it with a rain wing.
But now that the dragonets were out in
the world, everyone would know soon.
You know what Queen Scarlet did to all
the sky winged dragonettes who hatched on
the brightest night.
Cyrus hissed.
Mercy is not exactly in her nature.
Webbs raised his head and looked around
at the eyes that glittered in the dark.
Can't we go get them?
He asked.
Maybe if all the talons attacked at
once.
His voice faltered.
Who is he kidding?
He wasn't about to go rushing into the
Sky Wing Palace to die. and he was closer
to the dragonettes than any of the talons
who hadn't even met them.
All the talons, Sirius hissed. 40 dragons
against the 100 sky wing palace guards, a
brilliant plan.
No wonder we left the dragonette, senor
capable claws.
His diamond shaped head darted up and
snapped a bat out of the air.
Tiny bones crunched in his teeth.
A suicide mission may not be necessary.
Nautilus said.
Something happened in the Sky Wing Palace
yesterday.
We don't have any clear reports yet, but
one spy said he thought Queen Scarlet was
dead. killed by the dragonettes.
Webbs flared his wings in surprise.
By my dragonettes?
he asked.
Maybe they have a talent for escaping.
Nautila said.
Although another spy was sure they all
died trying to fight their way out.
Webb's stomach felt as if it were full of
poisonous jellyfish.
The dragonettes couldn't be dead.
Not after all he'd given out for the sake
of the prophecy.
And to save my own scales.
A small voice whispered inside him.
If they are loose in Pyria.
How do you suggest we find them?
Nautilus asked.
Non-suicidal suggestions only please.
Well, for us.
You may feel free to kill yourself
whenever it's convenient.
I don't know.
Webbs admitted.
He had no idea where the dragonettes
might go.
He didn't understand why they would want
to be on their own, cut off from their
protectors.
The worst 10 days of his life, were the
ones between the battle where he had
abandoned his queen, and the day the
talents had found him, alone.
With no tribe to support them, and no
talents to protect them, how would the
dragonets survive?
If we can't get the dragonettes back.
Nautilus mused.
I suppose we'll have to consider our
backup plan.
He scratched his gills thoughtfully.
What backup plan?
Webbs asked.
The one you don't get to know about, Sarah
said.
But, but we have to get them back, Webb
They're the dragonettes.
They're the only ones who can stop the
war.
Have a little faith in the prophecy webs
Nautilus said.
Yes.
Don't worry, Crocodile said
reassuringly.
The talons of peas wouldn't put all their
eggs in one nest.
It's a good backup plan.
Webbs looked from one shadowed face to
the next.
Apart from crocodile, he saw nothing
friendly in the eyes staring at him.
I don't understand, he said.
Was there another prophecy he didn't know
about?
Of course, Nautilus said.
That means you would be a problem.
Webb's barely had time to say, what?
before Cyrus was suddenly on his back
pinning him to the ground.
His wounds from the sky wing soldiers
flared up with bright new pain.
One wing was twisted behind him, and he
could feel the ice wings serrated claws
digging into his scales.
What are you doing?
Webbs yelped.
I'm one of you.
I've been with the talent of peace for 7
years.
And you failed us.
Sirius hissed.
Now, now, Nautilus said, then paused.
No, that's fair.
I'm going to dig your heart out and feed
it to the fish.
Cyrus growled.
Won't that be ironic?
Webb thought gloomily of the fish he'd
just eaten.
But we're the dragons for peace, he
said.
His teeth gritted with pain.
If we kill each other.
Aren't we as bad as burn and blister and
blaze?
Sorry, Webbs, Nautilus said.
Peace is more important than any one
dragon.
And you would disrupt our backup plan.
We're doing this for your own good, for
the prophecy.
For peace.
Webbs heard the horrible echo of his own
words.
The same thing he'd said to the
dragonettes whenever they complained
about life under the mountain.
It's for your own good.
Peace is the most important thing.
He'd believed it when he said it.
No doubt Nautilus did too.
Nautilus gestured with one talon.
Sirius.
Rip out his heart.
The jaws of the ice wing sprang open, and
Sirius flung webs down onto his back, his
icicle sharp claws flexed, ready to tear
into Web's underbelly.
Suddenly, crocodile cannoned into him
knocking Sirius into the undergrowth.
Webbs didn't hesitate.
He flipped upright and shot into the sky
as fast as his wings could carry him.
He heard shouts as crocodiles struck out
at the dragons around her, and he felt a
stab of guilt.
Should he stay to help her fight?
But why go back for death when he had a
chance at life?
He heard wing beats behind him and flew
harder.
He imagined Sirius breathing down his
tail, or Nautilus hissing closer and
closer.
But it was crocodile's voice who called
to him.
Fly, Webbs.
She cried.
I've knocked them out.
They didn't see that coming.
Ha!
Thank you.
Webb called back.
Twisting to see her heavy brown shapes
soaring behind him.
Where will you hide?
she asked He shook his head.
I have no idea.
I've heard there's a dragon in Jade
Mountain who might, you should go home
she said.
Tilting her wings to swoop under him.
From what I hear, Queen Coral is in a
merciful mood these days.
The thrill that ran through webs from
horns to tail nearly took his breath
away.
Home, back to the sea, after all these
years, is it possible?
She'll never forgive me.
Not after everything I did, he said.
It's not just that I deserted her during
a battle.
She must know I was the one who stole her
egg for the prophecy.
You might be surprised, said Crocodile.
Isn't she supposed to be one of the
greatest queens in history?
That's what all the sea wing scrolls
say.
Perhaps she'll forgive you.
Why not take the chance?
If it means you can go home again.
Webbs was silent.
One of the moons was rising, shimmering
off his blue green scales.
From up here, he could see the ocean.
Far off in the distance, but it seemed as
unreachable as the moon itself.
Up to you, Crocodile said.
Banking away from him.
Now, I'm just telling you what I've
heard.
Good luck.
Either way.
Good luck to you too.
Webbs called.
She vanished into the trees.
And he wondered where she would go now.
He missed the sea with every scale on his
body.
He missed the palaces, the currents, the
whale songs, the feasts, the gardens.
The other sea wings, If the talons are
done with me.
If I promise her, I'll be brave this
time.
Maybe, I can go home again.
Part one.
The edge of the ocean.
Chapter one.
A wave roared onto the beach and crashed
around Tsunami's talons, her webbed claws
sank into the wet sand, her blue wings
billowed in the wind.
She lifted her head, breathing in the
wild sea air.
This was where she was supposed to be.
This was her ocean.
Let me guess, Glory said mockingly behind
her.
You guys, that's the smell of freedom.
Freedom, smells a lot like fish, Starfly
observed, which, to be clear, is kind of
nose curlingly awful.
I love it, tsunami said.
This was what the talons of peace had
stolen from her.
They'd kept her trapped in the stale
dreary air under the mountain her whole
life when she was meant to be out here
flying and swimming, and living like a
real sea wing.
Starflight glanced up at the sky and
edged back toward the dark foliage that
lined the beach.
Shouldn't we stay under the trees?
What if a patrol spots us?
I mean, he stopped and took a deep
breath.
We must stay under the trees.
All right, yes, everyone back into the
trees right now.
The others ignored him.
Although Sunny gave him a pitying
glance.
Tsunami bent her head to study the waves
washing over her talons, small shapes
silver and green and yellow, darted
through the shallows.
The ocean smelled much more alive than
the cave river.
Was it only a week since they'd run away
from their guardians?
It was hard to remember exactly how long
they'd been trapped in the Sky Wing
prison.
But there was one thing tsunami
remembered clearly.
The sound of bone, snapping under her
talons.
She poked a hole in the sand with her
claw.
I had to kill that ceiling.
Queen Scarlet forced us to fight.
There was no other way out of the arena.
He was crazy.
It was him, or me.
The same thoughts kept circling in her
head like lame winged dragons.
She shook her head and flared her wings.
This was ridiculous.
Was she a dragon or a scavenger?
Dragons were meant to be fierce
warriors.
One little death shouldn't rattle her so
much.
Besides, glory had done worse with her
deadly venom, and she didn't seem
bothered at all.
You know what I love?
Clay said mournfully.
Fish.
Lots of fish.
Big fish I can eat.
Not these little wriggle scraps.
The mudwings sat down on the sand beside
tsunami.
His stomach growled loud enough for all
of them to hear.
Sonny giggled.
Clay, it's only been a day since you
caught that enormous pig for all of us.
Wasn't enormous.
Clay said.
He sighed, his wings drooping.
That was the smallest pig in the whole
world.
You should have eaten my carrots.
Sonny clambered up to sit on his back and
peer out at the ocean.
The sun was just rising in a peach pale
sky, casting broken paths of light across
the water.
Two of the moons barely slivers like thin
claws were vanishing behind the
mountains.
I'm serious, everybody, Starflight said.
It's not safe out on the beach.
Not with all the mud wings and sky wings
looking for us.
The Night Wing was standing well out of
reach of the waves, trying to shake sand
off his talons.
As far as tsunami was concerned, they'd
already wasted a day flying south of the
diamond spray delta.
Basically because Starflight had worried
and complained until everyone agreed.
Yes, the sky wings were after them.
Yes, they were probably mad about the
Dragonette's escape from Skywing Prison
and they were pretty definitely mad about
the part where Glory maybe killed their
queen on the way out.
But tsunami didn't want to keep running.
She wanted to find her family.
Once they knew who she was, she was sure
the sea wings would protect her and her
friends.
Most of all, she really wanted Starflight
to stop fretting, complaining, and
bossing.
It made the others nervous and harder to
organize.
She almost wished the night wings hadn't
given him back.
Why are you so worried?
Tsunami asked him, if they do recapture
us, won't your nightwing friends come
swooping in to rescue you again?
Starflight fluttered his wings
indignantly.
I'm not worried for me, he said.
I'm trying to keep all of us safe.
He glanced at Sonny and ducked his head.
I'm keeping us safe just fine, tsunami
protested.
When have I ever led us wrong?
Well, glory pointed out, there was that
one time we got captured by Sky Wings and
their queen nearly killed us all.
Tsunami smacked her tail into the water
to send a cold wave over glory.
The rain wing hissed and jumped away from
the sea.
Stop it, Sonny said.
Stop fighting, all of you.
Clay, stop them.
She patted the top of his head to pull
his attention back from the tiny fish
swimming around his feet.
Oh yes, let's hear from our big wings.
Glory teased.
Her scales this morning were gold, like
sunny's, but with drifting splashes of
ocean blue, she sat down and yawned at
tsunami, displaying her venom spitting
teeth.
Hey, Clay said, nudging tsunami's wing
with his own.
It's all right for Starflight to worry.
We don't even know if Queen Scarlet is
alive or dead.
But, he added quickly.
I know you want to find the sea wings as
fast as possible.
So let's find them instead of fighting
about it, and then we can get to safety
sooner.
Tsunami shot one more narrow eyed look at
Starflight, then turned back to the
ocean.
Clay was right.
The important thing was to find her
family and a safe place for them all to
hide.
Oh, Glory said, so wise and big.
I think he is.
Sonny said, wrapping her forearms around
Clay's neck.
Starflight sat down, flipping his tail
around his talons unhappily.
Glory settled her sun colored wings.
So now what?
Should we shout, hey, sea wings, we've
got your missing princess, and wait for
dragons to bound joyfully out of the
ocean?
With a feast, Clay cried, startling a
seagull into the air.
There was a feast at the end of the
story.
When the missing sea wing princess got
home, her parents were so happy they made
a feast.
I remember the feast.
They ate a whole whale.
That was a good feast.
I bet I could eat a whale.
Do you think we'll get a feast?
The missing princess was just a story in
a scroll, Starflight said.
We have no idea what we'll actually find
in the kingdom of the sea.
That's true.
Clay's wings drooped.
It might not be what you're hoping for
tsunami.
Like, finding out my mother sold me for a
cow.
Hey, said Glory, it was at least 2 cows.
Hmm, comforting, said Clay.
It wouldn't be like that for tsunami.
She was sure of it Maybe Clay's dreams of
his family had turned out all wrong, but
hers would be perfect, especially now
that she knew her egg had been stolen
from the royal hatchery.
She was the daughter of the sea wing
queen.
Not only that, but according to
Starflight, none of the Queen's other
female dragonettes had survived to
adulthood.
Tsunami was the only living heir to the
Sea Wing kingdom.
One day, she would be queen of the sea
wings.
True, that meant one day she'd have to
fight her own mother to the death to
become queen, but that day could be as
far off as she wanted it to be.
Not something she had to think about
now.
She spread her wings and breathed in the
salt spray air again.
Out of the corner of her eyes.
She kept seeing tiny creatures pop out of
the speckled sand and then vanish again.
I could just dive in and look for the
ceiling palace.
Tsunami suggested.
Out there?
Starflight sounded alarmed.
He spread his wings and shook sand off
them, blinking anxiously.
Where else do you suggest I find the sea
wings?
She asked.
Swimming in the ocean is not like
swimming in an underground cave river.
Starflight lectured.
There are strong currents and
unpredictable waves, and and big things
with teeth, I'm a big thing with teeth.
Tsunami grinned at him.
He didn't laugh.
It's not safe, he said.
What if we lose you?
Tsunami wanted to poke his wrinkled up
worried snout with our sharpest claw?
Starflight?
Cheer up.
Sonny interjected.
Tsunami can do anything.
And how is she supposed to get home to
her family if she can't go into the sea?
Oh no.
Clay heaved himself to his feet
scattering sand and nearly dislodging
Sonny, who grabbed his neck with a yelp.
Sand and seashells and tiny, astonished
crabs flew through the air as he lashed
his tail.
Ow, stop that.
Glory commanded, covering her eyes.
What about us?
Clay's big brown wings flapped.
I didn't think of that.
Tsunami.
We can't go with you to the Sea Wing
Palace.
We can't breathe down there.
How can we stick together if you're
underwater?
He clawed at the water, leaving deep
gouges in the wet sand.
What are we going to do?
Tsunami kind of adored Clay when he was
in a tizzy.
She also adored that it had taken an
entire day for it to occur to him that
the kingdom of the sea was underwater.
Seriously?
Glory said to Clay.
All of those geography lessons, and not a
single one sunk in.
Clay turned in a confused circle.
Crabs scurried out of the way of his
giant talons.
What?
The sea wings have an above water palace
too, Starflight said, in his, see, you
should have studied more, voice.
So they can receive guests, like their
sandwing ally blister?
It's on an island somewhere in the Bay of
a 1000 scales.
Oh.
Clay sat down with a whooshing sigh.
Sonny patted his shoulder.
I didn't remember that either, she
offered.
So we go there, right?
Not easily, Starflight said.
Both sea wing palaces, underwater, and on
land are well hidden.
That's how they've lasted so long in this
war.
Even though they don't have fire like the
other tribes.
Nobody can find them to attack their
homes.
Sounds like the Night Wings, Glory
sniped.
It's nothing like the Night Wings, tsunami
cried.
Seawings aren't trying to act all
mysterious and pretentious.
They're just being sensible about
guarding their home.
There are over a 1000 islands to search
but it's still probably.
Starflight stopped mid-sentence and
glanced to the sky again.
Does anyone else smell fire?
Three moon Starfight?
I'm not hiding in the trees every time
some little things spooks you, tsunami
said.
Wait.
I think he's right, Sonny said, lifting
her head.
I hear wing beats.
I do too.
Starflight said.
The spiny ridge along his back, stood up
in alarm, and he bolted for the trees
running as fast as he could.
From this far away?
tsunami said skeptically.
I don't see anything up there.
But just as she said it, she spotted a
cluster of red specks like spattered
blood in the sky, winging down from the
mountains in the northwest, a Skywing
patrol was coming their way.
Chapter 2.
Quick, into the water.
Tsunami ordered.
It was closer than the trees, and would
hide them just as well.
No way, said Glory.
She sank to the ground, spreading her
wings and shifted color.
Her scales flowed into the rocky, sandy
pattern below her until she was
impossible to see, especially from the
air.
It happened so fast, tsunami nearly lost
track of where she was.
Glory was getting better at that trick.
Fine.
Come on, sonny.
Tsunami reached for the little sand
wing.
I'd rather not, Sonny squeaked.
I can make it to the trees.
I'll fly really fast.
She jumped off Clay's back and flapped
after Starflight.
Tsunami stamped her foot, spraying ocean
water across the sand, glory made a
muffled, grumpy noise.
It'll be safer in the sea.
Tsunami huffed.
She cast a worried look at the sky.
The specks were getting closer, fast.
Maybe faster than Sonny could hide, but
it was too late to catch her now.
Tsunami turned and dove into the ocean.
Clay was already burrowing into the
shallow mud shelf, displacing startled
flatfish and sending up clouds of
minnows.
The mudwing didn't have a problem with
water like the others did, since he could
hold his breath for up to an hour.
Tsunami breathed in and salt water rushed
into her gills.
It surprised her how sharp it felt, like
inhaling smoke.
It was nothing like the crystal clear
water of the underground cave.
What's more, the current kept trying to
shove her back to the beach, then yank
her out again.
But she plowed forward and down, past
clay, beating her wings as the water got
deeper.
Schools of tiny purple fish whirled away
from her like stars exploding. over the
edge of the sand shelf.
The deeper ocean floor was covered in
bundles of eel grass.
Waving dark green tendrils reached up to
brush tsunami's underbelly.
She glanced up at the sky above her.
Still empty, and decided to risk
surfacing, she had to be sure Sonny was
safely hidden.
The thunder of wing beats echoed in her
ears as she poked her head out and turned
toward the beach.
The little sand wing was almost to
safety.
Tsunami could see Starflight standing
under the trees, reaching his front claws
out to pull Sonny in.
Overhead, an orange shape shot past
flying at full sky wing speed, faster
than any other tribe could fly.
A red dragon flew close behind the first
followed by 3 more.
Their enormous wings nearly blotted out
the sun as they whooshed over the
dragonette's heads.
Tsunami sank a bit lower in the water, but
it seemed like the patrol was going too
fast to notice a lone sea wing in the
ocean.
Maybe these soldiers weren't hunting for
the escaped prisoners.
Then she saw the last dragon.
Sunset orange, flames flickering from his
nose, with a jagged tear on the tip of
his left wing.
He flew slower than the others, bringing
up the rear, and his head swung back and
forth, dark eyes searching the ground
below them.
Tsunami found herself holding her
breath.
The Skywing's snout swung toward the
trees just as Sonny's tail whisked out of
sight.
He paused.
Beating his wings back to hover in the
air for a moment.
Was he staring at the trees?
Had he seen Sonny?
What if he called the others back?
The patrol dragons were several wing
beats away already, but one shout could
bring them hurtling around at lightning
speed.
Sunny and Starflight were no match for 6
full grown sky wing soldiers.
Actually, they were no match for one Sky
Wing soldier.
The 2 of them together would probably
have trouble fighting a sleepy bat.
A curl of smoke rose from the sky wing's
nose, and he opened his mouth.
If there was any chance of saving her
friends, tsunami had to shut him up, she
burst out of the water in a great leap
smashing her tail behind her for
momentum.
Her wings powered her up to ram right
into the sky wings underbelly.
He coughed at a puff of fiery smoke and
clutched his midsection.
The breath knocked out of him.
Tsunami had a few moments before he could
recover enough to call for help.
She ducked around him, slammed her tail
into his head, and landed on his back as
hard as she could.
The sky wing nearly fell into the water
but he fought back up into the air.
Tsunami kicked at his wings with her
claws and slid back toward his tail
trying to drag him down with her weight.
He was too big and too strong for her up
here.
Only taking him by surprise, had given
her a temporary advantage.
She needed to get him in the ocean to
even out the fight.
The orange dragon snarled and twisted
shooting a blast of flames out of his
snout, which barely missed her.
Tsunami yanked him down toward the
water.
But his massive wings beat harder and
harder.
It felt like a hurricane whistling around
her ears.
She could tell that he was gaining height
and in a moment, he'd be strong enough to
call the other soldiers back.
You're not getting my friends, tsunami
thought fiercely.
She found the vulnerable spot on his tail
and sank her teeth in.
He convulsed with pain, nearly throwing
her off, and shot another blast of fire
under his wing at her.
At first, tsunami thought he had missed.
Then she felt a searing trail of agony
spreading along her neck.
It felt as if someone were trying to saw
through her scales with a scalding hot
wire.
She closed her eyes and clamped her jaw
harder, determined to hang on, although
spots were starting to dance in her
vision.
Suddenly, the dragon lurched toward the
sea.
Tsunami's eyes flew open.
Clay had flung himself between her and
the dragon's snout, spreading his
fireproof wings.
His claws clamped onto the Skywing's back
and the extra weight drove the soldier
down and down toward the sea.
Together, Clay and Tsunami dragged the
sky wing into the ocean.
He fought wildly the whole way, but his
flames couldn't hurt Clay's fire
resistant scales, and his giant wings
couldn't help him once he was underwater
and cut off from breathing.
As soon as they hit the water, tsunami
swam to the Skywing's head and held it
below the surface until he stopped
thrashing.
She let go, and so did Clay.
The dragon's body began to drift slowly
toward the seafloor.
A shudder rippled through tsunami's
scales.
Him or me?
This didn't feel right.
Why couldn't she be ferocious and not
care?
She swam after the dragon and grabbed one
of his wings, then looked back up at
clay.
He met her eyes, and to her relief, didn't
even hesitate before swimming to the
other wing.
They dragged the sky wing up onto the
beach.
The current had carried them farther away
than tsunami had guessed, and it was
painfully hard to swim back to shore
especially with a full grown dragon
weighing them down.
She gritted her teeth, ignoring her
exhaustion and the pain from the burn on
her neck.
She was a sea wing.
This was supposed to be her element.
She was the boss of the ocean, not the
other way around.
By the time they reached the beach.
The rest of the patrol had vanished from
sight.
She wondered how long it would be before
they noticed this one missing, and came
back to look for him.
Tsunami collapsed onto the sand beside
the sky wing.
Clay peered into the dragon's snout, then
started thumping his chest.
What is wrong with you?
Glory's voice snapped?
The rain wing materialized from the sandy
background, turning her scales a darker
shade of brown so they could see her.
She glared at tsunami.
Why did you do that?
Oh, you're welcome, tsunami said, just
saving your life as usual.
By attacking random dragons?
Glory cried.
In another moment, they would have been
gone.
And what are you doing?
She jabbed clay in the side with one of
her wings.
Oh, Clay mumbled, fixing him.
He kept thumping the sky wing's chest.
What?
Glory yelped.
You can't let him live?
She tried to grab one of Clay's forearms
but tsunami shoved her away.
We don't have to kill him, tsunami said.
We'll tie him up and leave him here.
Great, Glory said.
How about a trail of cow parts too, and a
map of where we're going?
Or perhaps we could set this part of the
forest on fire, just to make sure
everyone knows how to find us.
Would you like me to spell out
Dragonettes was here in giant rocks?
Fine, Tsunami said.
Here he is.
You kill him.
Glory looked down at the unconscious
dragon and hesitated.
I don't kill dragons who can't fight back
she said finally.
Why not?
Tsunami said.
Just splat some venom on his face and
melt him, if it's that easy for you.
Glory sank her claws into the sand
scowling.
Bubbles of dark purple began spreading
across her scales.
Sunny and Starflight landed on the beach
beside them.
Sonny gave the sky wing a horrified look
and tsunami remembered that she'd been
trapped in another part of the palace
during the arena fights.
She'd never seen her friends battle
another dragon.
Is he all right?
Sonny asked Clay.
Troy this, Starflight offered, coming
over to help.
Clay shifted aside, and they rolled the
dragon onto his stomach.
Why did you attack him?
Sonny blurted at tsunami.
The little Sandwings harmless tail
flicked back and forth anxiously.
To save you, tsunami said, stung.
But he wasn't even doing anything, Sonny
protested.
He was just flying by.
All 4 of them were looking at tsunami
like she was the kind of dragon who hid
under rocks and bit innocent passers by
for fun.
She arched her neck indignantly.
I thought he saw you.
She growled.
He was about to call out to the others.
I saw him open his mouth.
So did I, said Glory.
I'm pretty sure he was yawning.
Pretty sure, tsunami said.
Would you risk our lives on pretty sure?
Was he yawning?
Did I attack him for nothing?
That can't be right.
I saw danger and reacted appropriately.
Didn't I?
Maybe if you'd just stopped to think for
a 2nd.
Starflight said, or forever, like you?
Think, think, think, worry, worry, never
do anything?
Tsunami cried.
The Sky Wing suddenly coughed, and
Seawater flooded out of his snout.
Clay ruffled his wings with a pleased
expression.
Oh, wonderful.
Our enemy will survive.
Well done.
We have to get out of here, Lori said.
She took a step back and glanced at the
sky where the other soldiers had
disappeared.
So, what do we do with him now, O great
leader?
Tsunami had no idea.
She glanced around frantically.
Maybe if they could find some vines to
tie him up with.
There's a tree, Starflight said, jumping
to his feet.
In the forest.
No way.
Glory said, a tree in the forest.
Being sarcastic is not helping.
Tsunami snapped at her.
I mean, a fallen tree, Starflight said.
We can use it.
Glory, stay and guard him.
Clay and tsunami, come on, quick.
Clay charged up the beach behind him.
Tsunami paused for a moment.
She didn't like leaving the soldier, even
if he wasn't fully awake yet.
She also didn't particularly like taking
orders from Starflight.
Go on.
Hurry.
Sonny said, nudging her with one wing.
Not far into the forest, a large tree had
fallen, with the top of its branches
brushing the sand.
Clay and tsunami shoved and rolled it
onto the beach and dragged it back to the
sky wing, while Starflight flapped around
squawking instructions.
As if we need to be told how to move a
tree.
Tsunami thought grumpily.
The soldier's eyes were blinking awake as
they reached him.
He coughed and coughed again, lifting his
head to peer groggily at the
dragonettes.
So how does the tree help?
Tsunami asked.
We put it on top of him, Starflight said
so he'll be trapped in place, at least
long enough for us to get away.
Tsunami hated to admit it, but it was a
good idea.
She helped Clay wrestle the tree over
until it lay heavily across the orange
dragon's back and wings.
The Sky Wing tried to push himself up, but
the tree kept him pinned to the sand.
What if he's stuck here forever?
Sonny worried?
She reached over and brushed some sand
off the Skywings snout.
He snorted a puff of smoke, and Clay
pulled her back.
Maybe we should just let him go.
We can't do that.
Tsunami said.
I wish you hadn't attacked him.
Sonny said, ducking her head.
Me too, said Glory.
It wasn't the smartest move, Starflight
agreed.
Tsunami's gills flared, and she spread
her wings.
You don't know that, she said.
Maybe I saved us, again.
She looked at Clay, but he only shrugged
as if he wasn't sure.
Thanks for the support, guys.
Tsunami thought angrily.
When all I'm trying to do is keep
everyone safe.
Don't worry, sonny, Clay said, patting
the little sandwings head.
His friends will come looking for him
eventually.
Eventually, or soon, Glory said.
So like I said, let's seriously get out
of here.
Wait.
The Sky Wing rasped.
His voice was hoarse and deep.
He wriggled, lashing his tail across the
sand.
Don't leave me like this.
Starflight stepped into his line of sight
and gazed down at him.
Remember, we could have killed you, he
said.
Remember that the dragonettes of destiny
were merciful.
We want peace, not more death.
We have come to save Pyria.
Oh, good grief, tsunami said, as glory
rolled her eyes.
No more hanging out with night wings for
you.
I thought it sounded nice.
Sonny said.
Starflight shot her a grateful look.
Sonny, don't encourage him, said Glory.
Carefully, Starflight draped a few large
leaves over the dragon's head, so he
couldn't see where they went.
He pointed toward the forest and mouthed
just to be safe.
Tsunami sighed.
More flying in the wrong direction.
She wanted to go home already, home to
the ocean, and the sea wings, and her
royal parents.
But she couldn't argue about it with a
sky wing listening, and the others were
already nodding.
All of them were ready to follow anxious
overly cautious Starflight yet again.
And none of them thought she'd done the
right thing by attacking this sky wing
even though it was to save their stupid
scales.
As they lifted into the sky.
She cast a longing look over her shoulder
at the ocean.
Soon, she thought.
Soon, I'll be with my own dragons.
Chapter 3.
The Bay of a Thousand Scales was farther
away than Tsunami had realized.
She'd been studying the map of Pirus and
she was tiny, but it was hard to fit that
picture over the enormous world below
her.
She kept expecting to find neat little
spirals of islands that would fit in the
palm of her talons.
Instead, she found herself flying over
vast expanses of empty ocean, dotted here
and there with a solitary outcropping of
rock.
After they took a long detour inland to
convince the Sky Wing they'd gone in the
opposite direction, they circled around
south and flew out to sea.
They managed to make it to a small rocky
island shortly after night fell, but
according to Starflight, they were still
a long way from the Bay of a 1000
scales.
He'd calculated the distance and their
speed and had a long, boring lecture
ready to explain it all.
The rest of them fell asleep halfway into
it.
And he spent the next day sulking about
that.
Still, tsunami had to admit, if only to
herself, that it was useful having
someone with all the geography and flight
plans in his head.
For a few days, they stopped whenever
they saw an island, ate a seagull or fish
if they could catch any, and then flew
on.
Tsunami tried diving into the ocean
several times, and was disappointed to
discover she couldn't swim as fast as she
flew.
The only good news was that the ocean
water helped to heal the burn on her
neck.
It was 4 mornings later, when tsunami
finally woke up on an island that was
officially part of the 1000 scales.
She started awake from a dream in which
their cave had collapsed and was slowly
crushing her to death, and discovered
that clay had rolled over on top of her
in the middle of the night.
Grumbling, she wriggled out from under
him, and let his tail flop over onto
Starflight's head.
The 5 dragonettes were packed into a
cavern, halfway up a tall sea cliff.
It was cramped and uncomfortable, and
smelled of seagull droppings.
Clay had barely been able to scrunch his
wings low enough to crawl inside.
And why were they sleeping in this
horrible spot instead of on the nice
white, sandy beach below?
Tsunami sat down in the cave entrance and
glared at Starflight, which wasn't very
satisfying since everyone was still
snoring away.
Clay was stuffed against the back wall
with sunny between his front talons, and
Starflight curled up alongside.
Even glory had her tail draped over
clays.
Her scales glinted orange and gold in the
light of the rising sun, with bursts of
red when she shifted sleepily.
Starflight had been acting so weird since
the night wings gave him back.
Suddenly it seemed like he wanted to
argue with tsunami about everything.
If she said, let's sleep on the beach
it'll be fun.
He'd say, no, no, we have to sleep in a
hidden cave.
That'll be much safer.
Safer, as if there was anything to worry
about all the way out here in the middle
of the night.
But everyone was still mad at her about
attacking that soldier, so they all voted
with Starflight.
She didn't like that development at all.
Tsunami watched them sleep for a moment.
It was so hard to lead effectively when
everyone kept questioning you and
complaining about everything.
She only wanted what was best for them.
Didn't they know that?
She'd always figured she would fight a
100 sky wings to protect them.
But maybe I shouldn't.
Maybe my friends don't want my protection
after all.
Maybe they wanted Starflight to be their
leader instead.
Even though he'd never risked one scale
on his body for them.
Tsunami glance down at the sea.
Sparkling aquamarine below her.
Somewhere, in those blue green depths, was
her family.
Her parents, her kingdom, everything that
should have been hers, if the talons of
peace hadn't stolen her away and ruined
her life.
Perhaps the problem with her friends was
that they were from different tribes, all
stubborn and muddled up, instead of
sensible like sea wings.
Maybe her own kind would understand her
better.
They'd appreciate her instead of yelling
at her.
Well, she didn't have to sit here waiting
for everyone else to wake up.
It wasn't like they'd be much help when
it came to searching anyway.
Tsunami stretched her wings and then
tipped forward out of the cave opening.
Wind whistled past her snout, tugging at
her tail as she plummeted down the
cliff.
At the last moment, she snapped her wings
open and sailed across the top of the
water, skimming it with her claws.
Joy tingled through her scales.
She spun and dove into the water.
The sea was warmer here, and busy with
underwater life.
Her splash sent what seemed like 1000s of
fish scattering away, several of them
disappearing into a pinkish orange coral
reef that curled out of the sand like a
petrified forest.
A blobby, dark blue octopus, goggled at
her from the branches.
Tsunami kept saying flickers of bright
yellow and silver at the edge of her
vision, as fish fled from her webbed
claws.
No welcoming committee of delighted sea
wings, though.
No glowing jellyfish marking a path to
Queen Carl's Castle.
No cavalcade of bowing seahorses and
bejeweled lobsters to lead the way.
Not that she'd been picturing the
homecoming scene from The Missing
Princess or anything.
Tsunami swam along the coral reef, peering
at the creatures hiding in the nooks and
holes.
A hideous thing she thought might be an
eel stared back at her.
Little orange and white fish nestled in
the waving lavender anemones.
She still wasn't used to swimming in the
sea, and that frustrated her.
Unexpected currents kept knocking her off
balance.
The saltwater felt like it was scraping
roughly against her gills.
Where were her natural sea wing
instincts?
Her world was supposed to make her
stronger, faster, tougher.
Not pathetic.
She swam all the way to the next island
fighting the currents.
More of the pinkish coral reef stretched
across the sand here as well, dotted with
waving green fans and lacy dark purple
ferns.
Her wings felt sore and tired.
So she spread them wide and floated near
the surface, not far from the land.
Something flashed below her in the
shadows of the coral reef, something very
large.
Tsunami had a brief vision of all the
large toothy things that might live in
the ocean, then dismissed it.
If it was a shark, she would kill it and
bring it back to the others to eat.
Mainly so she could see the look on
Starflight's face.
She flicked her tail to swim closer.
It was another sea wing.
A shiver rippled across her scales when
she saw him.
And part of her wanted to bolt right back
to her friends.
Don't be a smoke breather.
She scolded herself.
This is what you were hoping for, a
dragon from your own tribe.
She took a deep breath.
The strange sea wing had dark blue horns
and sky blue scales several shades paler
than hers.
He was paddling by the reef, shifting his
talons and wings slightly to change
course, his head turned alertly from side
to side.
Well, it wouldn't hurt to follow him for
a while first.
Tsunami told herself.
She crept along the top of the reef
peering over the edge at him.
Her claws caught on small gaps in the
curl.
She accidentally poked an indignant black
lobster, which came bustling out with its
long whiskers bristling and pincers
snapping.
It took one look at her, and hustled
right back into hiding.
Up here.
The reef was covered in a layer of green
moss like algae.
Tsunami passed a couple of large sea
turtles slowly swimming nearby.
An enormous tentacled thing like a sea
spider sat nibbling bits of algae.
The tips of its 8 dark purple legs glowed
orange yellow, and so did its eyes.
The sea wing down below stopped suddenly
and glanced around.
Tsunami flattened herself against the
reef.
Knobbly bits of limestone poked into her
underbelly.
She peered through one of the holes of
the other dragon.
He spun slowly, staring into the ocean
depths.
Had he heard her?
But he didn't look up.
The dragon checked around him one more
time, then lit up the stripes along his
wings.
Almost immediately, another dragon swam
out of a cave in the coral reef.
Hmm, tsunami thought.
Much less handsome.
His green scales were perfectly nice, but
she didn't care for the black spiral
patterns on them.
She'd never seen a pattern like that on a
dragon before, and his face wasn't nearly
as handsome or friendly looking as the
1st dragon, although perhaps that had
something to do with a giant bruise
swollen over his left eye.
She wondered if they were guards
switching patrol duty.
If so, they were being quite strange
about it.
The 2 dragons floated in place, staring
at each other for what seemed like an
eternity.
Occasionally, the stripes on one sea wing
would light up.
Then on the other.
They moved their talons about as if
waving away fish, even though no fish
went anywhere near them.
And then, the spiral marked dragon ducked
back into the cave, and the blue dragon
swam on.
Some kind of sea wing patrol ritual?
Tsunami wondered.
I guess I'll have to learn all that stuff
in order to become queen.
She lifted her wings to swim after the
1st Dragon. and a pair of yellow striped
fish wriggled out from under her and shot
away.
The sky blue dragon swam back the way
he'd come, toward the stretch of open sea
between this island and the one where
tsunami's friends were sleeping.
Now or never, tsunami thought.
She'd rather meet this dragon than the
other one, and she'd rather do it while
he was alone, if she could.
That seemed easier than trying to explain
herself to a whole bunch of dragons at
once.
She beat her wings to catch up, dove over
the edge of the reef and swam around in
front of him.
The sea wings started back in an eddy of
ripples.
His eyes were a blue so dark, they were
almost black.
Tsunami pointed up at the surface.
Come on out of the water so we can talk.
She tried to signal.
Hopefully he'd figure out what she
meant.
To her surprise, he whipped around and
fled.
His tail smacked a wave of water in her
face.
Well, that's unfriendly, she thought.
She swam after him, swinging her tail to
propel herself even faster.
He glanced back over his shoulder, saw
her chasing him, and put on a burst of
speed.
Why was he running away?
And how was he so fast?
Stop!
She tried to yell through the water.
I just want to talk.
Of course, that didn't work.
He didn't even slow down.
But then he twisted to look back at
tsunami.
And so he didn't see the whale that
suddenly loomed out of the deep in front
of him.
Tsunami waved her talons and pointed
Watch out, she shouted in a cascade of
bubbles.
The sea wing smacked into the whale's
side and careened backward.
The whale was only slightly bigger than
the dragon, with ridges all along its
back, and a flat, mild mannered face.
It made a weird squeaking groan and
blinked at the sea wing in confusion.
The dragon was still shaking his head
trying to reorient himself.
When tsunami caught up, grabbed his tail
and pinned him to the sand.
The whale blinked again and swam on.
Eddy's rippled around the 2 dragons as it
powered away through the water.
Now what do I do?
Tsunami thought.
I have to get him to the surface to talk
to him.
But if I let him go, he might try to
escape again.
She frowned down at the dragon and
pointed at the surface again.
Flashes of sunlight shimmered above them
like pieces of broken, gold, white glass
floating on the water.
The other dragon tipped his head to one
side.
Luminescent stripes lit up along his
wings, flashing fast, then slow.
All right, tsunami thought.
I can do that too.
Maybe he's testing me.
She lit up her own stripes, illuminating
the ones on her snout, then the ones
along her tail, and finally her wings.
See?
My stripes flash too.
I'm a sea wing.
Now let's go up and talk.
Slowly, she spread her wings and lift it
up.
Prepared to grab him if he tried to bolt
again.
He scrambled upright, but stayed with
her.
Encouraged, tsunami swam a bit closer to
the surface.
He followed, but only for a bit before he
stopped and looked around.
His stripes flashed again, this time
along his neck and tail.
Impatiently tsunami lit up her stripes
one more time, mirroring what he'd done.
The sea wings wings flared open with a
whoosh. that scared fish into the reef, he
lunged towards tsunami, fast as a
minnow.
His front talons reached for her, tsunami
roared, blasting him in the eyes with
bubbles, and sliced her claws across his
snout.
She didn't know why he was attacking.
Maybe he was a traitor's sea wing, or
maybe he was guarding his territory or
treasure.
Perhaps he thought she was an intruder
although he wasn't much of a guard if his
1st instinct was to run away and his 2nd
was to attack with no reason.
He'll be sorry when he finds out who I
am.
She thought fiercely.
She kicked his underbelly hard with her
back legs.
He coughed up a stream of bubbles and
fell back. tsunami spread her wings
snarled at him one more time, and shot to
the surface.
She burst into the air, and kept beating
her wings to rise into the sky.
In the distance, she could see the
cliffside cave and the worried faces of
her friends poking out.
An enormous splash sounded behind her.
The other sea wing surged out of the
ocean.
His massive tail whacked the water twice
as he lifted into the air, sending giant
waves rushing in all directions.
He looked even bigger out here in the
air.
His hooked claws gleamed sharply in the
sunlight.
His dark blue eyes were fixed on her
wings.
The 1st true citizen of her kingdom she'd
ever met, and he was coming to kill her.
Chapter 4.
Tsunami shot toward the island where her
friends were.
The sea wing was close on her tail.
He roared something, but the wind whipped
it away so she couldn't hear it.
She saw Clay wriggle out of the cliff and
take to the air.
That's what she needed, back up.
With a quick twist of her wings, she
aimed for the strip of white, sandy beach
where she'd wanted to sleep the night
before.
The other 3 could stay safely in the cave
she and Clay together could handle this
sea wing.
She hoped.
Wait.
Her pursuer yelled, where are you going?
What's wrong?
Tsunami's wings missed a beat, and she
nearly dropped into the ocean.
She swung around, hovering over the sea
between the cliff and the beach.
Out of the corner of her eye, she saw
clay veer into a circle in the air
waiting to see what she would do.
The other sea wing paused as well.
He kept the length of 2 dragons between
him and her.
The scratches on his snout were
bleeding.
What's wrong?
Tsunami cried indignantly.
Didn't you just attack me?
I certainly did not. he protested.
Glowing lines flickered along his snout.
I thought you.
That's the normal.
He seemed to be getting more and more
embarrassed.
You said you liked me, he finally burst
out.
I didn't say anything of the sort, tsunami
said, astonished.
The Sea Wing's brow furrowed.
You very clearly said you liked me, and
you'd followed me all the way out here to
tell me that.
Tsunami just about fell out of the sky.
You are a delusional squid brain, she
cried.
Well, maybe not in those exact words. he
said.
All right, it was a little confusing.
Maybe a lot confusing, but the message
was in there, and why else would you be
chasing me?
When exactly do you imagine I said all
this?
Tsunami demanded shortly after you
attacked me, perhaps?
The other dragon touched his snout gently
and winced.
You were the only one doing any attacking
he said.
I was being friendly after what you
said.
Stop, tsunami said.
Maybe she'd misunderstood his actions.
Maybe his approach had been a sea wing
greeting ritual she didn't know, in which
case, his poor snout.
She winced guiltily.
Perhaps she shouldn't have gotten
defensive so quickly.
Tell me exactly what you think I said.
He sighed.
I said, what are you doing all the way
out here?
And you said.
He paused, rubbing his front talons
against his head.
You said, hey, sparkling teeth, I totally
love 3 of your claws but not the others
and I wish your nose was a herring so I
could eat it.
And also your wings sound like sharks
snoring.
Tsunami burst out laughing.
All right, I get it, she said.
Although she didn't really.
Did all sea wings have a strange sense of
humor?
Would she have to develop one too?
You're making this up?
He stared at her.
Are you seriously going to pretend you
didn't say any of that?
Of course I didn't.
Tsunami said.
Maybe he wasn't kidding.
Maybe he was mentally unbalanced.
I didn't say anything at all.
We were underwater, remember?
The strange dragon hovered for several
wing beats, glowing stripes lighting up
along his blue scales.
His face slowly went from confused to
angry as he frowned at her.
Who are you?
He demanded.
I'm a sea wing, she said hotly.
Just like you, so no need to get
hostile.
A sea wing who doesn't speak aquatic, he
growled, not likely.
What are you really?
How did you make yourself look like a sea
wing?
Tsunami's heart sank?
Aquatic?
Sea wings have their own language?
Of course they do, she realized.
It felt like the tide was going out
inside her, leaving nothing but stretches
of bare sand.
And of course, nobody ever bothered to
teach it to me.
Just one more creative way the talents
found to ruin my life.
Why hadn't she thought of that before?
Three moons.
She was as thick as clay.
The dragons of the sea had a whole palace
underwater.
Of course, they needed a way to
communicate down there.
They couldn't just pop to the surface
every time they needed to chat.
She glanced down at her webbed talons and
remembered the gestures she'd seen the 2
sea wings making while their luminescent
stripes flashed.
Talent signals and glowing stripes.
She must have said all that nonsense with
her stripes without realizing it.
But how can I be queen of the sea wings
if I don't even speak their language?
And why didn't anyone ever tell me about
this?
Clay had never met a dragon of his own
kind before.
That's why he knew nothing about mud
wings, but tsunami didn't have that
excuse.
One of the guardians who'd raised them
had been a sea wing.
So why?
Why?
Had Webbs never taught her the sea wing
language, or even told her they had one?
All those scrolls about sea wings.
Not that she thought about it.
There was plenty of dialogue in the
underwater scenes, like in the missing
princess when the lost daughter found her
parents.
Tsunami had always assumed that was a
storytelling technique, not an actual
underwater language.
She looked up and met the sea wings, dark
blue eyes.
His head was tilted curiously.
You don't look guilty, he observed.
You look sad, and I imagine it would be
hard to fake those.
He nodded at the webs between our claws.
So where did you come from?
And what's wrong with you?
Tsunami bristled.
There's nothing wrong with me, she
snapped.
I just happened to have been raised by
idiot.
His gaze suddenly shifted behind her.
Look out.
He yelled, his tail whipped around and
slammed into her, knocking her aside.
She spun toward the water, dizzy and
shocked.
Her wings brushed the ocean waves as she
righted herself and turned around.
The strange sea wing was grappling with
clay up in the sky.
Tsunami gasped.
The sea wing was full grown, bigger than
clay, and he was not afraid to lash out
with teeth, tail, and claws.
But she could tell clay was holding back
worried about hurting a possible ally.
He ducked his head between his front
talons and tried to dive away, but the
sea wing seized Clay's tail and dug his
talons viciously into Clay's scales.
Clay howled with pain.
The other dragons started to drag him
down to the ocean, where he would have
all the underwater advantages of sea
wings, and clay would eventually drown.
Clay!
Sonny shrieked, launching herself out of
the cliffside cave.
Tsunami got there first.
She smacked the sea wing over the head
with her tail, seized his wing and her
talons, and yanked him away from clay
when he turned around in surprise.
He tried to spin around her to get back
to his prey, but she blocked him with her
wings and lashed out at his snout again.
He flinched back, and that was enough
time for Clay to scramble out of reach.
What are you doing?
The sea wing yelled at tsunami.
I'm saving you from that mud wing.
Well, don't!
Tsunami yelled back.
He's my friend.
But Sunny slammed into the back of the
sea wing, landing between his wings and
wrapping her talons around his neck.
Leave him alone, she panted.
The sea wing looked more astonished than
alarmed.
He wriggled his shoulders and twisted his
neck, trying to see what was on his
back.
Sonny kicked his wing and he yelped.
That's my other friend, tsunami said.
Sunny, try not to hurt him too badly.
We need his help.
I hardly think this gnat is going to hurt
me.
The sea wing growled.
Sonny kicked him again.
Promise me you won't attack clay, she
said.
His eyes went to the brown dragon
circling just above them.
Clay rubbed his head anxiously.
The mud wings are our enemies.
The sea wings snarled at tsunami.
If you don't know that, then you'd better
leave the Bay of a 1000 scales, before
Queen Carl's army finds you and does what
they always do to traitors.
I'm not a traitor, tsunami said, and clay
is not your enemy.
She glanced up at him, then back at the
sea wing.
You'd better learn some respect, squid
brain.
We're the dragonettes of destiny.
Chapter 5.
Riptide, Sonny said again.
That's a funny name.
I like it, tsunami said.
Fierce and scary, like mine.
Ribtide was pacing the beach, lashing his
tail in a long, swishing trail through
the sand.
His sky blue scales glinted metallically
in the morning light.
He had claw mark scars along his pale
underbelly, and what looked like an old
bite mark on his tail.
Tsunami was pretty sure he was only a
couple years older than she was.
The scratches she'd given his snout had
finally stopped bleeding.
She hoped those wouldn't leave scars
too.
He had a very handsome snout when it
wasn't all clawed up.
All right, he said.
So the talons of peace are real.
Unfortunately, Glory muttered.
Ribtide glanced at her, and tsunami felt
a weird tingle of jealousy run through
her scales.
Glory had found a large rock to perch on
spreading her wings open to the sun, and
her scales were shimmering silver and
rose.
I thought everyone knew about the talons
Sonny said.
Just rumors and whispers, said Riptide.
None of the tribe queens would be pleased
to find a member of the peace movement in
their midst, conspiring with other tribes
stealing eggs?
He shook his head.
Queen Coral would kill any dragon she
found working with a talons.
He gave tsunami a searching look she
didn't understand.
Clay was sitting with his tail in the
water.
He had muddy sand packed over the spot
where riptide had clawed him.
Sonny sat next to him, giving riptide
fierce looks whenever he paced too close
to clay.
And you're the dragonets of destiny.
For real, the ones in the prophecy.
That's real.
Riptide stopped, inhaled deeply, and blew
out again.
And you're here.
In sea wing territory.
Just like, He glanced at tsunami again
then went back to pacing.
I know, it's thrilling, tsunami said, but
we're really looking for somewhere safe
to go.
The talons of peace treated us terribly
and I figured the sea wings would welcome
and protect us.
I suppose, Riptide said, not very
reassuringly.
So you were all raised in a cave?
He stopped in front of tsunami.
With no ocean?
Never.
You never went into the ocean?
This seemed to be the hardest part for
him to believe.
Not until we escaped, tsunami said.
But that's awful, said Riptide.
Thank you, tsunami said, flaring her
wings.
I know it was.
I've always said our life was miserable
but these dragons keep arguing with me.
Not me, Glory said.
I can't believe the talents did that to
you, Riptide said, clawing the sand.
Tell me about it.
Tsunami said.
They really are the worst.
Even webs, webs didn't take you to the
ocean?
Riptide asked.
You know about webs?
Sonny asked.
Riptide ducked his head and frowned at
his talons.
He's pretty infamous in the tribe.
We all know he deserted during a battle
and later he came back and stole one of
the queen's eggs.
At least, Queen Coral was sure it was
him.
But nobody knew if he stole it for the
talons of peace, or for his own reasons.
We're not really supposed to talk about
the talents of peace rumors.
Didn't anyone think he might have stolen
the egg to be part of the prophecy?
Starflight asked.
Riptide nodded.
Some of us did.
But again, nobody talked about it.
Queen Blister doesn't like hearing about
the prophecy, so that's also been a
forbidden topic.
Tsunami wrinkled her snout.
Blister gets to decide what sea wings can
talk about?
Riptide shifted uncomfortably and picked
up a large conch shell.
He twisted it between his talons.
You'll want to call her Queen blister
when you meet her, he said.
Not until we decide she should be queen
tsunami said stoutly, that's up to us
remember?
It looked for a moment like riptide was
trying not to smile.
Well, Starflight stammered, she is a
pretty good.
I mean, she's the smart one.
I think we'll probably, tsunami tilted
her head at him.
What was he rattling on about?
He snapped his mouth shut and went back
to picking sand out of his scales.
Did you know webs?
Clay asked riptide.
The sea wing dropped his gaze.
Not really.
He ran away during a battle when I was
only 2 years old, but I've been hearing
about his treachery my whole life.
He sighed.
I really can't believe he never took you
to the ocean and all that time.
It's true, tsunami said.
And he never taught me aquatic.
I wish I had all the talons apiece here
so I could bite them.
To be fair, the talons were just keeping
us safe, Sonny interjected.
They needed us to survive to fulfill the
prophecy.
Tsunami snorted, and Sonny gave her an
injured look.
But the prophecy, Riptide said.
He pointed at glory.
It calls for a sky wing.
She's not a sky wing.
It's a little complicated, tsunami said
as a hint of sea green rippled across
Glory's scales.
Anyway, I'm not sure we really care about
the prophecy, but we do care about
finding the families we were stolen
from.
I care about the prophecy, Sonny
protested.
She poked Clay's side, and he nodded
agreeably.
Starflight cleared his throat, but
tsunami hurried on before he could start
lecturing again.
His egg hadn't been stolen.
The night wings had handed it right
over.
So maybe he didn't care about getting
home, but she certainly did.
Only a few days ago, I found out I was
stolen from the royal hatchery, tsunami
said.
So, So I thought maybe my parents were
looking for me.
Like in the missing princess?
Do you know that scroll?
Riptide definitely squashed a smile this
time.
I do, he said.
It's required reading in school.
School, Starflight said, in the wistful
tones Clay used to talk about food.
Required reading?
Tsunami echoed.
That was odd.
It was a fairy tale, not a historical
document, and not perhaps the best
written scroll she'd ever read, although
it was still one of her favorites because
of the story.
But I can't take you to the palace
Riptide said firmly, not with him along.
He jerked his head at clay.
Weren't you listening?
Tsunami said, exasperated.
He's not a regular mudwing.
He's certainly not allied with Bern or
the Skywings.
You can trust him.
Perhaps you should stay here, Riptide
suggested, and I'll bring Queen Coral
back to you.
He glanced across the water the other
island, where he'd met the green dragon
with the black spiral patterns.
Tsunami wondered if he was wishing for
reinforcements.
Nope, she said, we're all coming with
you.
I'm in enough trouble with Queen Coral.
Riptide protested.
That's why I'm stuck patrolling all the
way out here.
If I bring a mud wing back to the palace
I might as well pull out my own teeth.
Ew, Sonny cried.
That's not a real punishment, is it?
Tsunami, didn't want to know the answer
to that.
She wanted to meet her mother without
images of horrible things in her head.
Think of it this way, she said quickly.
What happens if Queen Carl finds out you
met her missing daughter and didn't bring
her back to the palace?
Riptide squirmed and wrinkled his snout.
Can't I bring you and leave the others?
he asked.
At least until Queen Carl gives her
permission?
No, she said stoutly.
We all go together.
She'll understand once she realizes we're
the dragonettes of destiny.
Riptide side.
All right, but he has to be blindfolded.
He looked at the other three, rubbing his
chin.
It'd be better if they could all be
blindfolded.
What am I going to do?
Glory asked.
Round up some scary rain wings to come
sleep on your roof?
And I thought no one was afraid of my
tribe.
We're not, Riptide objected.
Afraid of rain wings?
Psst.
What a thing to say.
More streaks of pale green appeared along
Glory's scales and then faded away.
Wonderful.
She said.
So, no blindfold for me then.
She tossed her head and turned back to
the ocean.
Riptide looked doubtfully at Starflight
and Sunny.
The night wings know everything.
Starflight said loftily.
It's no use trying to keep secrets from
them.
I mean, us.
I could just use my powers to figure out
where your palace is.
Tsunami rolled her eyes.
Starfly had no powers whatsoever.
As far as any of the dragonettes knew.
But if he wanted the sea wings to think
he did, maybe that could be useful
eventually.
Please don't argue with him, Tsunami said
to Riptide.
Once he starts yammering on about how
amazing night wings are, we'll never get
him to shut up.
Starflight ruffled his wings in outrage.
Riptide muttered something under his
breath and started poking around in the
shallow water below the rocks.
You can blindfold me, Sonny offered.
I don't mind.
If you do that, she can ride on my back
tsunami suggested.
She missed having a little sand wing come
lean against her trustingly.
Sonny was still acting jumpy and nervous
around her.
Four whole days after her fight with a
Skywing soldier, as if tsunami might
suddenly attack someone out of nowhere
for no reason.
Or my back, Starflight jumped in
quickly.
Tsunami frowned at him.
Why was he trying so hard to take her
place?
You think you're strong enough?
She challenged.
Sure he is, Sonny said.
I'll ride with him and you can leave
Clay.
Well, fine then, tsunami thought.
I guess everyone's giving the orders
now.
Riptide came stomping back with several
long strands of thick black seaweed.
Sonny immediately looked like she was
regretting her offer, but she let the big
sea wing wrap the seaweed tightly around
her head, covering her closed eyes.
Ew.
She said, shivering.
It's all wet and slimy.
I like wet and slimy, Clay said. ducking
his head to make it easier for riptide to
blindfold him.
That's weird, Clay, said Glory.
Riptide's attention was focused on
plastering seaweed all over clay's broad
head.
When he was done, it looked more like an
octopus trying to eat clay's brain than a
blindfold.
But of course, Clay didn't complain.
He never complained about anything except
being hungry.
It was one of the things tsunami loved
about him.
Tsunami helped Sonny climb awkwardly onto
Starflight's back, balancing in the
narrow space between his wings.
The sand wing was small, but Starflight
wasn't as burly as tsunami or clay.
If you can't handle it, tell me, and I'll
take her, tsunami said to him.
Starflight nodded, breathing deeply.
His wings curled in, and he shivered as
Sunny lay down, rested her head on his
neck, and clasped her forearms trustingly
around his shoulders.
Tsunami turned to clay and brushed one of
his wing tips with hers.
Can you feel that?
She asked.
If I do that in the air?
you stay with me?
I think so.
Clay said doubtfully.
I'll fly on your other side.
Glory said, hopping down from her rock.
She reached up and nudged his other
wing.
That way, we can steer you together.
Clay shook his head a little, and a loose
flap of seaweed went glop flop against
his neck.
This is really strange, he said.
It's as dark as the underground river.
Only with breathing, so better.
I'm in favor of breathing.
Definitely better than not breathing.
Just don't go too fast and listen to me
tsunami ordered.
To us, glory chimed in, and we promise
not to drown you.
She gave tsunami an arch look.
If I do decide to drown somebody, I know
who's at the top of my list, tsunami
thought, shooting a glare back at her.
All right, let's go, she said to
Riptide.
The sky blue sea wing waved his talent in
front of Clay's face to make sure there
was no reaction.
Finally, he sprang into the sky with the
dragonettes close behind him.
Tsunami forgot to be mad at Glorian
Starflight as they flew over the bay.
Green and white islands glowed like
scattered jewels in the ocean below
them.
Several of them were shaped like claws
curving neatly through the water.
From up by the clouds, she could see part
of the spiral pattern in the
archipelago.
And when they swooped down close to the
sea, she saw palescent pink dolphins
leaping in the clear water.
Glory told Clay about the dolphins, and
his head went up hopefully.
Can we eat them?
he asked.
No, Riptide called back over his
shoulder.
Queen Coral has forbidden it.
She thinks they might be distantly
related to us.
Tsunami glanced down at the sleek darting
shapes, related to dragons?
What a bizarre idea.
It didn't really fit with how she'd
imagined her mother.
Well, I can stop imagining soon, she
thought.
She had no idea how the sea wings had
managed to hide a palace on one of these
islands.
From the air, it seemed like you could
see everything.
The white sand below the azure waters
around the islands, every hole in the
twisting rock formations, every palm tree
and cormorant nest and scraggly bush on
every cliff.
There were a lot of small islands, but
surely the enemy had searched everyone by
now, after 18 years of war.
Here comes our welcoming committee.
Riptide said, just loud enough for
tsunami to hear.
She spotted a formation of blue and green
dragons flying toward them. 15 or more
with huge wings and bared teeth, she
could hear them hissing from a distance.
Uh-oh.
Riptide muttered.
Clay, stop and hover.
Tsunami instructed.
He paused in the air, with glory close
beside him.
What's happening?
Sonny asked, lifting her head from
Starflight's shoulder as they caught up.
Starflight, for once, didn't say
anything.
His jaw was set, and it looked like he
was using all his energy to stay aloft
with Sonny.
The advance guard.
Riptide said.
He swung in a slow circle around the
group and stopped in front again, facing
the incoming dragons.
They make sure no one even gets close to
the Summer Palace.
A few moments later, they were
surrounded.
The flapping wing beats filled their ears
and pushed the air currents around.
Riptide, growled the dragon in the lead.
His scales were green, so dull it was
almost gray, like stone where moss had
been scraped away.
He had tiny bone pale eyes that never
seemed to blink under a knobbly
protruding forehead, and his horns
twisted strangely toward each other.
Tsunami noticed that, unlike riptide, the
new dragon had no battle scars, which
either meant he stayed away from the
fighting, or he was a very skilled
fighter.
What are you dragging home now?
He snarled.
Riptide looked him straight in the eyes.
I found the missing princess.
That's not how I would have put it
Tsunami thought.
I was the one doing all the finding out
there.
A ripple of shock went through the other
sea wings.
Tsunami's scales felt like insects were
crawling under them as the guards all
stared at her.
She lifted her snout and tried to look
regal and imposing.
Oh, really?
said the leader.
You, riptide?
Of all dragons.
What an unusual coincidence.
His unsettling eyes scanned tsunami from
wingtips to claws, as if she were a dead
eel someone had left half eaten on the
beach.
Tsunami wanted to shred the skeptical
arrogant look right off his face.
And who are you?
Tsunami demanded.
Riptide winced.
This is Shark, he said.
Commander of Palace Defense and Brother
to the Queen.
Oh, really?
tsunami said, deliberately making her
tone even more insolent and challenging
than sharks.
She was not about to start her life with
the sea wings by kowtowing to every
soldier drag who came along, even if he
was her uncle.
Shark narrowed his eyes until they nearly
disappeared into his scales.
What makes you believe this snip of a
dragon comes from the stolen royal egg?
He asked riptide.
Why?
Do you lose a lot of eggs?
Tsunami jumped in.
Maybe whoever's in charge of defense
isn't doing such a good job then.
Oh, wait, that's you. isn't it?
Her story makes sense.
Riptide said desperately.
She knew about, about webs.
He raised her.
And look at the glow patterns under her
wings.
All of the sea wings craned their necks
to stare at tsunami's wings.
She snapped at a couple who got too close
then peered around to see what they were
seeing.
Under her wings, when she lit them up, the
luminescent stripes formed spirals around
the outer edges, starbursts, shaped like
webbed dragon footprints, branched away
from the lines in the middle.
Was that weird?
She glanced at the other sea wings.
Most of them had smaller starbursts and
no spirals.
Only shark's patterns matched her own.
Because we're both royal.
She lifted her head and met his gaze
triumphantly.
But one day, I shall be queen, and you
will always be nothing but a soldier.
Shark let out a long hissing breath.
Very well, he said.
Kill the other 4 and bring her.
Chapter 6.
Don't you touch them!
Tsunami yelled.
She whirled and smacked a sea wing out of
the sky as you reached for clay.
Starflight had already ducked below
Clay's massive wings.
Glory drew her neck back and bared her
fangs.
I am the queen's daughter, and I order
you to leave these dragonettes alone.
Tsunami shouted.
The guards looked from her to Shark
uncertainly.
His eyes were pale reflecting pools
hiding his thoughts.
He slowly raised one talon, and made a
strange circling motion with it, a sign
in the sea wing language tsunami guest.
Whatever it was, it worked.
To tsunami's relief, the guards backed
away.
But when she glanced at riptide, she
noticed that he still looked tense and
unhappy.
Maybe he's just afraid of shark, she
thought.
Very good, she said. trying to sound like
she was in command.
Now take us to my mother.
The queen is conducting business at the
Deep Palace, Shark said flatly.
We will take you to the Summer Palace
where you may wait for her.
He made another talent signal, and 2 of
the guards broke away from the group
winging off across the water, taking the
message to my mother, tsunami thought, her
wings expanding with joy.
They were so close to everything she'd
always imagined.
I'm going to meet my parents today.
Islands flashed by below them as they
flew on.
Now, with a tight guard of sea wings.
Some of the islands were small patches of
sand, barely big enough for one dragon to
land on, and others were towering jagged
rocks shooting out of the water.
Ahead, tsunami saw one that looked like a
huge dragon skeleton, with holes and gaps
all through the pale stone.
The stone skeleton's nose pointed toward
another island.
This one ringed with forbidding looking
rocks, and presenting only a high, sheer
cliff face on all sides.
The top was a rioting jungle.
Thick green vines and trees pressed so
close together that there was not a
single spot clear enough to land on.
Tsunami was startled when sharks suddenly
swerved and dove toward the base of the
cliff.
He splashed down between 2 spiraling
rocks, sharp and evenly matched, like
dragon horns, and vanished into the azure
water.
She blinked.
Where had he gone?
The water was so clear here that she
could see fat black turtles strolling
across the sand at the bottom of the
sea.
But then, one by one, half the guards
around them dove for the same spot, and
each of them disappeared the same way.
Gone before the bubbles of their splash
had cleared.
Clay stop, she said, brushing his wing.
Riptide?
It's the entrance to the Summer Palace.
Riptide said.
There's no other way in.
You'll all have to swim.
Sunny let out a small and happy noise.
How far?
she asked riptide.
You only have to stay underwater for
short swims, he answered.
It has been redesigned, so Queen Blister
in particular can visit.
And she hates water.
Sonny said hopefully, since she's a
sandwing too.
Is she uh...
Is she here now?
Starflight asked.
Riptide shook his head.
She is not fond of swimming, and even
after all the changes we've made.
She rarely visits.
Tsunami was secretly a bit relieved to
hear that.
After meeting Bern.
She wasn't looking forward to
encountering the other 2 rival sandwing
sisters.
What if they were all equally dangerous
and crazy and controlling?
But eventually, the dragonettes would
have to choose one of the 3 to win the
war.
To be fair, Tsunami thought they probably
needed to meet both Blister and Blaze.
Then again, if tsunami's mother liked
blister, enough to alter her palace to
accommodate her.
Surely that was a sign in blister's favor
wasn't it?
Maybe they didn't have to meet Blaze.
Maybe supporting the sea wings and
blister would be the obvious right thing
to do.
Stay close behind me.
Riptide said.
I'll light up my stripes so you can
follow, and I'll flash them to signal you
to surface at the breathing spots.
Um, Clay said.
So about this blindfold.
Uh, any chance, once we're in the tunnel
riptide answered.
He turned and dove for the dragon horn
rocks.
Tsunami flipped her tail into Clay's
front talons and dove after riptide
towing clay behind her.
Her scales tingled with excitement.
Deep breath clay.
She called.
She was not far behind a riptide when he
dove into the water, but even so, she
nearly lost him in the fizz of bubbles
that swarmed up in her face as she
splashed down.
She blinked frantically, searching for a
hole or a tunnel entrance.
Long, sun colored tendrils of kelp grew
up from the sandy floor, glowing in
orange gold, and the light filtering down
from above.
They were clustered around the base of
the cliff, waving like a forest of
octopus arms, as tall as the 5
dragonettes laid end to end.
The hole in the cliff must be hidden by
the tendrils, but where?
Then tsunami saw riptide's glowing tail
knocking the golden kelp curtain aside
and she plunged after him.
It was hard to swim as fast as she wanted
to with clay clinging to her tail.
She could feel him trying to beat his
wings and kick helpfully, but he kept
accidentally whacking into underwater
boulders and slowing her down.
She poked her head into the forest, and
felt the tendrils of kelp slide and
slither around her snout.
Up close, she could see little clear
globules growing on them.
These were surprisingly sticky, while the
rest of the tendril was slippery smooth.
It felt like gigantic golden inch worms
were swarming around her.
She had to swim through a thick patch
following the glimmer of riptide's lit up
tail before reaching the cliff wall.
Suddenly, the tendrils slithered away and
popped her out into a dark underwater
tunnel.
Not entirely dark.
Riptide was directly in front of her.
His luminescent stripes all glowing.
He reached around her, guided clay into
the tunnel, and unwrapped the seaweed
blindfold.
Clay blinked and rubbed his talons
against his eyes, then immediately turned
back toward the faint sunlight, searching
for the others.
Glory came through next.
Her snout wrinkling as she pushed
tendrils off her wings.
Tsunami noticed that her scales had
ripples of the orange gold color
crisscrossing the silver that had been
there before.
She wondered if Glory had done that
deliberately, or if her scales
automatically tried to match their
environment when she was stressed.
After a long pause, Starflight burst
through after her.
His face was puffed up like he was about
to explode, and on his back, Sonny was
shivering violently.
Riptide flashed the lights in his tail
and shot upward, aiming for a hole in the
tunnel roof not far inside the entrance.
Tsunami was expecting more of a swim, and
was surprised when her head almost
immediately popped out into air.
It wasn't much air, a tiny cavern, barely
lit by a faraway gleam of sunlight up a
long, narrow chimney.
The dragon's bodies were still in the
watery tunnel below.
There was only enough room in the cavern
for their heads, all gathered closely in
the pool.
Tsunami could see right away that there
was nowhere to climb out.
This was a place to stop and breathe
nothing more.
Sunny and Starflight both gasped for air
like they hadn't breathed in months, Clay
fumbled in the dark to Pat Sunny's head
and pulled her blindfold off as well.
Good thing this breathing hole is here
Clay remarked to Riptide.
So close to the entrance, I mean.
Riptide inclined his head in a sort of
nod.
Queen Blister insisted on it.
Tsunami felt the whoosh of several sea
wing guards swimming past below them.
She knew there would be a few of them
bringing up the rear, making sure none of
the dragonettes ran off to spread the
news of the summer palace's secret
location.
She couldn't keep her wings still.
They thrummed like trapped dragonflies
wanting to spring loose.
She was so close.
This was her palace.
Her dragons were only a few wing beats
away.
After 6 years of imagining what this
would be like, she didn't think she could
stand another minute of waiting.
Let's go, let's go. she said, splashing
the others enthusiastically with her
tail.
Good grief, Glory said with a shake.
It's like you've been possessed by Sonny
or something.
Come on.
We're almost there.
Tsunami flashed her stripes happily, and
the other dragonettes covered their
eyes.
I can swim from here, Sonny said to
Starflight, or I'll hold onto clay if you
all go too fast.
Starflight looked disappointed and
relieved at the same time.
Riptide sank below the surface, and
tsunami ducked after him. too excited to
wait for the others.
Now it was easy to follow riptide's
glowing scales.
The tunnel twisted up and down and around
corners with frequent stops like the 1st
for breathing.
Too frequent if you asked tsunami.
Each one made her want to bang her head
into the cliff walls.
She lost count after the 4th stop, but
there had to be at least 10.
How long was this tunnel?
Then suddenly, finally, there was light
ahead.
Real light, not glowing scales.
A moment later, they swam out of the
tunnel into an open lake, lifted their
heads above the water and breathed in
deeply.
Green tinted sunlight dazzled their eyes
at first.
But as her vision cleared, tsunami saw
dragons.
Over 100 blue and green dragons
surrounded them.
All of them, staring expectantly at
tsunami.
Her tribe, her dragons, her future
subjects.
They had reached the Summer Palace of the
Sea Wings, in the heart of the Kingdom of
the Sea.
Part 2 Into the deep.
Chapter 7.
Overwhelmed, tsunami spread her wings to
float on the water and gazed around.
They were inside the island, surrounded
by towering cliffs on all sides.
Far above them.
Sunlight filtered through a thick green
canopy.
The vines and treetops she'd seen from
the sky, woven so thickly.
It looked like a jungle from above.
Like an emerald umbrella over the island
the canopy protected the summer palace
from view, and gave the light a sea green
quality that made tsunami feel like she
was still underwater.
Waterfalls cascaded down from several
holes in the cliffs like slender dragon
tails of silver, bursting into spray as
they hit the lake.
The only exit tsunami could see was the
tunnel behind her.
Four pillars of blue tinted white stone
spiraled out of the water, winding toward
one another until they formed a towering
pavilion in the middle of the lake.
The pavilion had 12 circular levels, each
one smaller than the one below.
There were a few walls, most of them very
low, and the whole structure was latticed
with curving shapes and holes and little
wading pools.
It didn't look like it had been built.
It looked as if it had grown that way
although tsunami was pretty sure that was
impossible.
Dragons were clustered along the edges of
the pavilion, on ledges of the cliffs, and
all across the water.
She'd never seen so many faces like her
own, dark blues and pale greens, and
sharp seeing the dark eyes staring.
The only sound was the splashing of the
waterfalls, the soft hush of dragons
breathing, and the quiet lapping of waves
on the beaches around the lake.
After a moment, Starflight spotted the
nearest stretch of sand, and set off for
it in a frantic paddle that sounded
horribly loud in the silence.
Sunny and clay and glory followed him.
Tsunami stayed where she was, ignoring
the tiredness that was flooding her
scales.
She wanted to make a good impression on
the dragons of her kingdom.
Many of them were floating on the water
like she was, but many more were perched
in cave openings all along the cliff, or
on rocks that jutted out of the water
while others lined the shallow beaches.
Tsunami wondered what they'd all been
doing before she appeared to capture
their attention.
She spotted shark, hunched on one of the
spirals of the closest pillar.
She rather thought he should have given
some sort of welcome speech, but he only
stared at her with his pale, unblinking
little eyes.
In the story, the royal parents had swept
forward with a parade and a whole
orchestra to welcome back their missing
princess, but her parents weren't here
yet.
And now that she thought about it
dolphins playing harps would probably be
a bit silly looking.
Well, she was a future queen, and she
wasn't going to be intimidated by crowds
of staring dragons.
She shook her head and lifted her neck
out of the water.
Hello, fellow sea wings?
She called, and then paused as her voice
echoed off the rocks, much louder than
she'd expected.
I'm tsunami.
And, um, I'm very happy to be home at
last, and, and I look forward to meeting
each of you.
Three moons.
Was that the most awful speech in the
history of Pyria?
What were all these still silent faces
thinking?
Could the dragon see tsunami's natural
royalty?
Were they excited that she'd be their
queen one day?
She remembered her royal stripe patterns
and lifted her wings out of the water so
everyone could see them.
To be sure they were visible.
She lit them up.
And then, with a sinking feeling
remembered what she'd accidentally said
to Riptide.
She really, really hoped she hadn't just
told her entire kingdom, that they had
delicious fish breath or something.
A murmur ran around the gathered dragons
but she couldn't tell if it was good
murmuring or bad murmuring.
She turned to riptide, who was watching
Shark with a grim expression.
I think you should take me somewhere I
can wait for my mother.
Tsunami suggested in a low voice, or she
thought it was low, but the echoes still
skipped back to her across the water, and
now there was more murmuring.
Tsunami wished she had nightwing powers
so she could hear the dragon's thought.
Up there, said Riptide, nodding to the
top of the pavilion.
He glanced at Shark again.
You should bring your friends.
The other dragonettes were sprawled on
the white pebbles of the beach in front
of a tall cave opening lined with sand.
They had their wings spread out, and were
gasping in a rather undignified way.
All except for Glory, who was sitting
neatly by the cave, peering in.
Her silver scales were now modeled with
azure blue.
Any sea wings who weren't staring at
tsunami were staring at her.
Tsunami thwacked the water with her tail
to get their attention.
When Clay finally looked over, she
pointed to the pavilion.
He nodded, and she lifted into the air.
Her wings felt heavy out of the water, and
it took a few beats to get her balance.
She wished the sea wings would go back to
whatever they were supposed to be doing.
Riptide flew up beside her.
He looked uncomfortable with all the
scrutiny as well.
Tell me about the Summer Palace, Tsunami
said, trying to distract herself.
He flicked his tail at the cliffs.
Guest rooms are in the caves.
Queen Blister usually stays in the one
closest to the tunnel.
We brought in extra sand to line the
floor for her, and it's the only cave
where fire is allowed.
His snout turned toward the pavilion as
they flew higher.
She meets with Queen Coral on the 2nd
level from the top, which is only for
visiting royalty.
Each level has a different purpose.
For instance, there's a floor for dragon
at school visits, one for celebration
spectacles, and one for war planning.
When they are here instead of the deep
palace, the council meets on this level
halfway up.
He paused, beating his wings, so tsunami
could look across the middle level. 12
dragon sized pools were arranged in a
circle, with small channels running from
one to the next and crisscrossing the
center, glittering emeralds the size of
fish eggs, which were embedded in the
stone, spelled out words by each pool.
Tsunami saw one marked Treasury, one
labeled Defense, and another that said
Secrets and Spies.
Before she could read any further, Riptide
turned to fly higher.
Counsel, tsunami said, catching up to
him.
They prefer the Deep Palace, as does the
Queen, Riptide said.
Only Shark and Lagoon are here at the
moment.
Tsunami had no idea what he was talking
about, but she didn't want to reveal how
ignorant she was of sea wing politics.
She wondered if there was anything about
a council in Starflight's favorite
scrolls.
So, which level is for missing
princesses?
She joked.
I think the top pavilion would be best.
Riptide said.
That's for new visitors, and we hardly
ever have any of those.
Queen Blister was probably the last.
Oh no, it was that night wing.
He landed gracefully on the uppermost
ledge of the pavilion, his claws catching
on polished ridges in the bluish white
stone.
What night wing?
Tsunami asked, landing beside him.
This level was bigger than she'd
expected.
A spiraling starburst of webbed talon
print shapes was carved into the floor
and filled with glittering water, lined
all along the bottom with tiny pearls.
Tsunami realized the pattern was the same
as the one on her wings.
I don't know.
Riptide answered her.
He only spoke with her majesty and queen
blister, and all I heard was that he
wanted to fly out through the canopy
instead of the tunnel, but of course they
wouldn't let him do that.
He looked big and bad tempered.
Sounds like Maro Seer, tsunami muttered
although she didn't exactly have a lot of
other night wings to compare him to, but
he seemed more meddlesome than the rest
of them.
While most of the tribe hid in their
secret location, being all mysterious and
unhelpfully powerful, Maro Seer kept
turning up, delivering the dragonette
prophecy, inspecting the dragonettes
trying to get glory killed, saving
Starflight, but no one else, from the sky
wings, then giving him back once everyone
had escaped.
Tsunami could easily imagine him poking
around here.
Although she couldn't guess why.
Riptie glanced down at the dragons below
including shark, who hadn't moved from
his spot on the pillar.
I can't believe you spoke to shark like
that, he whispered.
I've never seen anyone talk back to him
apart from the queen and queen blister.
He deserved it, tsunami said, settling
her wings.
Arrogant blowfish head.
When I'm queen, I'll make him go sit in a
lagoon and grow seaweed.
Riptide coughed hard to cover a laugh.
Don't talk like that, he whispered.
Don't you know the difference between
brave and reckless?
Shark will eat you and your friends for
lunch if he thinks you're a threat to
him.
Tsunami said.
He can try.
She shoved away the creepy memory of
sharks, unblinking, malicious eyes.
By the moons, you make me nervous, Riptide
said.
One end of the top floor was raised and
carved into a magnificent dragon throne
studded with emeralds and sapphires, and
shot through with gold lines in the shape
of waves.
Beside and below the throne was another
smaller throne carved to match with the
same patterns made of tinier gemstones.
Tsunami tilted her head at the 2nd
throne.
It looked too small to be for a king.
So was this for her?
Had Queen Coral prepared a throne for her
missing daughter, waiting all these years
for her to come fill it?
She took a step toward it, her heart
pounding with excitement.
A throne of her own, already.
The arrival of her friend stopped her as
the 4 dragonettes crashed down around the
ledge.
Sunny landed lightly, avoiding the
channels of water, but clay somehow
stumbled as his claws hit the stone, and
nearly somersaulted right off the other
side.
Glory darted in his way and pushed him
back, then made another loop around and
landed close to the throne.
Her green eyes studied it closely.
She looked almost ready to climb onto it
herself.
Starflight arrived last, catching on to
the side and pitching forward, as if his
wings had barely been strong enough to
carry him.
He lay there like a woeful black puddle
for a moment, taking deep breaths.
Sonny hopped over a watery footprint to
nudge his wing gently.
Tsunami managed not to roll her eyes, but
really, couldn't everyone at least try to
act a little more impressive?
This is a really big thing.
Clay said to her in riptide.
His tail accidentally splashed glory, but
she was too busy looking at the throne to
snap at him.
I mean, this thing we're standing on?
What do you call it?
It's really tall.
Taller than our prisons in the Sky
Kingdom, I think.
He peered over the edge, missing
riptide's sharp look.
Tsunami realized they hadn't told him
about being captured by Queen Scarlet and
the Sky Wings.
I like it, Clay went on, sitting down and
splashing glory again.
Of course, it's much nicer to be this
high when your wings are free.
But at least the Skywings gave us a pig
sometimes.
Do you have pigs?
Octopi would be all right instead, if you
don't, or squid, or manatees.
I could go for a manatee right now.
Or a whale, I'm not fussy is what I'm
saying.
Say, how did you make this big thing?
Did it take forever to build?
Riptie blinked for a moment, following
Clay's train of thought?
The pavilion?
An animus seawing designed it many
generations ago, and magicked the stone
to grow this way, Riptide said.
Even so, it took nearly 10 years to reach
this form.
Wow, said Clay, and tsunami couldn't help
being impressed too.
She hadn't realized animus dragons had
that kind of power.
In their lessons, Webbs had told them
animus dragons could enchant chess pieces
to play themselves.
Sometimes they left curses on their
jewels to poison anyone who tried to
steal them.
But making a whole pavilion grow from
stone?
That seemed like strong magic, more
powerful than anything the night wings
could do.
Starflight was clearly thinking the same
thing, judging from his disgruntled
snout.
Tsunami hurriedly interrupted before he
could begin a lecture.
This top level is where Queen Coral meets
new visitors, like us.
She said importantly to her friends.
So when she arrives, everyone, please act
like dragonettes of destiny instead of
half drowned seagulls for goodness sake.
Sonny looked wounded and Starflight
sniffed loudly.
While Glory turned up her snout like she
wasn't taking any orders from tsunami.
Clay poked his nose over the edge and
blinked at the lower pavilion tears.
Which level is the feasting on?
He asked.
You do have feasting, right?
His wide brown eyes turned to ribtide.
No reason.
Just wondering.
Sure.
Sometimes we have feasts, Riptide said
especially when Queen Blister is, a
commotion from below interrupted him.
Tsunami sprang to the edge and gazed down
the lake.
A huge blue sea wing, exactly the color
of tsunami's scales burst out of the
tunnel.
Vines of pearls were woven around her
horns and neck and wings, and a twisted
white horn with a wicked looking point
was attached to the end of her tail.
She had odd black stains on her claws, but
she was the most beautiful sight tsunami
had ever seen.
All over the palace.
Dragons were folding down into low
boughs.
This had to be her mother, queen of the
sea wings.
Tsunami reached to grab Riptide's forearm
feeling dizzy with joy.
But as Queen Coral shot out of the water
tsunami saw that she wore a thin webbed
harness with a long cord, which led to a
harness on another dragon flying close
behind her.
The 2nd dragon was much smaller, a
dragonette, only about a year old
perhaps.
She flapped her wings frantically, trying
to keep up.
With a jolt of shock, tsunami spotted the
royal pattern of stripes on the underside
of her wings.
Who is that?
She hissed at Riptide.
He was backing away into the edge of the
floor, the farthest spot from the
throne.
That's anemone. he said, blinking in
surprise.
Your sister.
Chapter 8.
An enemy, anemone.
An enemy.
It took tsunami a few moments to realize
what riptide had actually said.
Her skin prickled, hearing an enemy, an
enemy, until it sank in that he'd been
saying a name.
Anemone, tsunami's sister, another heir
to the throne.
So much for being special.
So much for her guaranteed future
kingdom.
Uh-oh, Glory said, echoing her thoughts
looks like you've got some competition.
Maybe you're not destined to be queen
after all.
Tsunami whirled towards Starflight, her
gills flaring.
You said I was the only one, she cried.
You said none of the others survived.
That's what I read, he protested.
He spread his black claws.
Blame the talons, not me.
Our scrolls were often old and outdated.
The royal lineage of the sea wings from
the scorching to the present must have
been written before this one was
hatched.
He nodded at the little dragon flapping
behind the queen.
Anemone was a pale, pale blue, almost
white, like an ice wing, with hints of
pink along her wings and ears and horns.
She looked a little bit like the dolphins
they'd seen earlier, and tsunami wondered
grumpily if that was really why Queen
Coral had forbidden sea wings to eat them
in case one of them ate anemone by
mistake.
Anemone's eyes were large and blue, and
tiny strands of pearls were woven around
her neck and tail, as if to match her
mother's.
That could have been me.
Tsunami thought.
I could have been the one with matching
pearls and a matching throne, and a
mother who loved me.
If the talons hadn't stolen me from my
home.
She didn't have a chance to notice
anything else, because suddenly, Queen
Coral was landing and running toward
her.
My baby?
Kroll cried.
Enormous blue wings whooshed around
tsunami, enveloping her in a hug that
smelled of sea air and starfish.
Pearls pressed into tsunami's face as
Coral cuddled her close.
Her wet scales were warm, and her talons
were gentle as she stroked tsunami's head
and back and wings.
I knew you'd come back to me, she said.
I knew you were out there, trying to find
your way back.
I never stopped searching for you.
It was exactly. what tsunami had always
wanted to hear.
Actually, it was word for word what the
queen said in The Missing Princess, but
tsunami shoved that thought aside.
She leaned into her mother, feeling
elation flood her from horns to claws.
Someone does want me.
I have a place in the world.
Mother, whined a tiny voice from behind
them.
Ow, that was too fast.
I think I hurt my claws.
Queen Coral let go of tsunami, whirled
around and tugged anemone closer with the
harness cord, the little dragonette crept
under her wing, and held out her front
talons with a pitiful expression.
I'm sorry, sweetheart.
Carl said, carefully examining anemones
claws, and then giving them a quick lick
with her forked tongue.
Is that better?
I guess, Anemone said, flexing her talons
mournfully.
Look, darling, it's your sister, the one
I told you about, who was stolen 6 years
ago.
Coral reached out and slid one webbed
talent over tsunami's snout.
Isn't she gorgeous?
Anemone blinked at tsunami.
She was really tiny, no taller than a
scavenger, and she didn't look very
strong.
Maybe I don't have to worry about her.
Tsunami thought, she'd be easy to
defeat.
And obviously, I'd make a better queen.
Then she felt a stab of guilt for
thinking about something like that on her
1st meeting with her real family.
She held out one of her front talons to
anemone.
And after a small pause, Anemone pressed
her own talent against it.
Hi, tsunami said.
I'm tsunami.
Ah, Queen Coral said, a good name.
Webbs did one thing right.
Her green eyes narrowed.
Where is he now?
I have been planning his punishment for
years.
She glared over tsunami's shoulder, but
when tsunami looked around, the only
dragon there was riptide.
He had his head ducked in his wings
folded as low as he could get.
I knew he was a coward and a deserter
Coral said, but after he returned to
steal my egg, Well, let's just say, it
won't be a quick death.
Oh no, Sonny squeaked.
Please don't hurt him.
He was the only one who was really nice
to us.
We don't know where he is anyway, tsunami
said, as Queen Carl turned to stare at
Sonny.
He escaped when...
What are you?
Coral asked Sonny.
Her gaze fell on the other dragonettes
and her tail lashed dangerously.
Why is there a mud wing in my summer
palace?
She took a step toward clay.
Gills flaring.
These are my friends.
Tsunami cried, leaping in front of Clay.
You can trust them, I promise.
We were all stolen from our homes as
eggs.
We're the dragonettes of destiny, from
the prophecy.
Ha. muttered a voice.
And tsunami realized that Shark was now
perched on the rim of the ledge along
with 9 other very large dragons.
Oh.
Queen Coral said slowly.
Oh, I see.
She studied clay suspiciously, then
turned her gaze to Starflight, Sunny, and
glory.
Yes, that was the rumor.
If you believe in things like prophecies
of course.
Dragonettes of destiny.
Well, Queen Blister will be so interested
to meet you, we'd better make sure you
don't go anywhere.
She flashed the royal patterns along her
wings and clapped her front talons
together.
Seven burly sea wings rose up behind the
dragonettes, claws twitching ominously.
Put these 4 in Blisters Cave.
Queen Coral commanded. and set a guard so
they stay there.
What?
Sonny cried.
But we came here to be safe?
Not to be prisoners again.
She squeaked in terror as one guard
snatched her into the air.
Starflight stared after her, frozen in
place with his claws half outstretched.
Nobody touches me.
Glory snarled at the sea wing who was
reaching for her.
Black clouds billowed up in her scales.
Don't hurt son.
How?
Clay yelped, as 3 sea wings landed on him
at once, pinning him down.
Ouch, ow.
One began lashing woven seaweed ropes
around his wings and claws and snout.
Wait, tsunami said.
She clasped her talons pleadingly.
Your majesty.
Mother.
The word felt so odd on her tongue, even
though she'd imagined saying it a 1000000
times.
You don't have to do this.
They're my friends, and I brought them
here so you could protect us.
I swear, they're trustworthy.
It's for their own safety too, dear.
Coral said, stroking tsunami's head
again.
We won't hurt them, of course.
You've come to the right place for
protection.
But they shouldn't wander the palace
unsupervised.
Most of my dragons will attack mud wings
and unfamiliar sand wings on site.
Or whatever that is.
Shark muttered, sniffing at Sonny.
Starflight shot him a glare, then looked
away quickly as the Seawing turned his
gaze to him.
I guess this means no feast, Clay said
mournfully.
He rested his snout on the stone with a
sigh.
Food can certainly be arranged, said the
Queen.
Lagoon, make sure our guests are well
fed.
A plump turquoise dragon bowed and dove
off the ledge.
See, darling?
We'll take good care of you all.
Please tell that one to stop looking so
fierce.
Carl flicked a claw at glory, who was
still facing all with a nervous looking
sea wing guard.
Tsunami thought, uncomfortably, of
Glory's secret weapon.
In the Sky Wing Palace, they'd discovered
Glory could spit a deadly venom, which
seemed to be a rain wing skill most
dragons didn't know about.
It certainly hadn't been in any of the
scrolls, which rarely mentioned rain
wings at all.
But tsunami hoped glory would decide to
keep her venom a secret for now.
Melting one of the queen's guards
probably wasn't the best way to introduce
the dragonettes of destiny to the sea
wings.
You don't have to tie them up, tsunami
said.
They'll go with you.
Speak for yourself, Glory growled.
Calm down, Glory, tsunami said.
She hoped her mother and the other
dragons would see her as the leader of
the dragonettes.
You heard the queen.
It's for your own safety.
You'll be fine.
Please don't argue with me in front of my
mother.
Tsunami prayed.
Glory glared at the sea wing guard for a
moment longer.
All right, she snarled.
I'll go with you.
But I still say, nobody touches me.
Fair enough.
Queen Carl purred with another gesture
and flash of her stripes.
Off you all go, then.
Tsunami, darling, come sit with me and
let's talk.
She swept over to her throne, towing
anemone behind her.
The tiny dragonette settled onto the
small throne, flicking her pearly wings
and watching tsunami's friends with big
eyes.
It'll be all right, Tsunami said to Clay
as the guards hefted him into the air.
I'll come join you very soon.
He nodded, still looking rather anxious.
Another guard tentatively tried to shoe
Starflight off the edge.
The night wing backed away from him
unhappily, then turned and flew after the
guard who had Sonny.
Tsunami watched her friend spiral down to
the cave by the entrance.
Brown and gold, black and silver, all of
them so out of place here.
She saw them vanish into the dark hole
and then the guards emerged and planted
themselves outside.
It didn't look like the way you'd treat
guests.
At least it's better than the Sky Wing
Palace, she thought.
At least we're not being forced to fight
to the death.
My mother is keeping us safe.
She's really being welcoming in her own
way.
She glanced up at her mother's warm eyes
especially to me.
Her mother reached out her talons to her
smiling.
She was perfect.
Just what tsunami had always imagined.
Her friends would be all right, tsunami
was sure.
They were in the Seawing Palace now.
She was home with her family.
This was her lifelong dream.
There's nothing to worry about, she told
herself.
Nothing at all.
Chapter 9.
Here, Queen Coral said, taking a strand
of pearls off her own horns.
You are so unadorned, my beautiful
dragonette.
I have to start making up for all the
presents I missed giving you.
She leaned forward and draped the pearls
around Tsunami's neck.
They were heavy and smooth, sliding
coolly across tsunami's scales.
My 1st treasure.
It was a strange thrill, having something
of her very own.
All dragons loved treasure.
It was the only thing they had in common
with scavengers.
But this was more than a shiny, beautiful
thing.
It belonged to tsunami, and nobody else
and it made her look even more like her
mother.
Tsunami stroked the pearls with her claw
and tucked her tail around her back
talons.
She wished anemone would stop staring at
her.
She must hate me, she thought.
I would if I were her.
She must know I want the throne she
thought was hers.
But not yet.
Now was the time for getting to know her
mother.
Can we talk alone?
Tsunami asked.
The 10 dragons were still perched like
creepy sentinels with Shark, the
creepiest of all.
Of course, said the queen.
Counsel you are dismissed.
Moray, send a message to Queen Blister
and see how quickly she can get here.
As for you, creature, go back to your
guard outpost and stay there until
someone actually wants to see you.
Riptide crouched, nodding, and dove over
the edge.
Tsunami leaned out to watch him swimming
into the tunnel.
What's wrong with riptide?
she asked, as the other 10 dragons also
flew away in a thunderclap of wing
beats.
I thought he was nice.
Oh no.
Queen Coral said with a shudder.
He can't be trusted.
Webbs is his father.
Their bloodline is tainted with
betrayal.
Tsunami felt like a giant wave had just
knocked her over.
Webbs is his father?
But she'd liked riptide, and all along, he
was the son of her kidnapper, which he
had carefully never mentioned.
What else hadn't he told her?
Nasty family, Coral went on.
She lashed her tail, nearly hitting
anemone in the head.
Not fitting company for royalty by any
means.
We keep him as far away from us as
possible.
Poor Riptide.
Tsunami thought.
It wasn't his fault his father had turned
traitor, but he suffered for it anyway.
And yet, he had hidden the truth from her
and she didn't like that at all.
Was Queen Coral right about him?
Surely she knew her own subjects better
than tsunami did.
But there was still a part of tsunami
that hoped she'd see him again.
She glanced at anemone.
So we were saying, Alone?
Oh, no, anemone never leaves my side.
Queen Coral said.
She reached over and lovingly patted the
little dragonette's head.
I finally got a living daughter, and I'm
keeping her that way.
By watching me every second, Anemone said
she widened her eyes at tsunami, who
wondered if she'd imagined a hint of
sarcasm in her sister's words.
And now I have 2 daughters, Queen Coral
said proudly, possibly 4 by the end of
next week, if Tortoise does her job
right.
She gave tsunami a worried look.
Maybe we should make a harness for you
too, dear.
Oh, no, that's all right, tsunami said
eyeing the straps that lashed coral and
anemone together.
I've managed to take care of myself up to
now.
I promise I'll stay alive.
Much as she already loved her mother, She
cannot imagine being attached to anyone
every moment of every day.
Hmm, said the queen.
Well, we'll think about it.
She studied tsunami's shoulders, as if
she was mentally measuring her for a
harness anyway.
I have to tell you something, tsunami
said, hoping to change the subject.
I...
I don't know the underwater language.
Webbs never taught it to me.
Queen Coral stared at her.
What is wrong with that dragon, she
growled.
It's all right sweetheart.
We'll have Whirlpool teach you.
He's a terrific teacher.
Right, anemone?
Anemone shrugged.
So, what do, you know, Queen Coral asked
did they teach you anything?
Of course.
Tsunami said.
She didn't want her mother to think she
was unfit to be queen.
We had lots of battle training, and Webbs
taught us the history of Pyria.
We learned all about the scorching, and
how the tribes were founded, and how we
nearly wiped out the scavengers.
Um, and he did geography too.
Dune taught us hunting.
Kestrel was supposed to teach different
tribes strengths and weaknesses, but
mostly she just yelled and try to set us
on fire a lot.
Anemone's eyes were bright with
interest.
Why don't I get to learn those things
mother?
she asked.
You will, dear, said Queen Coral.
When I think you're ready.
What do you study?
Tsunami asked.
Anemone glanced up at her mother.
How the council works, she said.
Aquatic, of course, how to interpret
battle reports and order our defenses
managing the food supply and the treasury
although the council commanders really do
all that.
It's still important to stay on top of
them. purred the queen.
Dragons do their best work if you watch
them closely the whole time.
But mostly I'm stuck in training sessions
with Whirlpool, Anemone said.
Her wings drooped.
For what?
Tsunami asked.
Aquatic?
Never mind, dear.
Queen Coral interrupted.
You'll see eventually.
Were the talents of peace very cruel to
you?
Terribly?
Tsunami said.
This was one of her favorite topics.
They never let us out of the caves at
all.
They acted like we were brainless
snails.
Nobody ever listened to me, and they
wouldn't tell us anything about our
families or where we came from.
I only found out about you a few days
ago.
My poor, poor baby.
Queen Coral said, stroking tsunami's head
again.
Exactly, tsunami thought.
This was the sympathy she'd always wanted
although she didn't appreciate the
skeptical look on Anemone's face.
What are these?
Tsunami asked.
She leaned forward and touched the dark
stains on the queen's talons with one
claw.
They looked too dark to be bloodstains
but she couldn't guess what else they
were.
The perils of my job, Queen Carl said
with a laugh.
Well, my hobby.
My art, you might call it.
I should show you.
She sprang to her feet, tugging anemone
up with her.
And then you can meet Whirlpool.
You'll adore him.
He's just the most wonderful, brilliant
young dragon.
Tsunami was nearly certain she caught
anemone rolling her eyes.
She followed the 2 of them down 4 levels
to a floor with low walls and several
shapes like large cauldrons molded into
the stone.
Black and blue webbed talon prints
trailed all around the floor, and a
raised podium stood at one end, with
space for an audience of 30 dragons in
front.
At the other end was a long gray stone
table with a scroll spread out on it, held
down at either end by a small seahorse
carved of dark brown wood.
Tsunami peered at the scroll, which
looked only half written.
That's my work in progress.
Queen Coral said proudly, Whirlpool, come
here.
She bustled over to one of the cauldrons
and tsunami realized they were all packed
with neatly rolled scrolls.
This is beautiful, she said, lifting one
of the carved seahorses.
They were heavy, and intricately detailed
with curiously dragon like expressions on
their tiny faces.
Orca made those, Queen Coral said sadly.
My 1st daughter, she was a very talented
sculptor.
First daughter.
What happened to her?
Tsunami hadn't thought any of them lived
long enough to become artists.
She gave anemone a quizzical expression
but her sister was watching the queen
intently.
I'll ask Starflight later.
Orca must be in that lineage scroll he
was going on about.
A dark green dragon with pale green eyes
rose up from the council level.
He had a remarkably large gold hoop
piercing one ear, and dappled light green
scales in wave patterns along his back.
He also had the same dark stains on his
talons.
Your majesty.
He said with an elaborate bow.
And your smaller majesties.
His voice was oily and slow, like squids
creeping into tsunami's ears.
She guessed this was whirlpool, although
he didn't look particularly wonderful or
brilliant.
He bowed to anemone and tsunami as he
settled onto the floor behind the stone
table.
His eyes almost immediately went from
them to the scroll in front of him, and
he tilted his head thoughtfully.
After a moment, he reached forward and
dipped one claw into a small pool of
black ink in the top corner of the
table.
With the ink, he scratched a few more
words at the point where the scroll went
blank.
Oh, tsunami said, glancing from his
talons to her mother's.
Oh, it's ink.
Yes, dear, said Queen Coral.
She pulled an armful of scrolls out of
the cauldron.
It's a special formula made of squid ink
and a touch of whale blood, so it never
fades.
Immortality is worth a few claw stains
don't you agree?
Whirlpool invented it.
He's terribly clever.
She peered at the words he'd written.
Exactly what I was thinking.
This is an exciting one, isn't it?
Certain to win all the awards in the
kingdom, your majesty.
Whirlpool oozed.
Queen Coral piled 4 scrolls into
tsunami's talons.
These are my favorites.
You can read them all tonight, and
tomorrow I'll give you 4 of my other
favorites.
Read all these tonight?
Tsunami echoed, dismayed.
Reading was Starflight's specialty.
She liked it fine, but only if there were
exciting stories and female warrior
dragons.
She didn't read very fast, and really
she'd rather be fighting something.
Start with this one.
Queen Coral said, plucking one of the
scrolls free.
It was the missing princess.
Relief flooded through tsunami.
I've read that one, she cried.
That was my favorite story ever.
Really?
Queen Coral looked delighted, and tsunami
was pretty sure Anemone had rolled her
eyes again.
I wrote it for you.
You...
Tsunami looked from Queen Coral to
Whirlpool and the scroll on the table.
You wrote The Missing Princess?
I wrote all of these.
Queen Coral waved your talent at the
scrolls in the cauldrons.
I'm really quite prolific.
Whirlpool makes sure 100s of copies are
instantly made and distributed all over
sea wing territory, and wherever else on
Pyria, we can send them.
My communications, Herald, Moray, is in
charge of the printer dragons who make
the underwater copies.
She also makes sure they go to all the
schools, but Whirlpool organizes my
readings here.
Isn't he brilliant?
She lowered her voice and winked at
tsunami.
And don't you think he's very handsome?
Whirlpool looked up and gave tsunami a
toothy smile that didn't reach his eyes.
His teeth were weirdly small, and his
eyes were too pale and blobby, like frog
eyes.
Tsunami couldn't help thinking of riptide
who was much more handsome if you asked
her.
Although she knew better than to tell
Coral that.
He'll make a fabulous king one day.
Queen Coral added in a loud whisper.
Oh, dear.
Tsunami hid her shudder.
Is Queen Carl throwing him at me?
She glanced at anemone, and saw the
little dragonette quickly erasing a
hopeful expression from her face.
Hmm.
She bet anemone could clear up a lot of
mysteries.
If tsunami could get her alone for a
moment.
Too bad that was impossible.
Your majesty?
They all turned and found another council
dragon hovering in the air behind the
queen, with a smaller dragon beside her.
I'm sorry to interrupt, but urchin just
arrived with strange news.
I knew you'd want to hear it right away.
Of course, Moray, said Queen Coral.
You always know what's best.
Moray's scales were the same dull gray
green as sharks, and her eyes were also
small and colorless.
Tsunami wondered if they were related.
The council dragon pressed her snout into
a brief, smug look.
That's because I have had excellent
training at the side of the most
wonderful queen in pyrene history, she
said.
Oh my word.
Tsunami thought.
This time she was able to catch anemone's
eye, behind the queen's back, to make an
is she serious?
Face.
Anemone looked startled for a moment. then
made a face back that tsunami was pretty
sure meant, believe me, it gets worse.
Moray went on.
Apparently, a dead dragon has been found
only a few islands from the summer
palace.
Oh, how sad. said Queen Coral with a
little yawn.
She glanced at her scrolls as if she
wanted to get back to them.
What happened to him?
Her, said Moray.
And we don't know yet, but the strange
part is that it's not a sea wing.
It's a sky wing.
What?
Queen Coral leaped to her talons.
That close to the palace?
She snapped at the air and spread her
wings.
Get shark and piranha, and take me to the
body, now.
The queen shot into the air, with anemone
flapping wildly to keep up.
Tsunami dropped the scrolls and jumped
after them, flying in a tight spiral down
to the water.
This was her chance to see the queen in
action.
She thought she heard someone shout her
name as she splashed down, Sonny or
Clay?
The water rushed into her ears, muffling
the cry.
They didn't have to worry.
She wouldn't be gone long.
They'd be safe here.
Shark whipped past, churning up the water
as he charged into the tunnel ahead of
her.
He was between her and Coral now, but
tsunami wasn't going to let that stop
her.
She swam after them as fast as she
could.
She felt another dragon close on her tail
but didn't turn around or slow down.
It felt like only moments later, when
tsunami's snout emerged into the golden
kelp curtain, she followed the eddies
left by the dragon tails ahead of her and
realized they weren't going to the
surface, so they weren't flying to the
body.
They were swimming there.
Which made sense.
They were sea wings after all.
All right, I can do this.
Tsunami ignored how tired her wings felt
and beat them harder, determined to keep
up.
Even so, the 2 dragons behind her quickly
passed her, Moray, and another from the
council, who she guessed was piranha.
She saw both dragons dipped down in the
water and suddenly speed up.
Despairing, she tried to do the same
thing, tipping her wings to dip down to
the same level.
A fierce current immediately caught her
up and shoved her along after them.
For a moment, tsunami struggled against
it.
She didn't like being caught by anything
stronger than her.
But then she realized the other dragons
were using it to travel faster, and she'd
have to do the same thing if she wanted
to stay with them.
Slowly, she relaxed, and let the current
sweep her along.
It gave her a chance to look around.
A school of black fish with silver
speckles shot by overhead, like a flock
of crows or night wings, spinning and
whirling and shifting formations.
Large translucent mushrooms sprouted from
the ocean floor, with tiny orange fish
clustered around them.
A pulsing, reddish pink octopus wobbled
by.
And tsunami wondered if they were
delicious.
They were definitely slow enough to
catch.
Out of the corner of her eye, she spotted
movement behind a swarm of iridescent
jellyfish.
She squinted, and realized it was riptide
following her from a distance.
She lifted one of her wings and waved to
him, and after a moment, he sheepishly
waved back.
She didn't know what he was supposed to
be doing, but this probably wasn't it.
Still, she kind of liked having him there
so she wasn't going to tell Coral on
him.
Not until she decided how mad she was
about the Webbs being his father secret
anyway.
They swam for what felt like miles over
wide stretches of algae covered coral
reef that looked like ancient stone ruins
palaces and temples that had collapsed
long ago.
Occasionally, a large greenish silver
fish would dart up, swim alongside
tsunami for a moment, notice her with a
start of alarm, and flash away again.
She was hungry, but too tired to try
eating any of them.
Even with the help of the current, tsunami
felt ready to collapse.
Finally, up ahead, she saw Moray and
Piranha sweep up to the surface, relieved
she struggled out of the current and
followed them into the air.
Queen Coral was already standing on a
large craggy boulder that jutted out of
the sea at the base of an enormous
cliff.
Anemone was crowded onto a tiny
outcropping beside her.
Not far away, a seal edged nervously into
the water, trying not to attract their
attention.
Waves pounded the rocks, roaring like
angry dragons, and spraying salt water
over everyone who has clustered around
the queen on smaller rocks.
Tsunami found a jagged black rock the
right size for her, and clambered up.
For a moment she just breathed, happy not
to be moving.
She had no idea how she'd make it back to
the Summer Palace.
Deal with that later.
Far off to the north, she saw a bank of
dark clouds huddled on the horizon
muttering and flashing.
She's been dead a day or two.
Shark said grimly, killed quite violently
by the looks of it.
Tsunami glanced down at the broken red
body snagged on the rocks.
Shark was leaning over the corpse
inspecting the deep slashes across the
throat.
He shook his head and stepped back.
A bolt of shock and terror shot through
tsunami.
She knew this sky wing.
It was Kestrel, the dragon who'd raised
them.
Kestrel was dead, and somebody had
clearly murdered her.
Chapter 10.
Tell.
Don't tell.
Mother needs to know who it is.
But what if she thinks we killed her?
Tsunami didn't know what to do.
It was too strange a coincidence.
Kestrel turning up dead, a few islands
away, at the same time as the dragonettes
arriving at the Summer Palace.
If tsunami admitted she knew her.
Wouldn't her mother's 1st thought be that
the dragonettes had killed her
themselves?
After the way her friends had been
looking at her lately?
Tsunami didn't want to risk getting a
similar reaction from her mother, the
What kind of dragon are you really?
And can you be trusted?
And who else might you attack, looks?
She worried about it all the way back to
the Summer Palace.
Mercifully, they flew back, giving
tsunamis swimming muscles a rest.
But in the bustle of orders and flying
messengers, there wasn't a moment to talk
to the queen on her own anyway.
Back at the palace, Queen Coral told
tsunami to wait for her and took a few
council dragons off for a war meeting.
Tsunami sat on one of the pavilion
pillars, watching dragons dart about.
Who would kill Kestrel?
Apart from glory or me, that is?
She glanced at the cave where her friends
were being held, where guards were still
posted outside.
She knew she should go check on the other
dragonettes, but what would they think
when they heard about Kestrel?
What if our friends decided it wasn't
safe here?
Starflight might convince the others, that
Kestrel's murderer could be nearby
waiting to kill them too.
He talked them into leaving the kingdom
of the sea, and tsunami wasn't ready for
that.
They were all too mad at her right now to
listen to sense, and they were probably
pretty grumpy about being stuck in a
guarded cave all afternoon too.
It'd be better to wait and tell them
everything after they had a chance to see
how wonderful it could be here.
Tomorrow, she'd ask her mother to bring
them out for a feast or something, and
that would cheer up at least a couple of
them.
Yes, that's a better plan.
Avoid them until tomorrow, then tell them
everything.
Besides, she was so, so tired.
Darkness had fallen as they flew back to
the Summer Palace, and now the cavern was
lit only by trails of glowing jellyfish
in the water below.
Not that it mattered to sea wings, who
could see in the dark, but her friends
probably wouldn't be too thrilled about
having no light either.
Another argument that could wait until
tomorrow.
She was relieved when the queen finally
came down from the council level and led
her across the lake.
Queen Coral's chambers at the Summer
Palace were in a vast underwater cave
below one of the waterfalls lined with
waving tendrils of forest green and
brilliant gold anemones.
Stone carvings of dolphins danced around
the entrance.
The walls were studded with emeralds and
pearls, and the beds were soft expanses
of bubbly seaweed.
A bed was already made up for tsunami
next to anemones.
She collapsed onto it with a sigh.
Sleeping underwater on comfortable
seaweed instead of a hard ledge of stone
was even more wonderful than she'd ever
imagined.
She fell asleep to the sound of the
waterfall splashing overhead, and didn't
wake up until the next morning.
When she opened her eyes.
She found the pale pinkish blue head of
anemone leaning over her.
Tsunami yelped and leaped back, crashing
into the stone wall and bouncing off it
in a stream of bubbles.
She had a wild, brief moment of thinking
anemone had been about to kill her, and
then her sister waved her talons and made
a shushing gesture.
Anemone pointed at Queen Coral, who was
still asleep.
She clasped her talons in front of her
and flashed some of the stripes along her
wings and tail.
Sorry, little sister.
Tsunami spread her front talons and shook
her head.
I wish I could.
Anemone flashed her stripes again, then
smacked her head, remembering that
tsunami didn't know aquatic.
She frowned in frustration.
Tsunami felt equally frustrated.
They couldn't sneak off to the surface to
talk.
Anemone was trapped here by the harness
tethering her to the queen, and tsunami
couldn't communicate underwater.
They'd never had a chance to talk
privately.
She swam over to her sister and studied
the harness.
It was made of a stretchy, gummy, clear
material that seemed to cling to anemones
scales, as if it had grown along with
her.
It probably has, tsunami thought
wondering if the poor dragonette would
have to wear this until she was tsunami's
age or even older.
When tsunami tugged on it lightly, Anemone
shook her head.
She mimed trying to wriggle out of the
harness and pointed to the queen again.
Not possible without waking her up
tsunami guessed.
If it's even possible at all.
Anemone carefully eased toward the
entrance, glancing back at the queen.
The chord between them uncoiled.
The little dragonette lifted off the
floor and swam up toward the top of the
door, stretching the leash to its full
length.
She beckoned tsunami after her.
Where the waterfall met the lake, just
behind the cascade, and right outside the
cave entrance, there was a small pocket
of air.
At the end of her leash, Anemone was
barely able to reach it with her snout.
Tsunami popped her head out beside her.
Clever, Tsunami said, glancing around.
Here they were also hidden from view.
If any sea wings were out and about this
early in the summer palace.
I hope she doesn't wake up, Anemone
said.
She blinked at tsunami for a moment, then
burst out, oh, I'm so glad you're here.
She reached out one of her front talons
and tsunami pressed it like they had the
day before.
Really?
Tsunami said, astonished.
But aren't we rivals?
If I'm here, doesn't that threaten your
chance at the throne?
Maybe you can make her less crazy.
Anemone said in a whisper.
Or maybe she'll set me free now that she
has you.
Maybe you could talk to her.
I need to get out of this harness.
Tsunami.
You have no idea how awful my life has
been.
Tsunami stared at her, hearing the echo
of her own words.
Your life has been awful?
she said.
You can't even imagine awful.
Try being raised under a mountain with no
ocean or proper sunlight and only a river
to swim in.
Try being raised by 3 dragons who hate
you and treat you like a blobby tadpole.
I am treated like a tadpole, Anemone
protested.
Mother doesn't trust me to do anything by
myself.
You're only what, one year old?
tsunami guest.
I'm sure that'll change.
Well, I'm mostly sure.
Halfway sure.
And at least she cares about you.
She cares about me way too much.
Anemone said.
I never get to do anything except
whatever she's doing.
At least you have friends.
I never even see any other dragonettes.
Well, I was sort of stuck with those four
tsunami said, and they're always arguing
with me or getting mad about something.
She felt a pang of guilt about not
visiting them the night before.
They must be wondering where she'd gone.
Well, maybe if they miss me for a while
they'll be more pleased to see me when I
do show up.
They seem great.
Anemone said wistfully.
I always wanted brothers and sisters.
Don't you have brothers?
She snorted.
Yes, but mother thinks they play too
rough, and she won't let them near me.
My cousins are all possible suspects in
her mind, except Moray, who's perfect and
boring and old, and can do no wrong.
And non-royal dragonettes aren't special
enough for me to play with.
Anemone side, blowing bubbles across the
water at tsunami.
I guess my friends are all right when
they're not complaining, tsunami
admitted.
They complain a lot, though.
I tried complaining once, Anemone said
with a stab of venom in her voice, Mother
nearly got me a gag to match the
harness.
At least somebody loves you, tsunami said
and you're with your own kind, and you
know your own stupid language.
She loves you too, Anemone offered.
She paused, glancing down into the cave.
Queen Coral was still fast asleep, her
blue scales rising and falling smoothly.
I hope you'll take Whirlpool, Anemone
blurted.
Three moons.
I was so sure I'd have to marry him, but
now you're here and you can have him, and
that'll be much better.
No way, Tsunami said, lashing her tail.
No, no, no.
An image of riptide flashed in her head
which was ridiculous because she hardly
knew him either.
Absolutely not.
First of all, I don't have time to get
married.
I have to stop the war and save the
world.
And or learn how to be queen of the sea
wings.
Second of all, that dragon?
No, thank you.
I'd rather have my tail nibbled off by
snapping turtles.
Anemone giggled.
He's dreadful, isn't he?
You are smaller in the Hudges to his
tsunami smarmed, imitating his fake grin
and tiny bow.
Anemone had to stick her head under the
water so her giggling wouldn't shake the
harness and wake the queen.
Anyway, mother can't decide who we marry
tsunami said.
Really?
Anemone said doubtfully.
She gets to decide everything else.
We're royalty, tsunami pointed out
meaning we do whatever we want.
Gosh.
That is not what I've seen, Anemone
said.
More like, we're royalty, so we only get
to do what historical sea wing queens
would approve of us doing, for the good
of our subjects, for the honor of the
throne, for the yawn claw meter death
already.
Tsunami laughed, but her gills felt
choked, and her scales prickled
uncomfortably.
She'd never thought of royalty that way.
Did queens really have to worry about
honor and other dragons' approval?
What would happen if a sea wing queen, or
potential queen, decided to say, marry
someone the rest of the tribe disapproved
of?
Or chose not to get married at all?
It would be harder to rule subjects who
didn't respect you.
Tsunami had enough trouble with her usual
for.
She imagined a whole grumbling tribe full
of glories and starflights.
But no one would dare argue with the
queen, would they?
Maybe it depended on the kind of queen
you were.
No one argued with Scarlet in the Sky
Wings, that was for sure.
But Scarlet was murderous and insane.
Not exactly the role model I want to
follow.
She stretched her wings out to feel the
splashing of the waterfall.
Outside their hidden spot, she could hear
the quiet noises of the summer palace
waking up.
Dragon wings fluttered overhead.
Bubbles burbled up from underwater caves
where most of the sea wings were
sleeping.
Pots clattered on the kitchen level of
the pavilion, reminding her of how hungry
she was.
Uh-oh, Anemone whispered, glancing down.
I think she's waking up.
We'd better go back in.
Tsunami hesitated.
Should she go visit her friends now?
But what would her mother think if she
woke up and found tsunami gone?
All right, she said.
But I have one more question.
What happened to Orca?
If Anemone could tell her, she could put
off going to ask Starfight about it
Anemone's pink tinted wings shivered
under the water.
She challenged mother for the throne when
she was only 7 years old, she whispered.
Everyone says it was horrible.
She nearly won.
But mother killed her in the end.
She glanced down again.
It's weird.
Mother worships her and misses her.
But lots of dragons still hate Orca for
nearly killing their queen.
Don't ever mention her name around
Moray.
Moray tsunami echoed.
She seems...
Trippy, fatuous, about as interesting as
sea slime, I was going to say odd.
Tsunami laughed, but those work too.
Uh-oh.
Anemone vanished below the water.
Tsunami followed her, swimming back to
her bed a few moments before Queen Coral
opened her eyes.
The queen sat up and stirred the water
with her wings as she stretched.
She beamed at tsunami and anemone
reaching to stroke their heads gently
with her talons.
The queen gathered her strands of pearls
from the coral branch where they'd hung
during the night.
Carefully she draped them around herself
again, then decorated anemone the same
way.
Tsunami hadn't taken off the one she'd
been given the day before.
Her mother smiled at this, and produced
another long strand of pearls.
These, a shimmering pale purple and oddly
shaped instead of round.
With expert talons, Queen Coral wound
them around tsunami's, chest and wings.
They were beautiful.
But it was strange to have something
weighing her down.
Tsunami felt almost as if she was wearing
a harness of treasure.
She wasn't about to complain, though.
The talons of peace had never given the
dragonettes beautiful things.
Finally, the queen beckoned for them to
follow her to the pavilion.
Tsunami wasn't sure how she felt about
being treated the same as anemone, a one
year old dragonette, but she did like how
her mother kept patting her, as if she
wanted to make sure tsunami was real.
As they flew up to the pavilion, tsunami
saw several guards clustered on one of
the lowest levels, half of them sleeping
and half of them drinking something
steaming out of handheld cauldrons, she
noticed that they looked well fed, well
rested, and content, not thin and grumpy
like Queen Scarlet's guards in the Sky
Wing Palace.
Proof that my mother is a better queen
than Scarlet, tsunami thought.
When Queen Coral landed on the council
level, a flurry of wing beats sounded all
over the palace.
Council members swept down from caves or
surged up from the water below.
Coral settled herself in the largest pool
which was labeled Queen.
She tugged anemone into the water with
her, although it was a bit of a squeeze
and the little dragonette had to curl
under the queen's wing.
Mother, Anemone protested, quit squashing
me.
She wriggled around until there was a
little more space for her.
Small turquoise dragons darted in with
platters of food, laying them all around
the pools as council members slipped into
their places.
Tsunami stood awkwardly to the side.
She felt like her tail and wings were in
the way of everything.
Oh, said Queen Coral, finally noticing.
Tsunami, you can sit there.
Tortoise is guarding the hatry at the
deep palace, so she won't be joining us
today.
The queen pointed her claw at a pool 2
down from hers, labeled Dragonette Care
in Tiny Emeralds.
The Wetstone was chilly under tsunami's
talons as she climbed into it.
The pools on either side of the queen
said, defense and communication.
Shark splashed down in the 1st one, and a
moment later, Moray landed in the other.
Good morning, Your Majesty, Moray said
bowing and dipping her wings.
I know yesterday it was a shocking day
but I hope you slept well.
I worried about you all night.
Thank you, dear, said the Queen.
Her eyes were scanning the rest of the
council.
Whirlpool flew up beside Moray.
His pool was labeled Magic and
Publishing.
Tsunami tilted her head at him.
How did one become an expert in either of
those things?
What kind of magic did he know anything
about?
She glanced around, wondering if there
was a pull for the king, but she didn't
see one.
Queen Coral hadn't said anything about
tsunami's father yesterday, and in all
the excitement about Kestrel's body
tsunami hadn't had a chance to ask.
Maybe he was at the deep palace.
Maybe she could meet him later today.
She remembered some of the council from
the day before.
The plump dragon Lagoon, who'd been sent
to feed the other dragonettes, sat in a
pool marked Aquaculture.
Piranha, the one who'd gone with shark to
examine and dispose of Kestrel's body, was
in war.
Tsunami didn't know any of the other
dragon's names, but from where she sat
she could see the labels Treasury, Justice
and Hunting.
She didn't really understand this council
business.
She wasn't sure what they did or why they
were necessary.
Wasn't it enough to have a queen?
Couldn't Coral just decide everything
herself?
That's what I do, she thought.
I'll get rid of this council and run the
tribe like a proper queen.
Maybe it worked for Coral, but tsunami
didn't need or want 11 dragons following
her around offering advice all the time.
Her stomach rumbled, and she tried to
remember when she'd last eaten.
The platters around her were loaded with
raw, ruby red fish, most of it sliced and
deboned, and arranged into fancy rolls
with seaweed.
She'd only ever eaten fish raw and whole
or sometimes scorched when her friends
decided to set their dinner on fire.
A few cauldrons held seething mountains
of tiny green crabs.
Three large bowls contained some kind of
salad of octopus tentacles and herbs that
tsunami had never seen before.
She plucked out one of the tentacles and
tasted it.
It was rubbery but sweet, with a tang
like lemons and salt.
She reached for another one and realized
the whole council was staring at her.
Nobody else had started eating yet.
Oops.
All the council eyes swiveled toward the
queen, who was staring at the bit of
octopus in tsunami's claws.
Carl shook herself and smiled.
It's all right.
The queen said, clapping her talons
together.
Naturally, I forgive my long lost
daughter any accidental impudence.
As we all know, she was raised by
barbarians, so she couldn't know any
better.
I give you all permission to eat.
Tsunami crushed the tentacle between her
claws.
Raised by barbarians?
Perhaps it was true, but what a thing to
say to tsunami's future subjects.
They'd think of her as the dragon who
knew nothing about sea wing customs.
How would she ever earn their respect
with that reputation?
Was Coral deliberately making tsunami
look foolish in front of the other
dragons?
Tsunami studied her mother, while Coral
helped herself to the largest pieces of
fish and crunched through talonfuls of
crabs.
She dropped bits of food into Anemones
open mouth as she ate.
Maybe not.
Maybe tsunami was seeing problems where
there weren't any.
But maybe, it wouldn't hurt to be a
little more careful from now on.
Chapter 11.
Pearl, report, ordered the queen, after
the dragons had eaten in silence for a
while.
No change, said the elegant pale green
dragon in the treasury pool.
All your jewels are safe, as always.
No scavengers can get to them, and no
dragon would dare to try.
Splendid, said Coral.
She abended the last of a cauldron of
crabs into her mouth.
Shark, report.
I am concerned about our defenses, snarled
the gray green dragon.
He glared at tsunami.
The intruders in our midst are danger to
us.
We have no idea whether they might have
led others to our palace, or what they
might be planning.
Now, now, said the Queen, those are our
guests, not intruders.
If my daughter trusts them, then, of
course, I do too.
Oh, good, tsunami said quickly, because I
was thinking maybe they could join us for
breakfast.
I'm sure they're hungry, and if they
could see that they're really welcome
here.
She trailed off as Coral shook her head.
Only council members and royalty are
allowed at council meetings, darling
Queen Coral said, running one claw along
a strand of her pearls.
But they certainly won't go hungry.
Lagoon, did you make sure they were
served an ample breakfast?
The turquoise dragon nodded.
They can have the rest of this as well.
Queen Coral waved her talons at the
breakfast leftovers.
The same small dragons from before, darted
up from the kitchen level, collected the
platters, and flew down to the cave with
them.
Tsunami watched over the edge of the
pavilion.
None of our friends even poked their
heads out, where they sulking in there?
Were they still mad at her?
Well, she was doing a fine enough job of
embarrassing herself.
She didn't need them to come out and
help.
Raised by barbarians, friends with other
tribes, not the stuff most queens were
made of.
Whirlpool report. said the queen, smiling
at him.
Whirlpool touched the hoop in his ear and
flared his wings.
Anemones lessons are going wonderfully, he
said.
Tsunami wasn't sure why his voice was so
irritating.
But it felt like claws scraping on stone
to listen to him.
And your scrolls have never been more
popular.
The latest has been bought by every
single sea wing in the tribe.
Mostly the underwater editions.
Moray jumped in.
Those tend to sell the best.
Of course, I spend all my energy
promoting them.
But I've organized another reading.
Whirlpool interrupted.
Every high ranking dragon is clamoring to
attend.
We're charging an emerald apiece this
time.
Queen Coral waved her tail thoughtfully.
I want to be sure, I'm reaching the eel
eating masses as well, though, she said.
I mean, my writing should be shared with
everyone, not just those who can afford
it.
Of course.
Moray said.
That's why the schools have all changed
their curriculums again, to be sure the
dragonettes have enough time to read
everything you've written.
It's the most important subject they
study.
You can't be serious, tsunami burst out.
More important than how to fight the
war?
Cold, silence.
Queen Coral pressed a talent to a chest
looking injured.
Darling, my riding is about everything.
As you would know if you'd finished the
scrolls I gave you yesterday.
What did you think of them?
Tsunami guiltily remembered the scrolls
she'd tossed aside as they flew off to
see Kestrel's body.
She hadn't even gone back to the library
to get them.
Uh, she mumbled.
The missing princess is still my
favorite.
A chuckle ran around the assembled
dragons.
Tsunami felt hot with embarrassment.
Councils were so stupid.
She would never, ever have something like
this when she was queen.
That reminds me. said the queen.
Whirlpool, tsunami needs lessons in
aquatic.
Can you believe she never learned it?
Poor thing.
She tapped her claws on the stone in
front of her.
Such a sad upbringing.
Her face was sympathetic, but her stripes
were flashing, and Tsunami wondered
angrily if she was saying something
different to the council, knowing Tsunami
couldn't understand.
Of course, Your Majesty.
Whirlpool said.
He inclined his head towards tsunami.
I would be happy to instruct the
princess.
Piranha, report.
Queen Carl snapped her head around to the
warpool.
The war commander was so clawed up that
she seemed to be more scars than scales.
One horn was snapped in half and several
of her teeth were broken.
Still no information about the dead sky
wing.
Piranha growled.
Tsunami ducked her head.
Eventually, she had to tell her mother
the truth, who Kestrel was, how tsunami
knew her.
But she didn't want a harness attached to
her, or some kind of permanent guard, and
she felt like she should tell her friends
first.
I'll tell her later, I will.
A war party returned early this morning.
Hirana went on.
Do you want to hear their report?
Queen Carl sighed and gestured with her
claws?
Piranha culed over the edge, and 2
soldier sea wings came flying up from a
lower level.
One was too injured to fly, so the other
supported him.
They spiraled in a jerking, awkward
motion and landed heavily in the center
of the council meeting.
The sea wing who couldn't fly, had long
burned along his side, and one wing was
scorched almost entirely black.
Claw marks along his underbelly were
still oozing blood, which dripped into
the sparkling channels between the
council dragons, staining the pearls
red.
Tsunami saw the queen give her decorated
floor a concerned look.
The other sea wing had a scorch mark in
the middle of his tail, and a horrible
gash in his neck.
He was breathing heavily, and bubbles of
pale red blood foamed out of his gills.
Let's hear it.
Queen Coral ordered.
Something strange is happening in the Sky
Kingdom, Your Majesty, said the one who
couldn't fly.
The battalions, it's as if nobody knows
who's in charge.
We were patrolling the outer islands, and
we were attacked by 3 separate wings.
The 1st squadron was half sky wings and
half sand wings during the 2nd attack.
We heard the Skywings yelling, For Ruby.
And in the 3rd, at least one dragon
shouted, the queen is not dead.
Long live the queen.
Queen Carl sat forward, splashing water
over the edge of the pool, and squashing
anemone over to the side.
For Ruby?
She echoed.
One of Scarlett's daughters, growled
Piranha.
Does that mean Queen Scarlet is dead?
Tsunami clenched and unclenched her
talons.
How much should she tell the council?
She didn't want to reveal Glory's secret
weapon.
They never knew when they might need it.
And they weren't even sure glory had
killed Queen Scarlet during the escape.
We would have heard if there had been a
challenge, surely, said Moray.
Queen Coral shot a stern look at the blue
dragon in the secrets and spies pool.
Why don't you know anything about this?
None of my spies have reported in for
days, he protested.
I had no idea anything strange was
happening in the Sky Kingdom.
The soldier who couldn't fly was leaning
more and more dizzily against his
companion.
Puddles of blood soaked their claws.
Mother, tsunami said.
Shouldn't somebody look at their
injuries?
She pointed at the soldiers.
Coral eyed them up and down.
Anything else to report?
12 casualties.
The soldier croaked.
All the rest badly injured.
But nobody followed you back to the
palace, demanded Shark.
We were careful, he promised, wincing
with pain.
We took the longest roots back.
Very well.
Queen Coral waved her talons
dismissively.
You may go.
She flicked her tail at the smallest
council member in the dragon health pool
who ushered the soldiers away.
Moray immediately jumped out of her own
pool and started cleaning out the blood
on the floor.
If there is chaos in the sky kingdom
maybe this is the time to strike, Carl
said.
She wrapped one strand of pearls around
her claws.
We should send the rescue mission now.
We could get him back today.
We don't know enough, growled the secrets
and spies, dragon.
If Scarlet is dead, how did she die?
Did Ruby kill her?
Or is she fighting with her sisters for
the throne?
Moray hissed at the blood under her
claws.
Like the sandwing rivalry all over again
making the war even worse.
Or has burn taken over?
Piranha suggested.
She would, if she was there.
But Scarlet's daughters might not listen
to burn the way Scarlet did, said Moray.
What could have happened?
Coral said.
Queen Scarlet was so strong.
Tsunami shifted uncomfortably, feeling
the cold water seeping through her
scales.
She couldn't hide what she knew, not when
her mother needed the information so
much.
Or at least she could share some of the
dramatic highlights.
Um, tsunami said.
The entire council turned to stare at
her.
That might have been us.
There was a shocked pause.
You barked Piranha.
Ridiculous, snarled Shark.
Queen Scarlet found us under the mountain
tsunami said.
She held us prisoner in her palace, and
when we escaped, we sort of might have
killed her.
Maybe.
I'm not sure.
I will say we tried.
She quite liked the horrified look on
shark's face at that bit of news.
Starting to respect us a bit more?
She thought.
You were at the Sky Wing Palace?
Coral lunged out of her pool, swarmed
across the stone, and seized tsunami's
front talons in her own, clutching them
so hard it was a little painful.
Behind her.
Anemone was yanked half out of the pool
with a squeak of protest, but Coral
didn't seem to notice.
Did you see a sea wing named Gil?
The queen cried.
Green scales, big and powerful with brave
eyes.
Tsunami felt sick.
Gil.
Yes.
She remembered Gil, but not the way Queen
Coral described him.
She'd been forced to fight Gil in
Scarlet's Gladiator Arena after he'd been
deprived of water for months and driven
mad with thirst.
He'd been covered in scratches, as if
he'd tried to drink his own blood.
The sound of dragon bones snapping
between my talons.
I did see him, tsunami said slowly.
A gasp went up around her, whispers
traveling from one council member to the
next.
Shark's pale, unfriendly eyes were like
octopus arms coiling around her neck.
Can you tell us where he is?
Queen Coral asked urgently.
We've been planning a rescue mission, but
he's not in the regular prison with the
others, and we've got to get him back
tsunami.
You have no idea how important it is.
Tsunami curled her tail in close to her
talons.
She wanted to dive into the lake, crawl
down to the bottom, and stay there
forever with her wings over her head.
He is, her voice cracked.
She swallowed and started again.
He's dead.
She'd had no choice but to kill the
desperate sea wing in the arena.
It was his life or hers.
She hadn't wanted to kill him.
At least, she was pretty sure she hadn't
wanted to kill him.
But when she did, the truth was, tsunami
had loved the look on Queen Scarlet's
face when she broke Gil's neck.
She liked the feeling of being powerful
and dangerous.
Gil's sanity had been long gone anyway.
It had been easy for tsunami not to think
about where he came from, or what his
life was like before he landed in the Sky
Wing prison.
It was easier not to think of him as a
real dragon.
She'd never imagined her own mother
desperately planning to get him back, or
that she'd have to explain his death to
anyone.
Dead?
Queen Coral released tsunami's talons and
staggered backward.
Her claws splashed in the winding
channels, slipping on pearls.
How?
Um, tsunami stammered.
Did she really have to admit this in
front of all these dragons?
In the arena.
But he refused to fight, Coral said.
We heard about it through our spies.
He convinced each of his opponents to lie
down and refuse to fight along with him.
He has had a way with words.
No one who met him would be able to kill
him.
A smile flickered across her snout and
vanished.
Queen Scarlet was furious.
I heard.
She was.
Tsunami swallowed again.
She punished him.
It was really awful.
What do you know about his death?
Shark demanded coldly.
Tsunami stirred the water with her
claws.
She drove him mad.
She kept him away from water until he
lost his mind, and when he was crazy, he
was dangerous.
He was barely even a dragon anymore.
He had to be killed.
Really?
Shark said.
And tsunami felt horribly sure he had
guessed the truth.
Why?
Tsunami asked.
Who, who was he?
An important general?
More than that, said Queen Coral in a
hollow voice.
Much more.
He was my husband.
Darkness seemed to be rushing into
Tsunami's vision, sucking away all her
breath.
She knew what Queen Coral was going to
say next.
And she would have fled back to the
mountains to avoid hearing it if she
could.
Tsunami.
Gil was your father.
Chapter 12.
Queen Coral dropped her head and slowly
dragged herself back to her pool.
Dead, she said.
My Gil is dead.
No more eggs?
Mori whispered.
She was still crouched in the center of
the floor, scrubbing at the blood.
Her eyes had a weird glow to them.
No more dragonettes.
No more challenges.
Not necessarily.
She could marry again.
Whirlpool murmured.
Moray shot him a glare.
Coral didn't seem to hear either of
them.
She pulled anemone into her wings and
clutched her tightly.
The little dragonette wriggled a bit, then
gave up and rested her head on Coral's
shoulder.
She blinked in a resigned way at tsunami
over their mother's back.
Tsunami felt like oceans were pressing
against the back of her eyes.
Her scales were heavy, as if they were
clogged with seaweed.
But I didn't have a choice.
Did I?
He was my father.
And I had no idea.
But he wasn't a real dragon anymore.
He wasn't anyone inside his parched
scales.
He was gone, and I had to survive.
I had to survive to protect my friends
and fulfill my destiny.
Nothing helped.
She hadn't really thought about other
options when she'd killed the Seawing in
the arena.
It was impulse, and wanting to prove
something to Queen Scarlet.
Shark was still staring at her
unblinking.
Tsunami bared her teeth at him.
I must grieve, said the queen.
Counsel dismissed.
She stepped to the edge of the pavilion
and flew off to her cave, still holding
anemone.
The council dragons peeled off to various
caves and other levels of the pavilion.
Tsunami buried her head in the pool and
clutched her horns.
Now what was she supposed to do?
She definitely was not in the mood for
seeing her friends.
It would not make her feel any better to
face their remarks about what a terrible
dragon she was, the kind of dragon who
attacked other dragons for no reason, the
kind of dragon who did what she thought
was right, but was always wrong.
The kind of dragon, who could kill her
own father.
Something tapped her on the top of her
head.
She emerged from the water and found
Whirlpool rubbing his claws together.
Time for your 1st lesson, he said, in his
oily voice.
Now, tsunami said.
Why not?
He spread his talons.
It is never too soon to begin filling our
minds with knowledge.
Tsunami hissed softly under her breath.
This was not going to be fun, but perhaps
it would be distracting.
Come, he said, strutting to the edge and
diving over.
Tsunami reluctantly followed him into the
cavern lake.
He was hovering several lengths below the
surface, flashing his stripes at her.
Tsunami sank to his level and watched
him.
She kept her own scales dark.
She most definitely did not want to say
something to him, like what she'd said to
riptide.
If Anemone was right about Coral's plans
for him, Whirlpool did not need any
encouraging.
After a few moments, Whirlpool swam up to
the surface again.
His pale green eyes seemed far too big
for his eye sockets.
What's the matter?
He said.
Don't your stripes light up?
Of course they do, Tsunami snapped, but
you haven't told me what we're saying or
anything.
Just imitate me, he said officiously, and
dove again before she could argue. tsunami
growled.
This time she imitated each flashing path
of light, along her wings, her tail, her
sides, alternating and sometimes flashing
faster, or slower.
It seemed to go on for an eternity.
Finally, Whirlpool nodded with
satisfaction and rose to the air again.
Excellent.
He proclaimed.
What's excellent?
Tsunami demanded, spreading her wings to
float.
What did we just say?
We recited the 1st chapter of the Queen's
very 1st work.
The tragedy of Orca.
It's extremely moving, glorious writing
you nearly repeated it perfectly.
Tsunami wanted to splash seawater up his
annoying snout, but I didn't learn
anything.
Oh, you will, he said.
With repetition comes perfection.
Shall we go on to the 2nd chapter?
No, tsunami said.
Teach me something I can use.
How do you greet strangers?
How do you warn other sea wings of
danger?
How do you say, I'm sorry I killed my
father?
She shook herself.
For moon's sake, at least show me how to
say, I don't speak aquatic.
All knowledge can be found in the queen's
writing.
Whirlpool insisted.
If we recite 3 chapters a day, we should
get through her entire body of work in
about 5 years.
I have to get out of here, tsunami said
before I tie your stupid tail around your
stupid snout and leave you in a bundle at
the bottom of the lake.
She turned and swam toward the exit
tunnel.
It wasn't quite as dramatic as storming
out of a cave, which she hoped would be
the 1st and last time she missed anything
about life under the mountain.
I am not impressed with your work ethic.
Whirlpool called.
This may take us closer to 7 or 8 years
if you.
Tsunami plunged her head under the water
so she wouldn't have to listen to him
anymore.
The exit tunnel yawned ahead of her, and
she shot into it as fast as her wings
could beat.
Outside the summer palace, the sky was
gray and overcast, which suited tsunami's
mood perfectly.
Wind whipped the sea into white tipped
peaks, knocking tsunami around even more
than usual.
She tried paddling away from the palace
underwater, but currents kept flinging
her into the jagged boulders.
She was sick of fighting with the ocean.
Why wouldn't it welcome her, like it was
supposed to.
Why couldn't she start over as a normal
sea wing with normal problems, instead of
having her past mistakes suckered onto
her tail like overgrown leeches.
Frustrated, she swam to the surface and
flew into the sky.
It didn't make sense that flying should
be easier for her than swimming.
What kind of sea wing didn't love the
sea?
The kind that shouldn't be queen maybe
tsunami thought.
Looming out of the water ahead of her was
the island of rocks shaped like a giant
dragon skeleton.
Tsunami banked toward it, studying the
holes and gaps.
She chose the cave where the eye should
be, and landed in cool semi darkness.
The stone was smooth like pearls under
her claws.
She flapped her wings to dry them and
turned to look out the entrance.
A dragon head popped into a view, then
vanished again.
Wow, tsunami said, you are the worst at
staying hidden.
Has anyone ever told you that you should
definitely never be a spy?
Riptide slowly poked his head around the
mouth of the cave.
I think I'd make a splendid spy, he said
with dignity.
Aren't you supposed to be patrolling the
outer islands where we met?
Tsunami asked.
Perhaps, but as you can imagine, I don't
have a very important job.
Riptide made a rye expression.
Her majesty can't trust me with anything
vital.
You do seem like a shady character.
Tsunami said, remembering that she was
supposed to be mad at him too.
She could yell at him.
Her 1st instinct was to yell at him.
Maybe I should stop listening to all my
1st instincts.
She scooted back farther into the cave.
Come on in.
I'm just recovering from an aquatic
lesson with Whirlpool.
Oh, whirlpool, Queen Coral's favorite
instrument of torture, cryptide said.
He climbed into the cave beside her
shaking water droplets from his scales.
The cave was only big enough for 3 or 4
dragons, so they were closer together in
the dark than tsunami had expected.
When she was much younger, Tsunami had
had fleeting crushes on clay and
Starflight before she realized that
Starflight could be massively annoying
and that sweet, loyal clay saw the other
dragonettes as brothers and sisters.
But they were the only dragonettes her
own age that she'd ever met.
Even though they weren't sea wings, who
else was she supposed to like?
Now here she was, alone with a sea wing, a
sea wing who looked at her as if he
didn't see a future queen, or a father
killer, or anything but a dragon whom he
liked very much.
Carl told me Webbs is your father, she
said quickly, awkwardly.
Why didn't you say something when we
met?
It's not how I usually introduce myself
he said.
He coiled his tail around his talons.
It makes dragons see me a certain way.
I'm sorry.
I should have told you.
I was hoping you might, um, I'd like to
know more about him.
Tsunami shook her head, tempted to say no
you wouldn't.
Is that why you've been hanging around
watching me?
she asked instead.
His dark blue eyes caught the faint light
from outside.
That and other reasons, he said.
I was worried about you.
There aren't a lot of outspoken dragons
in the kingdom of the sea.
I can say whatever I want, Tsunami said
boldly.
I'm the missing princess Mother loves me
so much, she'll have a harness on me by
the end of the day if I'm not careful.
Riptide snorted.
I'd like to see any dragon try to put a
harness on you.
Then they'd really find out how outspoken
I am, Tsunami said.
She opened and closed her wings
accidentally brushing against his.
Oops, say something, quick.
Webbs wasn't so bad, she blurted.
Not as bad as the other two.
He tilted his head.
We had 3 guardians.
The other two, Dune and Kestrel hated
everything, tsunami said, except maybe
sunny.
Nobody hates Sonny.
She's too sweet and simple and lovable.
She sounds frightful, Riptide said, and
tsunami laughed.
But Webbs, he wasn't just trying to keep
us alive.
He taught us everything he could, except
aquatic, I guess.
He taught us history and geography, and
all about the prophecy, and he wasn't
even that boring about it.
When it was his turn to hunt, he tried to
bring back prey he knew we liked.
It would have been worse without him.
She fell silent, thinking.
She'd never tried listing good things
about webs before.
It was a lot harder than complaining
about him, like she'd done her whole
life.
It's all right, Riptide said.
You can tell me the truth.
The end of his tail flicked up and down.
I want to hear the bad stuff too.
It's good for me.
Tsunami took a deep breath.
He should have protected us better, she
said.
If he was the only one who cared, he
should have stopped Dune and Kestrel from
hurting us and telling us we were
worthless, he should have fought for us
and he never did, except right at the end
when Scarlet and the Sky Wings attacked.
That's one thing I do, she thought to
herself, I fight for my friends, even if
I'm doing it all wrong.
Riptide nodded, looking down at the stone
under his talons, weak and cowardly, he
said.
That's how he's always been described to
me.
Tsunami reached out and touched his wing
with one claw.
That doesn't mean you're anything like
him.
She said.
It's not fair to punish you for what he
did.
Something tingled in the air between them
like the sky outside, waiting for the
storm.
This is most improper for the future's
sea wing queen, tsunami thought.
But maybe I'd rather have this than a
throne anyway.
Would you like a real aquatic lesson?
Riptide asked with a smile.
I demand one, she answered.
It's dark enough in here, he said.
All right.
Here's what you say to Whirlpool next
time you see him.
The stripe on his tail lit up 3 times.
Uh oh, tsunami said, copying him.
What did I just call him?
A squid brain?
Riptide said.
My new favorite insult, thanks to you.
I'm not sure this lesson is teaching me
much more than his did.
Tsunami pointed out.
Hey, now I'm offended, he said.
All right, you asked for it.
He sat down and pointed to his snout.
These stripes usually indicate a question
like this for why, and like this for how
and like this for when.
Tsunami mimicked him, memorizing the
patterns of flashes.
It was easier than she'd expected.
Maybe there was one part of being a
ceiling that she wouldn't be a total
failure at...
After she had to question patterns down
Riptide said, try this one.
I will protect you.
Stripes flashed along his side and he
gestured at the same time.
I don't need protecting, tsunami said.
I know, he answered, but knowing you
you'll probably need to say it to someone
one day.
Tsunami liked that.
I will protect you, she echoed, flashing
it back at him.
He smiled a little sadly.
I wish you could, he said.
Why not?
She said.
I am a princess.
I can do whatever I want.
Not while someone else's queen, he
pointed out.
All right, here's how you indicate
different kinds of danger.
Riptide showed her other stripe patterns
and some of the talent gestures as well.
It was all fascinating, and tsunami
wasn't sure how much time had passed when
she finally glanced out at the wind
whipped sea and realized she should be
getting back.
Mother might be looking for me, she
explained, but thank you.
You have no idea how helpful this was.
All of this, she thought, realizing she'd
managed to forget about Gil for a little
while.
Has Blister arrived yet?
Riptide asked.
Tsunami shook her head.
He took her front talons in his.
Be wary of her, he said.
She has her own plans, and I don't think
protecting sea wings is high on her
list.
I will, tsunami said.
Oh, she added, freeing her talons.
What does this mean?
She tried to imitate the circular gesture
Shark had made yesterday.
Riptide tilted his head at her.
If you mean this, he said, doing it
perfectly, then it means something like
not right now, we'll finish this later.
Tsunami stared at him.
Are you sure?
Pretty sure, Riptide said.
Why?
Who?
Yesterday, when I stopped Shark and the
guards from killing my friends, Tsunami
said, jumping to her feet.
That's the gesture he made to them.
You're telling me he was saying, we'll
just kill them later?
Riptide rubbed his snout.
Maybe, he said unhappily, but if Queen
Coral hasn't ordered it, then I'm sure.
How would I know?
Tsunami cried.
What if she has ordered it and I didn't
understand her?
She ran to the mouth of the cave.
I have to go back.
I have to check on them.
I haven't even seen them since
yesterday.
She leaped into the air, catching the air
currents.
Be careful, Riptide called after her.
I'll be out here if you need me.
Just, the wind yanked away his last
words.
Tsunami dove into the water between the
spiral dragon horn rocks.
She powered through the kelp into the
tunnel, shooting between the rock walls.
She was going so fast, she didn't see the
dark shape wading above her in one of the
breathing holes.
She thought she was alone, until Talons
slammed into her back, and sharp claws
closed around her neck.
Chapter 13.
Giant wings smashed tsunami to the rock
floor of the tunnel.
She tried to twist around, but her
attacker kicked her in the head, and then
shoved a hood that smelled of seaweed
over her snout so she couldn't see.
Tsunami shouted and struggled, lashing
out with her claws and tail.
Her attacker was bigger than her, and
heavier.
So tsunami could barely move under the
weight.
It seemed like he or she was wearing
something to make them heavier.
She felt something metallic clank against
her spines.
Fish hook claws dug into her gills, and
tsunami shrieked with pain.
She felt blood swirling away from her
neck into the water.
I'm not going to die here, she thought
ferociously. killed by a coward.
I can't even see.
I don't think so.
She remembered how Sonny always managed
to wriggle free during their battle
training sessions.
The tiny dragonette used her small size
to slip out of almost every hold tsunami
could think of.
Tsunami scrunched her legs and wings in
close and ducked her head, rolling into a
tight, spiky ball.
Her attacker's grip loosened around her
neck, and as the dragon fumbled for
tsunami's snout, tsunami was able to
squirm down and shove her opponent over
her head.
A blast of bubble slammed into her as the
dragon crashed into the wall.
Before she could pull her hood off, the
talons were back, clutching her
forearms.
Tsunami kicked viciously at the
underbelly that had to be in front of her
and felt her claws snag painfully on
metal rings.
Her attacker made no sound.
But a moment later, the dragon's tail hit
tsunami so hard, she thought she heard
bones crack.
The other dragon's wings began to press
her down toward the rock floor again.
Whoever it was, knew how to fight like a
sea wing.
They had all the advantages of this
world.
So use something they haven't seen
before.
Tsunami thought of how glory used
distraction whenever she fought Kestrel.
Tsunami's scales couldn't change color
but she bet she could still be pretty
distracting.
She flared her wings open and closed, open
and closed as fast as she could, stirring
up the water around them.
She felt her attacker pause as if
confused.
On her 3rd flare open.
Tsunami suddenly lit up all the stripes
all over her body, and what she hoped was
a blinding flash.
Her attacker's talons slipped, and
tsunami struck out with her claws again.
Again, she flared her stripes as bright
as she could make them, so she could even
see the light through her hood.
She reached to shove her attacker away
and suddenly, whoever it was, was gone.
Tsunami flailed in the water for a moment
fending off the attacks she expected from
every side, before she realized there was
no one around her anymore.
She reached up and yanked off the hood
then felt the movement of somebody coming
up the tunnel from the outside.
She whirled around, ready to fight.
And riptide, leaped back, waving his
talons.
Tsunami whipped her head back and forth
but there was no sign of anyone else.
All right?
Riptide signaled.
Who?
She signaled back with the stripes on her
snout.
Who?
She didn't have any of the other words
she needed.
He spread his webbed claws.
I don't know.
Then he pointed at her.
All right.
He lit up all his stripes, and she
guessed he'd seen the light from
outside.
She nodded impatiently.
She didn't have any way to explain she
was grateful he'd come, but she needed to
chase down her attacker now.
All right, she signaled back.
Then she spun away, swimming fast down
the tunnel toward the palace.
Tsunami burst out of the water into a
scene of eerie calm.
Dragons were lounging peacefully on
beaches and cliff edges or playing
underwater, and darting through the
waterfalls.
She searched the water and the pavilion
with her gaze, looking for anyone who
might have just been in a fight.
Surely she had left some kind of mark on
her attacker.
No one was acting suspicious.
Tsunami glanced up and saw her mother's
tail poking off a level of the pavilion
near the top, the library level.
She beat her wings, rose out of the water
and flew up to her.
Hello, dear.
Queen Coral said a tsunami landed.
She was surrounded by scrolls, several of
them half unrolled.
Anemone was curled on a curved white
boulder beside her, looking bored out of
her mind.
I've been reading out loud to your
sister.
It's her favorite part of the day.
We've just finished the story of how I
chose Gil to be my husband.
She sighed gustily.
He adored my writing too.
Mother, tsunami started.
He was a perfect candidate for king, Coral
said.
He came from a very noble family.
Nothing to worry about in his ancestry.
A lot like Whirlpool and his intelligence
too.
Coral sighed again.
Mother, tsunami said again.
Luckily, you've arrived just in time for
my epic poem on the differences between
oysters and clams.
It's an elegantly well crafted metaphor
about class differences and genetic
superiority, as Whirlpool always says.
Mother, tsunami interrupted firmly.
Someone just tried to kill me.
Queen Coral sat up, scattering drops of
ink from her claws.
What?
Who dared?
I don't know, but they must be here now.
Tsunami said.
Somewhere in the palace, we should gather
everyone and the eggs.
Queen Coral yelped.
The eggs must be in danger.
She started flinging scrolls back into
cauldrons.
What?
Tsunami said, bewildered.
What eggs?
Two eggs with female dragonettes, Anemone
explained to tsunami.
They're in the royal hatchery, in the
deep palace.
They're due to hatch in a couple of
days.
And if someone attacked you, they'll
probably go after the eggs too, Queen
Coral cried.
She dashed to the edge of the pavilion.
Moray, whirlpool.
Hurry.
But my attacker is here, tsunami said.
I'm sure of it.
Not at the deep palace.
So we have to get there first.
Queen Carl insisted.
But we could catch them here.
Tsunami didn't understand why her mother
couldn't see the obvious thing to do.
Mother, what about tortoise?
Anemone asked.
She's supposed to guard them, isn't she?
That's mother's council chief of
Dragonette Care, she explained to
tsunami.
This week anyway.
The others have all failed me.
Queen Carl said with a grimace.
Tortoise probably will as well.
She didn't even want the job.
Nobody wants it.
The most important duty in the kingdom of
the sea, and all my cowardly subjects
hide from it.
Moray, she bellowed.
Yes, Your Majesty.
Moray slithered up from the level below.
Tsunami eyed her as she climbed onto the
library floor.
Did she look like she'd just been in a
fight?
Tsunami couldn't tell.
Moray wouldn't look at her, but that
wasn't new.
Moray, we must get to the Deep Palace at
once, Queen Coral said.
I feel that my eggs are in danger.
My scales tell me so.
What about whoever attacked me?
Tsunami demanded.
We had to catch them and punish them.
It's more important to stop them from
hurting my eggs, Queen Coral said
grimly.
Someone has been killing my daughters for
years.
These are the last 2 Gil left me, and I
won't let anything happen to them.
She turned to Moray, who was sitting
close beside her and gazing worshipfully
at the queen, I wish you would guard them
dear.
You never fail me.
But everything I do for your scrolls is
so terribly important, Mori said.
They're like your other children, really.
I couldn't abandon them.
That's true.
Queen Coral said.
She patted her pearls and flicked her
wings open.
Behind your back, tsunami caught Moray
shooting a look full of hatred at
anemone.
Wow, she thought.
I wonder what that's for.
Do you hate all of Queen Coral's
daughters?
Enough to try to kill me?
I sent Shark on ahead this morning after
breakfast, but he never worries enough
Queen Coral said, clicking her claws
together.
He doesn't even believe there's an
assassin.
He thinks it's all bad luck.
She shook herself with a hiss.
He even told me once that perhaps I
wasn't meant to have daughters.
He's lucky he's my brother, and your
father, Moray, so I let him live.
Whirlpool, where are you?
Anemone winced and put her talons over
her ears.
Stay very close to me in the deep
palace.
The queen ordered tsunami.
We really have to put a rush order on a
harness for you.
They've been working on 2 for the new
Dragon Eds, but clearly yours is an
emergency.
I can take care of myself, Tsunami said
ruffled.
Obviously, I'm still alive, so whoever
attacked me failed.
She gave Moray a hard look, but the
council dragon only shifted her wings as
if she didn't care.
Pitter patter, pitter patter.
All the dragons glanced up at the canopy
far overhead.
Raindrops were spattering across the
green leaves.
Ah, the precipitation I predicted, said
Whirlpool, landing beside Coral.
My apologies for not appearing instantly
Your Majesty.
I was distributing scrolls to the kitchen
staff.
He didn't look as if he'd been in a fight
and tsunami didn't really think the
ridiculous dragon could have overpowered
her for a moment.
We're going to the Deep Palace.
Now, as fast as we can.
Queen Carl dove over the edge so suddenly
that anemone was yanked off her talons
after her.
Tsunami followed and found herself in a
swarm of dragons midair, as all the
council members hurried after Queen Coral
as well.
They crowded into the tunnel, tales
smacking into snouts and wings tangling.
Tsunami got pushed into the middle and
found herself swimming beside Whirlpool.
Too late, she remembered she had meant to
check on her friends.
Why can't I be a better dragon?
She berated herself.
She tried to turn and go back, but
council dragons were there shoving her
forward.
After nearly getting clawed in the face a
few times, she gave up.
Surely they're all right, especially if
shark is in the deep palace already.
I'll come right back and see them after
we check on the eggs.
Out in the sea, Queen Coral immediately
found a current and swept off.
One by one, each of the dragons followed
her.
Tsunami glanced around, scanning the
coral reefs and underwater boulders.
Her heart jumped a little as she caught a
glimpse of sky blue scales.
Riptide was still out there, watching for
her.
She waited a moment until she saw him
dart from one rock to another.
He was following them, following her, to
the deep palace. pleased, although she
felt a bit silly about it.
She swam into the current, and let it
carry her after the others.
She was starting to get the trick of how
to angle her wings, so it could sweep her
along as fast as possible.
It was a bit like flying, but with a lot
more to dodge.
Then again, fish managed to get out of
the way pretty fast when they saw the
dragons coming.
Above them, rain pattered down harder and
harder on the water's surface.
The light faded, and tsunami imagined the
dark clouds rolling in.
She hoped her friends would be all right
in the Summer Palace.
Surely there were storms there all the
time.
At least they were in a cave so they
wouldn't get wet.
Two giant sea turtles swam by, going in
the other direction.
They eyed the dragons warily, but nobody
stopped to eat them.
Explosions of tiny pink fish popped in
and out of the waving anemones along the
coral reefs.
Something large and yellow was lying flat
against the sand.
It opened its eyes, stared at tsunami, and
closed them again.
After a while, an island loomed in front
of them, with immense coral reefs
clustered all around it, orange branches
twined around purple star shaped clusters
lacy fans, the color of rust sprouted
from pale pink umbrella shapes.
Blue and silver fish darted in and out of
the holes.
The sea wings swam out of the current, and
around the bend of the reef, and then the
lead dragons ducked into a canyon in the
ocean floor.
Tsunami followed them down.
As her eyes adjusted to the growing
darkness, she saw a vast expanse of white
and green coral reef, spreading along the
sides and floor of the canyon.
It curled into caves and towers, and
underwater gardens full of glowing
colors.
In the center of the canyon.
The corals spiraled up into an enormous
palace, swarming with sea wings.
Sea wings were everywhere, swimming in
and out of the windows and doors of the
palace, shooting up to the surface and
diving to the bottom of the canyon
tending the gardens, gently cleaning the
coral, lugging large fish in from the
hunt, or sitting in small circles with
groups of dragonettes, reading from thin
stone tablets.
The only signs of the war were a few
troops drilling in formation around the
palace, and a group of soldiers gathered
in one of the gardens, each with terrible
bandaged wounds.
Tsunami saw 2 with missing feet, one with
scorched holes where his eyes should have
been, and several with black scars
twisting their wings or tail.
Several couldn't swim anymore, but had to
be helped through the water by nurse
dragons.
As Queen Carl swam past, dragons snapped
to attention, saluting or waving.
She waved to each of them with a wide
smile.
Tsunami noticed that most of them waved
to anemone too, and the little dragonette
smiled and waved back.
Surrounded by council members, for once
tsunami was able to sweep by without a
whole lot of staring and pointing.
For a little while at least, nobody knew
who she was.
They swam through the wide front entrance
into a coral cavern, sparkling with
emeralds and sapphires.
A statue of queen coral loomed in a
center, her talons outstretched
benevolently.
Seawing servants hurried in from all
directions, their luminescent stripes
flashing at the queen.
Coral swept past them all and charged
down a tunnel in the back of the hall.
Some of the council broke away to swim to
other parts of the palace, but Moray and
Whirlpool stayed with the queen, and so
did tsunami.
The tunnel curved down and around in a
spiral, getting warmer and warmer as they
descended.
Tsunami felt warm jets of water bubbling
up through the coral under her talons.
At the bottom was a stone door, and in
front of the door, a skinny seaweed green
dragon crouched, gobbling something
hungrily in her claws.
Her eyes went wide when she saw the queen
and she dropped her octopus with a
shriek.
The remains floated up to the ceiling as
she flapped her talons in a panic
flashing her stripes so fast, she looked
like a lightning storm gone mad.
Queen Coral roared and threw the door
open, smacking the green dragon back
against the wall.
The queen shot inside, towing anemone
behind her.
This is where I should have hatched
tsunami thought, with a rush of confused
excitement.
She swam through the doorway and gazed
around.
The royal hatchery.
The warm jets bubbled along every wall
heating the room, which was shaped like
the inside of a large pale egg.
A sea wing dragon carved from dark green
marble stood in the center of the room.
Garlands of blue and purple underwater
plants were woven through her horns and
along her wings.
The base of the statue said, Orca.
She looked tough and beautiful at the
same time.
Tsunome wondered if Queen Coral's 1st
daughter had carved her own self portrait
and if she'd known it would be a memorial
one day.
She glanced around and caught the hateful
look Moray shot the statue.
Maybe all her fawning over the queen is
for real, tsunami realized.
Maybe she actually means it when she goes
on and on about how wonderful Queen Coral
is.
Maybe she would even do anything to
protect Coral from her daughters.
Nests made of seaweed were tucked into
niches in the floor, with wide pathways
stretching between them.
Dragon eggs took a year to hatch, so
there should have been clutches at
different stages, from newly laid to
nearly hatched, but there were no new
eggs to be seen.
Because Gil has been gone.
Tsunami thought with a stab of guilt.
Andy's not coming back.
One clutch of 3 eggs was tucked against a
wall, and in the nest farthest from the
door, there were 2 eggs.
Queen Coral hurried to the far nest and
roared again, a howl of fury and despair
that reverberated through the water.
She sank down beside the nest and picked
up a piece of broken eggshell.
Oh no.
Tsunami started forward, but Moray pushed
past her and knelt beside the queen
leaning against her side.
Enemone glanced back at tsunami, looking
sick.
One of the eggs was still intact, but the
other was smashed.
The little blue dragonette inside had
been strangled to death.
Her neck was twisted in a horrible way
and her head flopped sadly as Queen Coral
gently picked her up.
Tsunami stared at the body in shock.
It, she, was so tiny.
Who would do this to a baby dragonette?
How could anyone?
To my sister.
She felt anemone's cold talons slip into
hers and she squeezed them tightly.
Whoever it was, wanted to do this to
anemone as well.
This was why the queen insisted on the
harness and protected her daughter in
such an extreme way.
Seeing the broken body of the hatchling
tsunami felt nearly crazy enough to do
the same.
No one would ever, ever hurt anemone, not
while tsunami was around.
And whatever she had to do to protect
that other egg, she would.
Chapter 14.
Queen Coral rose to her feet, knocking
Moray aside.
She shot back across the cave to the door
but the skinny green dragon was gone.
Anemone yelped a stream of bubbles as the
queen blasted up the tunnel with her in
tow.
Tsunami started after them, then turned
and looked down at the last egg.
Moray had already followed Coral.
Whirlpool was hovering uselessly in the
doorway.
If tsunami went after Coral as well, who
would be left to guard the egg?
But no one can get in except through that
door, she thought, staring around.
That door from that tunnel.
So how did someone get past tortoise?
She turned in a circle, staring at the
smooth walls.
Come to think of it, how did webs get in
here to steal my egg?
Surely there had been guards back then
too.
Surely the queen had tried to protect her
eggs even 6 years ago.
Webbs couldn't have fought past them
alone.
So how did he get in?
Tsunami narrowed her eyes of the nests
and the stone dragon.
A secret entrance.
There must be.
Well, one thing was for sure.
She wasn't leaving this egg alone in
here.
She crouched beside the nest and gently
lifted up the last intact egg.
It was surprisingly heavy, or perhaps not
that surprising, considering a baby
dragonette was supposed to pop out of it
in a day or two.
Cradling the egg to her chest, tsunami
swam out the door of the cave.
Whirlpool flashed a whole lot of stripes
at her, waving his talons indignantly and
pointing at the egg.
Tsunami gave him a wide-eyed, puzzled
expression.
Maybe you should have taught me some real
aquatic sea slug, then you could yell at
me all you want, she thought.
He lit up his scales again.
With a friendly smile, tsunami lit up the
same patterns back at him, then added
squid brain, with her tail stripes, like
riptide had taught her.
She swam away up the tunnel, leaving him
gaping in surprise behind her.
As she swam up and around, she started to
hear shrieks of pain echoing through the
water.
She hesitated, then beat her wings
faster.
In the main entrance hall, Queen Coral
had tortoise pinned under her talons, a
crowd of sea wings had gathered, watching
in silence.
The skinny green dragon was shrieking in
one long, high pitched scream.
Tsunami stopped, and pressed herself back
against the wall, horrified.
Queen Coral had already yanked out each
of tortoises' teeth one by one.
They rose through the water, tiny and
white toward the roof.
Now Coral had her claws stabbed into
tortoises exposed underbelly.
Clouds of blood filled the water, nearly
hiding the queen and tortoise in a red
haze.
Would I have to do that?
If I were queen?
Could I ever, ever do that?
Anemone had rolled herself into a ball
floating in the water above her mother
with her eyes tightly shut and her talons
over her ears.
Queen Coral's scales lit up in a slow
menacing way.
Tsunami didn't understand most of it, but
she guessed tortoise was hearing about
how she'd failed the queen.
Tortoises' stripes flashed weakly.
The queen snarled and twisted her claws
harder into tortoise's underbelly.
Tortoise gurgled up a bubble of blood.
Her stripes flashed again, and then, as
her head began to loll sideways, she
spotted someone in the crowd around them
she clutched at the queen's talons and
pointed, her stripes flashing
frantically.
She was pointing, straight at Shark.
He stared back, unblinking as always.
Queen Coral leaned down, pressing
tortoise into the floor.
One more message flared through her
scales, and then she seized Tortoise's
head in her talons and smashed it against
the rough coral floor.
Tsunami turned away just in time, huddling
around the egg with her eyes closed.
She didn't care if she looked like a one
year old dragonette, hiding her face.
She did not want that image in her head
for the rest of her life.
What was tortoise saying about shark?
Whatever it was, hadn't convinced Queen
Coral anyhow.
Tsunami kept her eyes closed until she
felt the eddies from other dragons
swimming away.
She peeked around and saw Moray busily
cleaning up the blood and bone fragments
that were floating around the main hall.
Gross, tsunami thought.
Moray must really adore Coral to be
willing to do that.
Tortoise's body was hooked on an
outcropping of coral by the front door
like a used up deer carcass waiting to be
taken to the trash heap after dinner.
Queen Coral loomed over shark, clutching
anemone to her chest, and exchanging a
heated, luminescent conversation with her
brother.
All the other sea wings had scattered to
faraway parts of the palace.
Tsunami started toward her mother, but
stopped, as a strange shape flashed by
one of the windows.
What the?
That wasn't a dragon.
She swam a bit closer and peered out.
Sharks.
Actual dead eyed sharks with enormous
jagged teeth were swarming around the
front entrance, sniffing at the blood
that still leaked from tortoise's body.
They were bigger than tsunami had
expected, big enough to eat a dragonette
the size of anemone, she guessed.
But even as she watched, 2 sea wing
guards darted down and killed 5 of them
with a few blows of their tails.
She turned back, and saw whirlpool
swimming up to Queen Coral.
He interrupted her conversation, waving
his talons furiously and pointing at
tsunami.
Uh-oh.
Tsunami took a deep breath and held the
eggshell closer.
Well, I'm not giving this up.
Queen Coral swam over with a half frown
on her face.
She pointed to the egg and gestured
commandingly for tsunami to give it to
her.
Tsunami flashed her stripes in one of the
few patterns she knew.
I will protect.
She wasn't sure how to say it.
She pointed at the egg.
I will protect.
The queen blinked.
She lit up a few of her stripes, including
one pattern on her snout, the tsunami
recognized as how?
Tsunami shook her head.
She didn't have enough aquatic to answer
that.
I will protect, she said again.
She spotted the eyes of several sea wings
peering around doorways at her.
Most of them looked shocked and
disbelieving.
She saw her sister glance from tsunami to
the crumpled remains of tortoise, then
back again.
Anemones' face was pale and anxious.
Oh.
Tsunami realized what they were saying.
She was putting herself in Tortoise's
place.
She was taking the job nobody wanted.
She hadn't even thought of it that way.
Which meant, if she failed, she might be
punished the same way too.
Chapter 15.
Queen Coral tried flashing some more
questions at tsunami, but finally she
flapped her wings and pointed to the
surface.
Tsunami pressed the egg to her chest and
followed her mother up and up and up
through winding tunnels and cavernous
palace rooms, through emerald studded
coral, and pearl laced curtains of golden
seagrass.
They swam to the top of the palace, where
guards stood watch over a view for miles
underwater.
He saluted to the queen, and she swam up
past him toward the gray light overhead
where raindrops pelted the surface of the
water.
Anemone paddled in her wake, glowing like
a pale blue pearl in the dark sea.
They emerged into a storm so fierce, it
almost felt like they hadn't left the
water at all.
Tsunami faltered in the air as wind and
rain tried to sweep her back into the
ocean.
The egg was slippery in her talons.
Don't you dare drop it, she hissed to
herself.
This way, shouted the queen, banking
toward the nearest island.
A large cave yawned open onto the beach.
Rough, dirty and muddy.
It was still the driest spot they could
see.
The 3 of them huddled into its shelter.
What do you think you're doing?
The queen demanded.
As soon as tsunami's claws touched the
ground.
Someone has to protect this egg.
Tsunami said, it's not safe in the
hatchery.
It'll be safe in a hatchery if I put all
my guards on it.
Queen Coral fumed.
Tsunami shook her head.
Haven't you tried that before?
Has it ever worked?
She paused and glanced at her sister.
What did you do for anemone?
The queen shook out her wings.
I slept by the egg myself for the entire
year, she said.
You did?
Anemone said.
Rain dripped off her tiny pale wings into
puddles around her feet.
I barely left the hatchery.
I let Gil run the war for me, but that's
how I lost him.
Coral's voice caught and she frowned.
I can't neglect my duties as Queen.
Now that he's gone.
So let me do this, Tsunami said.
Let me protect this egg.
But you have to stay in the hatchery, the
queen insisted.
It must be kept warm, especially right
before hatching.
Tsunami glanced down at the egg.
She didn't trust the hatchery.
Anyone could sneak in to attack both
tsunami and the egg, especially if there
was a secret entrance.
Besides, she couldn't stay in the deep
palace, she had to go back and check on
her friends.
I have a better idea, she said, trust me
I'll take it back to the summer palace.
The Summer Palace?
The queen flared her wings.
No, you don't want to do that in this
weather.
It gets terribly flooded there during a
storm.
Better to wait out the rain here at the
Deep Palace, where you'll hardly notice
it's happening.
Flooded?
Tsunami echoed.
Do you mean the caves?
And the beaches?
Where my friends are?
Oh.
Queen Coral waved her claws
dismissively.
I'm sure they'll be all right.
Can't they swim?
Not like we can, tsunami said.
I'm going back to check on them.
With my egg.
Coral growled.
You've tried trusting everyone else
tsunami said.
Taking a step back toward the pounding
rain outside.
Now trust me.
I promise this dragonette will hatch
safely.
Her heart beat like the thunder in the
clouds.
Was this, finally, the right thing to
do?
Was she doing it for the right reasons?
Or was she being impulsive again, trying
to prove something instead of thinking it
through?
I'm doing this for my father.
I'm doing this to make up for all my
mistakes.
And I'm doing this to save my little
sister.
How can that be wrong?
If anything happens to that egg.
Queen Coral hissed.
I'll lose 2 daughters that day.
So much for being a special princess.
I need a harness for it, tsunami said
looking her mother in the eye.
See?
I'm not afraid of you.
Maybe you should think about how your
next queen will come to power before you
start threatening me.
The harnesses they were making for the
dragonettes.
Anemone piped up.
One of those should work.
How will you get back to the Summer
Palace?
Coral demanded.
You don't know the way, and my court is
staying here with me.
I'll find it, tsunami said, but a nervous
shiver went through her wings.
She did not want to be wandering the
ocean alone during a storm, especially
when her friend needed her.
If riptide is still out there.
Please let riptide still be out there.
Wait, she said, as the queen started for
the entrance.
I have a question.
Tortoise pointed at Shark while she was
dying.
Was she saying he attacked the egg?
Carl flared her wings, looking shocked.
Certainly not, she said.
My own brother.
He wouldn't dare.
She wasn't saying he killed the egg.
Anemone agreed.
She said he'd given her permission to
leave her post.
He brought her an octopus to eat.
The fool.
Coral gnashed her teeth.
I've told Shark, a 1000000 times that
vigilance is the only way to protect the
eggs.
If that means going days without eating
then that is what my trusted counselor
must do.
He's too soft with them.
Right, tsunami thought.
Soft is definitely how I'd describe
shark.
Well, tortoise didn't think anything
could happen, Anemone said.
Not while she was right outside the door
and only away from the egg for a few
moments.
Why didn't she stay with the egg to eat?
Tsunami asked.
Nobody eats inside the royal hatchery.
Anemone said primly.
It's a pristine hatching place designed
for royal dragonettes, and if you get
blood in the water, sharks will try to
find their way in.
Regular sharks who eat dragonettes and
eggs, that is, hatcheries other than the
royal hatchery get attacked by them all
the time.
Tsunami sugar head.
She couldn't help feeling like following
all these rules was only helping the
assassin.
And it was pretty convenient that Shark
had set toward us up like that, not to
mention giving himself a chance to sneak
in and kill the dragonette.
She shook out her wings.
Take me to the harness, she said.
Queen Coral reached toward the egg, then
stopped herself.
She gave tsunami another hard look, and
led the way out into the storm.
This time, they swam down through the
murky churning water, and around to the
back entrance to the palace.
The queen burst into a room that seemed
to be a workshop, where small sea wings
crouched over seagrass weavings and
marble carvings.
Tsunami paused as her mother thundered to
the far end of the room.
She lifted one of the weavings in her
claws and realized it was made of the
same material as the harness, rubbery
stretchy, and waterproof.
Only these were woven in colors, not
clear like the harness.
Queen Coral flared her stripes angrily at
a dragon who had frozen over a marble
carving.
He hurried into a back room and returned
with a tiny harness, flopping in his
talons.
Coral pointed at tsunami, and he took it
over to her.
This dragon was old, she noticed, and
shaking with fear as he tried to fit
straps around tsunami's neck and
shoulders.
They flapped loosely.
It was meant for coral and was too big
for her, and of course, the smaller
harness was supposed to fit a little
dragonette with limbs and a tail, not a
smooth round egg.
The old dragon gestured helplessly at the
harness, and Queen Coral poked it
growling a stream of bubbles.
The queen yanked anemone closer, and
pointed at the harness, flashing some of
the royal stripes in her wings.
Anemone hesitated, then reached out
unhappily and touched the harness.
To tsunami's astonishment.
The straps around her shoulders suddenly
shrank until they fit perfectly.
The other webs snaked and wove closer
until the egg was securely bound to her
chest.
She grabbed Anemone's talon.
Her sister felt cold and weirdly hard to
the touch, and her eyes were out of
focus.
Tsunami shook her, and anemone blinked
until she was looking at tsunami.
What?
Tsunami flashed the stripes on her
snout.
Anemone shook her head and made the
circular gesture.
Not right now.
We'll finish later.
Tsunami wanted to know more, but a
gesture reminded her of Shark and her
friends.
She had to get back to them.
Protecting this egg was important, but
watching out for the other 4 dragonettes
had been her 1st duty her whole life.
She bowed politely at the queen and the
old harness maker. then swam out of the
palace and back through the gardens she'd
seen on their way in.
She wasn't going unnoticed now.
Everywhere she passed, Sea Wings stopped
to stare.
Then lit up their wings and hurried
conversations after she went by.
She could sense them pointing at the
egg.
She wasn't sure if they knew she was the
missing princess, or if they only knew
she'd volunteered for the suicide mission
of saving the Queen's last female
dragonette.
She remembered swimming into the canyon
so she climbed out and swam around the
bend in the coral reef.
The deep palace disappeared behind her
and the wide dark ocean yawned in front
of her.
All right, you ask for this.
Now what?
Chapter 16.
Tsunami twisted around, hoping to see
something familiar.
To be honest, hoping to see riptide, but
the ocean was dark and wild, and it
seemed like everything alive had gone
into hiding until the storm passed.
So I figured out myself.
Tsunami set her jaw.
She patted the egg through the harness.
Don't worry, I can do this.
They'd ridden a current most of the way
here.
Did she have to fight it all the way
back?
She swam slowly forward until she felt
the water try to shove her away.
Maybe she could just keep a wingtip in
the current and follow it that way.
Several wing beats later.
She pulled away from the current to rest
exhausted and confused.
Why was this so hard?
Riptide?
Where are you?
Perhaps she could find her way back in
the air instead.
She just had to look for the island
shaped like a dragon skeleton.
How hard could that be?
Tsunami lashed her tail to power to the
surface.
She burst out into a pounding cacophony
of thunder and roaring waves.
Rain crashed down on her scales like
hailstones.
The wind immediately tried to grab her
and carry her off.
She fought to stay balanced and fly
straight, but she was already lost.
She could see an island to her left, but
she didn't know if that was the one close
to the deep palace, or if she'd been
swept to another, and whether it was on
the way back to the summer palace or
not.
A dark shape on the surface of the water
caught her eye.
She rubbed her snout, shaking off
raindrops.
Riptide?
She flew lower.
It wasn't a dragon.
It was some kind of odd vessel, like a
large bowl floating on the water, and
huddled inside of it were 2 scavengers
scrawny and soaking wet.
That doesn't help me at all, Tsunami
thought.
I'm not even hungry right now.
She beat her wings to soar upward again
and one of the scavengers looked up.
Its eyes were as green as glory's, in a
smooth face, the same brown color as
clay's scales.
Tangled dark hair snarled around its
shoulders.
Tsunami had seen a few scavengers up
close before, one in the mountains, and 2
in the Skywing arena.
It struck her again how dragon like their
eyes were.
It was sort of unsettling, really.
She wondered if they could breathe
underwater or swim, because these 2 were
about to get swamped and end up at the
bottom of the ocean.
Unless I help them, as if I have time for
that.
She hesitated.
Maybe all scavengers looked that way all
the time, but if she had to guess, she'd
say their expressions were terrified.
On the other hand, I might as well help
somebody.
Maybe it'll give me luck.
Tsunami swooped down and snatched up the
vessel in her talons.
It was heavier than it looked, and she
immediately dropped it.
The 2 scavengers let out their long
piercing bird shrieks as the vessel
smacked back into the water.
Oh, calm down, tsunami thought.
She flew around in a circle, fighting the
gusts of wind, and wrapped a front talon
around each scavenger.
They both shrieked some more and banged
uselessly against her claws.
How do scavengers accomplish anything?
Tsunami wondered, flapping toward the
island?
They don't seem to have any useful dragon
qualities, and yet they managed to steal
treasure and occasionally kill a queen
and start a war.
That's right, she remembered, giving the
scavengers a little shake.
I'm mad at your kind.
It's your fault all of this is
happening.
They screamed in a satisfyingly terrified
way.
On the other hand, it's pretty unlikely
that it was these exact scavengers who
killed Queen Oasis and set off the sand
wing war of succession.
So I suppose I'll let them live.
She dropped them on the island beach.
They staggered to their feet and fled out
toward the trees and the caves without a
backward glance.
Pathetic little creatures.
Tsunami's wings ached from fighting the
storm.
She had to try going back underwater.
She dove in with a splash and spun
searching the dark water again for
riptide.
Had he given up on her?
Was he hiding from the storm like a smart
dragon wood?
Figuring she'd be safe in a deep palace?
Well, there was one thing that had gotten
his attention before.
She opened her wings and lit up all her
stripes, like she had done in a tunnel.
The glow blazed through the water, and
then she shut them down again and
waited.
Nothing.
She tried again.
It gave her a bit of a headache, lighting
up all her stripes like that, and left
her dazzled blind for a few moments
afterward.
She'd done it sometimes for the other
dragonettes when the caves got too
depressingly dark, or Kestrel tried to
punish them by taking away all the
torches.
Glory hated that the most.
She couldn't stand the dark.
Tsunami thought about the summer palace
where there was no fire allowed except in
one cave, and all the light came through
the canopy up above.
Not much light could be filtering down
from the sky in the middle of the storm.
Her friends were probably sitting in the
dark right now, listening to the water
climb up the beach toward them.
I have to get back to them.
Tsunami thought.
Blazing all her stripes on again.
Right in front of her, Riptide flung up
his wings to shield his eyes.
Tsunami grabbed his claws and turned down
her stripes.
She jabbed her talent in the direction
she thought the summer palace was, Oh, why
don't I know how to say anything useful?
He rubbed his eyes and squinted at the
egg attached to her.
His expression said, something you forgot
to mention.
She whacked his tail with hers and
pointed again.
She remembered the pattern for urgent, and
lit it up.
Riptide nodded and began paddling toward
the surface.
We don't have time to chat, Tsunami
thought, frustrated, but she followed him
because she had no choice.
But before he reached the air.
Riptide swung around and slid into
another current.
As far as tsunami could tell, it went in
the direction of the summer palace.
He beckoned her after him, and tsunami
ducked into the current as well.
All right, I suppose I could have looked
for one of those.
Maybe traveling the sea wasn't about
being strong and fighting with it all the
time.
Maybe it was about trusting the currents
and knowing where they were.
Maybe it would just take time before she
figured them out.
She lashed her tail to keep up with
riptide as they swung around islands and
dodged billowing clouds of translucent
jellyfish.
The current sped them along, but the
journey still felt endless, and tsunami
couldn't stop thinking about her
friends.
She should have fought harder to make her
mother accept them.
How could anyone not trust clay?
Every thought he had was written all over
his big, sweet, goofy face.
And Sonny?
Those 2 were the most trustworthy of the
bunch.
Tsunami didn't think Sonny had ever had a
negative thought in her life.
She did what she was told, and happily.
She believed the best of everyone, even
Kestrel and Dune.
Which didn't say much for Sonny's
judgment or intelligence, but the point
was, the littlest dragonette would never
hurt or betray anyone.
Not even a bunch of sea wings she barely
knew.
Starflight was the opposite of Sunny.
Very smart, totally unreliable, terrified
of the world.
He tried so hard to know everything, just
so he could be useful in some way.
He wasn't brave, he wasn't a good
fighter.
He didn't even have any useful night wing
powers yet.
Most of the time, tsunami felt sorry for
him.
At least, when he wasn't trying to steal
her position as leader of the group.
But if Queen Coral would give him a
chance, she might see that his
intelligence could be really useful
especially in fighting the other tribes.
He probably knew more about the war and
the different tribes than any other
Dragon Empirea.
Glory.
Well, Coral didn't know it.
The glory was probably the least
trustworthy and most dangerous of all of
them.
Her secret venom proved that.
Tsunami curled her talons in.
In the Skywing Palace, why had Glory
waited so long to save her friends?
If she'd used the venom on Queen Scarlet
earlier, tsunami wouldn't have had to
kill her father.
Plus, she always talked like she didn't
care about the prophecy, then got mad
when other dragons pointed out that she
wasn't in it.
It was hard to figure out what she really
wanted.
And tsunami could definitely live without
her sarcastic comments.
But glory had saved them all, in the end
in the sky kingdom.
She'd killed to protect her friends.
And I notice nobody seems all mad at her
about that, tsunami thought bitterly.
Instead, I'm the crazy impulsive one.
Like, that's fair.
Still, if glory would do that for them
then Queen Coral should learn to trust
her too.
When mother gets back to the Summer
Palace, tsunami thought, I'll talk to
her.
I'll make sure she treats them like my
friends, not prisoners.
No matter how mad they made her, tsunami
didn't want anything bad to happen to any
of them, and after 2 days of sea wings
she had to admit she kind of missed them
even Starflight and Glory.
The spiral horn rocks loomed out of the
dark ahead of her, with a golden sea
grass curtain behind them.
Riptide paused at the rocks, swimming
backward as if he was going to leave her
there.
Tsunami wound her tail around his and
faced him.
Come, she said, wishing she knew the
patterns for please, and I might need
your help, and the queen is far away and
won't return until the storm is over.
But all she could say was, come.
Apparently, that was all she needed to
say.
Riptide nodded and gestured to the
curtain, letting her lead the way.
She unwound her tail and ducked through
into the tunnel.
The current in the tunnel felt faster and
heavier than before.
She splashed out into the summer palace
cavern and turned toward the beach.
The white pebbles had been swallowed by
the rising water, and the cave mouth was
already partly underwater.
There were no sea wing guards, and no
sign of her friends outside the cave.
Tsunami looked up, wondering if they'd
been moved to a higher cave.
But all she saw was a few curious sea
wing faces peering down.
Most of the dragons had taken refuge out
of the way of the dripping canopy.
Being all wet was wonderful, but having
your head splatted one annoying drop at a
time was not as much fun.
Tsunami paddled over to the beach and
felt the pebbles scrape under her claws
as she climbed up to the cave.
The water was only up to her underbelly
but she could tell it was rising
quickly.
It lapped around the egg, chilly and
unwelcoming.
And tsunami remembered that she was
supposed to keep it warm.
Hang in there, little sister. she
thought.
Not much longer.
Hello?
She called into the cave.
Her eyes adjusted to the darkness, and
she saw one giant lump of shadows piled
near the back.
Her heart lurched.
No.
Were those her friends' bodies?
Had she come too late?
Chapter 17.
A small head lifted up from the top of
the lamp.
Tsunami?
Squeaked Sonny's voice.
Are you all right?
Tsunami blurted.
She waited over and realized the bottom
of the lump was clay, stretched out in
the water, half submerged.
Lying on top of him was glory, and on top
of her was Starflight, and at the top of
the pile sat Sunny, well out of reach of
the water.
This is a terrible strategy.
Tsunami pointed out, as her friends
opened their eyes one by one.
She covered her relief that they were
alive by scolding them.
Seriously, whose idea was this?
Starflights?
Look, once the cave fills with water
you'll be stuck in here.
And even if it only covers clay, he can't
hold his breath for the entire storm.
Why haven't you moved to another cave?
Oh, Glory said icily.
The sea wing princess has time for us all
of a sudden.
It's only been a day, tsunami said
uncomfortably.
Mothers kept me busy.
Well, we feel so blessed that you found
time to visit.
Please to impart some more incredibly
brilliant wisdom on us.
Glory wriggled and twisted her neck to
glare up at Starflight.
Get your honking gray claws off my wings
before I bite you.
We can't go anywhere, tsunami?
Sonny said, as Starflight hurriedly
adjusted his position.
We couldn't leave clay.
She pointed down at Clay's talons.
Clay lifted his front talons with an
apologetic expression.
Silver chains ran around each ankle and
were bolted to rings in the floor.
He had them around his back talons as
well.
Shock stabbed through tsunami, followed
by fury.
Had her mother ordered this?
If so, she must have known Clay could
drown in the storm, and she didn't care.
She'd lied to tsunami that her friends
would be all right.
But maybe she didn't know.
Maybe this was sharks doing.
If that's the case, I'll rip him apart.
I knew you'd come for us, though.
Sonny said.
I mean, I thought you'd come yesterday, or
this morning, or when the storm started
but I knew you would come, eventually.
Well, I was pretty sure.
I was sure you wouldn't, Glory said.
Don't you have a feast or a coronation or
a beheading to attend?
She squinted at tsunami.
Is that an egg?
Wow.
They work fast in the kingdom of the
sea.
Who's the lucky father?
Glory, stop sniping at me for 2 seconds
please.
Tsunami said.
She slung the harness off and carefully
passed it up to Sonny.
Sunny, I need you to take care of this.
It has to stay warm, and you're the only
one who can keep it that way.
She hoped the natural warmth from a sand
wings scales would be similar to what the
egg would have in the nursery.
Me?
Sonny's voice was filled with delight.
You want me to do something important?
Really important?
Tsunami said.
That's the very last female dragonette
Queen Coral may ever have.
Somebody wants it dead, and we're going
to make sure that doesn't happen.
Sonny wrapped the harness around herself
twice and nestled the egg into our warm
scales.
When tsunami glanced up, she thought she
saw a pulse of dark blue moving inside
the egg.
So keep it warm and safe, and for
goodness sake, don't break it.
And don't let clay anywhere near it in
case he accidentally sits on it.
I would never play protested.
His stomach growled loudly.
Haven't they at least fed you?
tsunami asked.
We got some breakfast leftovers this
morning, Clay said with a sigh.
Very extremely tiny small crabs.
I am going to claw someone, tsunami
snarled.
So was Lagoon lying to Queen Coral, or
was she neglecting the dragonettes on the
Queen's orders?
Tsunami crouched to study the chains.
Did you try melting them?
She asked Sonny and Starflight, like you
did when you freed me under the
mountain?
Starflight leaned over and pointed at a
few blackened sections of the chain.
We tried, he said.
His voice sounded more deflated than
usual.
It didn't work.
This metal must be like the Skywing wires
reinforced in some way.
Tsunami heard splashing behind her and
whirled around.
But it was only riptide.
How do we get these off?
she demanded.
He rubbed his snout nervously.
You'll need the key from the guards, he
said, but they'll never give it to you.
We'll see about that.
Tsunami growled.
Hide if you need to, she said to
Riptide.
I might have to bring a guard back with
me.
By force, with my claws through his ears
she muttered, as she stomped out of the
cave.
Seawing faces disappeared all over the
palace when they saw her glaring around.
But she remembered the lower pavilion
level where she'd seen guards resting and
drinking from cauldrons.
She could see a few huddled shapes there
now.
Perhaps they assumed they could watch the
cave from over there, out of the rain.
Tsunami flapped over to the pavilion and
landed next to a large cauldron that
bubbled and smelled like green tea.
Four guards were clustered around a low
table, playing a game that involved
rolling fish bones.
They all froze when they heard her talons
thud down.
Slowly they turned toward her, and she
guessed by their guilty faces that they
weren't supposed to leave the cave.
She couldn't tell if they felt guilty
about leaving her friends to drown too, or
if they were only worried about how the
queen would react, when she found out
tsunami had sauntered right into the
Dragonette's cave.
Give me the key, she growled.
Ah, mumbled one of the guards.
What key?
Don't make me bite you, tsunami shouted.
The key right now.
She stepped forward, lashing her tail
threateningly.
Although all 4 of the guards were larger
than her, they quailed backward.
She wondered how many of them she could
hurt if she attacked quickly.
We can't. protested a 2nd guard.
We have orders.
Orders from whom tsunami demanded.
Our, our commander, said the 1st guard.
Shark.
They all nodded fervently, as if they
were hoping she'd now go away and yell at
him instead of them.
Too bad for him, tsunami said.
Key.
She held out her talon.
But we can't, said the 2nd guard again.
Tsunami studied his scales, looking for
weak spots.
She knew she was fast and strong, and she
was pretty sure she could knock 2 guards
over the side with her tail while she
clawed a 3rd in the face with her
talons.
Perhaps she could use her teeth on the
fourth.
She remembered the feeling of sea wing
scales, sliding under her claws, and
shuddered.
She'd looked at Gil this way too, in the
arena, sizing him up so she could defeat
him.
What was she about to do?
Hurt more dragons, just for being in her
way?
Dragons she didn't even know.
Dragons who could be her brothers.
Her cousins, Dragons who had families, who
were more than nameless guards to
somebody.
Maybe her friends were right about her.
The guards looked terrified, as if they
were waiting for her to attack them.
But they also knew what coral was capable
of, and surely shark as well.
Tsunami couldn't think of anything
scarier than what her mother had done to
tortoise.
She didn't really want to try.
So if she couldn't be more scary than her
mother, maybe there was another way.
Maybe she could convince the guards
instead of fighting them.
She remembered the dragons in the Skywing
prison, singing the song about the
dragonettes coming to save the day.
Maybe these guards were like those
dragons, believing in the prophecy
wanting it to come true.
Maybe she could use that instead of just
hitting them with her tail like she was
tempted to.
Listen, she said fiercely, don't you know
about the prophecy?
The guards exchanged glances.
She guessed that the prophecy had been
talked about plenty since the dragonets
arrived.
Great.
So do you remember anything in the
prophecy about a group of octopus heads
letting the mud wing drown before he
could save the world?
Did I miss that part?
She lashed her tail.
Do you want to be the ones who ruined
Pira's only chance of stopping the war?
No, blurted the 3rd guard.
The war has to end.
He ducked his head.
You saved my brother today.
When you sent him to have his wounds
tended.
She would have kept him standing there
for the rest of the council meeting.
Tsunami was shocked into silence for a
moment.
Was that true?
Did Queen Coral let soldiers die like
that?
For no reason?
Which one was your brother?
She asked.
He indicated his throat, the one with the
gash, and the blood coming from his
gills.
Oh, tsunami said.
What happened to his friend?
All the guards shook their heads.
Too late, said the 1st guard.
She crushed the fish bones between her
front claws and looked away.
We want to help you, said the 3rd guard.
But if we support a new queen before the
challenge is even made, it could go
really badly for us.
So, somebody does see me as a potential
queen, tsunami thought, pleased.
I told you, she can't be our new queen
said the 1st guard.
The dragonettes and the prophecy have to
be outside the war to stop it.
Besides, anemone is supposed to be our
next queen, growled the 4th guard.
You don't know what a prophecy means
argued the 3rd guard.
Maybe they're all supposed to rule their
tribes and stop the war that way.
That's not possible, insisted the 2nd
guard.
Two of them are male.
Tsunami got the feeling they've been
having this argument for a while.
The 3rd guard turned to her suddenly.
You tell us, he said.
What's your plan?
If you really are the dragonette of the
prophecy, How are you going to make it
come true?
Tsunami shifted her weight on her
talons?
That was the question she couldn't
answer.
The talons of peace hadn't taught them
what to do.
Nobody seemed to know.
As much as she liked to talk about how
the dragonettes would choose the next
sand wing queen.
She couldn't imagine how that would
work.
Who would listen to them?
Even if they went around the whole
continent saying, how about blister?
We like her, let's have blister win.
What good would that do?
It wouldn't stop burn and blaze from
fighting.
But some dragons believed in the
prophecy.
Soldiers, exactly like these four.
She couldn't let them see that she had no
idea what she was doing.
Listen, she said.
I don't know if I'm supposed to be the
next sea wing queen or not.
Sometimes I think Queen Coral is doing
everything right, and then sometimes, she
stopped, remembering tortoise.
Would anemone be a better queen?
One day when she was old enough, would
tsunami?
But I do know this, she went on.
We can't fulfill the prophecy without
clay.
He's the heart of our group, without him
the rest of us will fall apart, and we
won't be worthy of any destiny at all.
She stepped toward the 1st guard.
Whose expression was wavering between
belief and worry.
I know you don't trust Mudwings.
I know you obey Shark in everything, but
we're talking about the end of the war.
You thought nothing you ever did could
bring peace or save the dragons you care
about.
But right now, you can make all the
difference.
She took another step closer.
Just give me the key.
The guard twisted her talons together and
looked at the others.
Two of them nodded.
The 4th looked away.
Her tail twitching as if she wanted to be
left out of the blame.
I'll do everything I can to protect you.
Tsunami promised.
The 1st guard reached into a niche in the
table and pulled out a pair of heavy
silver keys.
She placed them carefully in tsunami's
talons.
Thank you, Tsunami said.
What are your names?
Snail, said the 1st guard.
She pointed at the others.
Flounder, herring, and kelp.
Please.
She paused.
If you do become queen, please remember
us.
Whatever she does to punish us.
Please, take care of our families.
And stop the war, Herring said fiercely.
Whatever you have to do.
Tsunami stepped back, curling her claws
around the keys, and saluted to the
guards.
She took off from the pavilion and flew
back down to the cave.
The water was nearly up to her wings by
now.
Clay was standing, watching the rising
water unhappily, with Sonny still perched
on his back.
Glory and Starflight were in the water
with riptide.
They both looked tremendously irritated
at how wet they were.
Hooray!
Sonny yelped when tsunami held up the
keys.
Wow.
Glory said.
Swirling waves of bright yellow shifted
through her scales.
I did not think that was going to work.
Tsunami plunged her head under the water
and lifted the shackles around Clay's
ankles.
She found the lock for the front talons
quickly, inserted one of the keys and
freed him.
The other key unlocked the chains on his
back talons.
Clay kicked them away and shook out his
wings as tsunami stood up again.
All better, he said, grinning at her.
His stomach roared in disagreement.
Well, almost all better, he amended.
Let's find somewhere dry, and I'll see
about food, tsunami said.
She herded them out of the cave ahead of
her.
Riptide paused, still in the shadows, and
she turned to him.
Thank you, she whispered.
You saved my friends.
I didn't do much, he whispered back.
I could never boss anybody into doing
what I want.
You're really good at it.
Well, tsunami said.
Sometimes bossing doesn't work, and you
have to try something else.
It'd be much easier if everyone just did
as I told them.
He laughed.
I should get out of here before someone
sees me.
She nodded and wound her tail around
his.
I'll look for you again tomorrow, if I
can.
There's a lot of aquatic.
I still have to learn.
He smiled, and slipped out of the cave
into the water.
She waited onto the beach and watched his
sky blue scales vanish into the
underwater tunnel.
She was glad she'd found at least one
dragon she could trust in the kingdom of
the sea.
Ooh, glory started.
Don't you dare, tsunami said, shoving her
into the lake.
The rain wing squawked indignantly and
flapped up into the air, showering them
all with cold droplets.
Rain was still dripping down through the
canopy, and small waves scudded across
the surface of the bay.
Let's try that cave, tsunami said
pointing to one far up the cliff.
If there's anyone in it, I'll clear them
out.
Glory snorted.
But the cave turned out to be empty and
dry, and once they all huddled into it, it
felt warm as well.
Sunny immediately curled around the egg
stroking it and murmuring to it.
Starflight blew a small spurt of flame
into the air to heat them up.
The dragonette can't hear you.
Tsunami pointed out to Sonny.
We don't know that.
Sonny said.
She might be scared.
I'm just telling her it's all right, and
we'll take care of her.
Tsunami hit a smile.
She was glad Sonny had agreed to take the
egg.
She'd been a little worried that the
little sand wing might still be too mad
at tsunami to want to help.
But maybe she'd forgotten about tsunami
attacking the Sky Wing soldier, or maybe
Sonny was always willing to help.
She didn't fight about everything just to
be difficult. like glory did.
Clay nudged tsunami with his snout.
We're happy to see you.
He said, tell us about the tribe.
Does everyone adore you?
Are they good fighters?
What do they eat?
He finished wistfully.
Let me find you some food first, tsunami
said, turning toward the cave entrance.
She was surprised at how warm and happy
she felt to be back with her friends
again.
This was how she'd expected to feel among
the sea wings, like she was coming home.
So why don't I?
Chapter 18.
Tsunami dropped three cauldrons on the
cave floor.
One packed with fish, one with clear
water, and one with a seaweed mushroom
salad.
She'd found them on the kitchen level
unguarded, so she thought they might as
well go to the dragonettes.
Sunny seized the salad cauldron and
shoved her nose into it.
Starflight peered at the fish, and then
without even asking the others if they'd
mind, he shot a burst of fire into the
cauldron, which left all the fish
blackened and smoky tasting.
Hey, tsunami protested, I like them raw.
Overruled, Glory said, raw fish is
gross.
Raw fish is awesome.
Tsunami insisted.
You have unreliable taste, said Glory.
You think your terrifying mother is
awesome.
She is not terrifying, tsunami said.
She's a wonderful queen.
That is what all the scrolls say.
Starflight pointed out, through a
mouthful of charred fish.
Tsunami looked up at the cave ceiling and
shifted from talon to talon.
Er, she said.
Well, apparently she wrote a lot of those
herself.
Really?
Starflight blinked in astonishment.
She's a writer?
I had no idea.
That's so, I mean, I wish I...
Do you think she'd read something?
I...
He stammered to a stop and fidgeted for a
moment with a cauldron.
It's cool, is all, he mumbled, shoving a
fish in his mouth.
Anyway, it's not just the scrolls.
Her subjects think she's a great queen
too.
Tsunami said loyally.
Most of them, I think.
Compelling, said Glory, except for the
part where she's killing off all her
daughters.
Tsunami stared at glory, to shocked to
respond.
Well, wait.
Clay said, that's just a theory.
A good theory, Starflight observed, with
her daughter's dead and no sisters
either.
No one will ever be able to challenge her
for the throne.
She could be queen for 100 years, and die
peacefully in her sleep instead of in
combat.
Sonny pulled the egg closer to her and
patted it reassuringly.
No, tsunami blurted.
You're so wrong.
She would never.
You haven't seen how protective she is.
I mean, look at how she takes care of
anemone.
Like a crazy dragon.
Glory interjected, waving a smoky fish at
tsunami.
It's a good way to make herself look
innocent.
Starflight offered.
Besides, think about when the murders
started.
He waited, with an isn't it obvious?
Look on his face.
Oh, dear.
Clay said, rubbing his head.
Did we really study this?
I don't know either.
Sonny whispered to him.
Starflight, tsunami growled.
Just tell us.
Very well, he said.
It was right after the only challenge
Queen Coral has ever faced.
Her 1st clutch of eggs had one female in
it.
Orca, tsunami guest.
Starfly nodded with a pleased
expression.
You do remember?
She challenged the queen almost the
moment she was full grown.
I'm sure Coral was more shocked than
anyone, especially when Orca almost
killed her.
Queen Coral only won by accident. impaling
Orca on that narwhal horn she has on the
end of her tail.
So, Tsunami said.
Why would that make her murder all her
future daughters?
Seriously?
Glory scoffed.
She saw how close she could come to
death.
She realized if she let any of her female
children grow up, she might be dead
within 7 years, much easier to kill them
all in their eggs, or as little
dragonettes, before they become a
threat.
Stop it!
Tsunami clutched her head.
It couldn't be true.
She's not like that.
She loves her daughters.
When she found the other egg broken.
Tsunami paused, realizing how much they
didn't know.
She backed up to tell them all about the
council, her mother's scrolls, the
mysterious dragon who'd tried to kill her
in the tunnel, and the way Queen Coral
had reacted when Tortoise failed her.
So you see?
She finished.
It can't be her killing off the female
dragonettes.
She wants them alive more than anyone.
Someone tried to kill you?
Clay said.
Are you all right?
I'd like to know what would have happened
to us if they'd succeeded?
Glory said angrily.
Are you saying Sonny's in danger now?
Starflight demanded at the same time?
Because of that egg?
Why would you do that to her?
I don't mind, Sonny said, cuddling the
egg to her chest.
But she looked paler than usual.
No, listen, tsunami said.
She took a step back toward the cave
entrance.
Don't you see?
We're doing a good thing by keeping this
egg alive.
And now Queen Coral has to take care of
all of us, because we're protecting her
daughter.
She can't chain you up and not feed you
anymore.
If that was even her idea in the 1st
place.
Glory and Starflight exchanged, yeah
right.
Glances.
Tsunami frowned at them.
And if we find the real assassin, she
hurried on, then we'll be heroes.
Not if it's your mom, Glory said firmly.
Which it is.
Tsunami wanted to kick her.
It can't be my mother, she said again.
The dragon who attacked me in the tunnel
didn't have a dragonette attached.
Where are you suggesting she stashed
anemone while she came after me?
And how could she have broken one of her
eggs when anemone is with her at all
times?
She could have sent someone else
Starflight said, or the attack on you
could be unrelated to the princess
murders.
Perhaps there's another reason someone
wants you dead.
Ooh, I have a few guesses, Glory said.
I think it's Shark, tsunami said, ignoring
her.
Tortoise pointed at him before she died.
He was at the deep palace before the rest
of the council.
If I'm right, and there's a secret
entrance to the hatchery, he could have
snuck in to kill the dragonettes without
anyone knowing, and he could have
attacked me in the tunnel too.
Queen Coral thought she'd sent him on
ahead already, so nobody knew where he
was exactly.
Tsunami, Clay said, nosing her with his
snout.
His forehead crinkled worriedly.
It doesn't sound like you're safe here.
Maybe we should go.
Or at least we should go.
Glory suggested.
You can stay here if you really want to.
We could leave now while no one is
guarding us.
Tsunami hesitated.
It was so much harder to fit in with a
sea wings than she'd expected, and she
didn't like seeing sides of her mother
that scared her.
She preferred the image in her head that
she'd dreamed about her whole life, the
loving queen from the missing princess.
She fingered the pearls around her neck
thinking of how Coral had given them to
her the moment she saw her, and how happy
she had been.
No, Sonny said unexpectedly.
I'm not leaving this egg until it
hatches.
She rested her talons on it
protectively.
And we can't split up.
We have to fulfill the prophecy
together.
I agree with Sonny, said Starflight.
I don't love it here either, but we have
to stay until we meet blister.
That was the whole point of coming here.
Not for me.
Tsunami thought.
She'd forgotten that blister would be
coming to meet the dragonettes.
She was not at all sure that was
something to look forward to.
Then, I think you should stay with us
Clay said.
Taking tsunami's talents in his again, so
we can keep one another safe.
That was what tsunami had planned to do
anyway.
But hearing it from Clay and seeing Sonny
nodding vigorously behind him, made her
feel much better.
They couldn't hate her too much if they
wanted her to stay with them.
All right, she said, as if he'd convinced
her.
Then I can help you protect the egg as
well.
You'd better.
Starflight muttered, glancing at Sonny
with a worried look.
They curled up together to sleep
sheltering the egg in the middle of their
pile.
Tsunami rested her head on Clay's
shoulder, and listened to the rain
pattering on the canopy far above them.
Last night, she'd slept underwater on
seaweed, and it had been the most
comfortable sleep she'd ever had.
But even though she was back in a cave
Something about the rise and fall of
clay's deep breathing under her snout was
more calming than any seaweed bed, or
pearl studded underwater palace.
It wasn't until she was almost asleep
that she remembered she'd forgotten to
tell the others about Kestrel.
Chapter 19.
Where are they?
Tsunami bolted awake out of a nightmare
about the last egg slipping through her
claws and smashing on a coral reef?
She blinked and checked under her wing.
Sunny was still curled neatly around the
egg, keeping it warm.
The little sand wing lifted her head as
if something had woken her up as well.
What was it?
Where are the dragonettes?
Where is my daughter?
Where is my egg?
Up here, called an unfamiliar voice with
a weird hiss to it.
Tsuname leaped to her feet.
A shape was coiled in the cave entrance
watching them.
Glittering black eyes met tsunamis.
A poisonous tail barb flicked up and
down.
White gold scales marked with black
diamond patterns caught the glint of
sunlight, now trickling through the
canopy.
The storm had passed.
And there was a sand wing watching them
sleep.
Tsunami didn't have to remember the
illustrations in their scrolls to guess
who it was.
She poked her friends with her claws.
Wake up, you lazy snoring manatees?
She hissed.
You're a lazy, snoring manatee.
Glory mumbled, with her wings over her
head, and you smell like one too.
You're going to feel very silly in a
minute.
Tsunami whispered crossly.
Oh, if you insist, Clay muttered, mostly
asleep, I suppose I could eat one more
hippo.
Clay!
tsunami yanked on his ears and he sat up
with a bewildered look, shaking his
head.
Aw, he said, his wings drooping.
What happened to the hippos?
Look.
Tsunami whispered, pointing toward the
cave entrance.
Her friends all went silent as they saw
the sand wing in the shadows.
Well, hello, said the stranger with a sly
smile.
Tsunami shivered, without quite knowing
why.
So nice to meet you.
I'm Queen Blister.
They're up here, she called again.
Staying dry out of the storm, I presume?
She went on conversationally.
Very wise.
I would have done the same thing.
A flurry of wing beats announced Queen
Coral's arrival on the ledge behind her
followed by anemone, and 3 sea wing
guards.
The queen poked her head into the cave
and saw tsunami.
Where is my egg?
She demanded, eyeing the other 4
dragonettes.
Safe and warm, like I promised.
Tsunami stepped aside and let her see
Sunny coiled around the egg.
Queen Coral hissed and lashed her tail.
You never said anything about a sand wing
touching my egg.
Oh, but think about it, Coral.
Blister interjected.
These are not ordinary dragons.
These are the dragonettes of destiny.
If they can't be trusted with our
future.
Who can?
She smiled again, but tsunami couldn't
shake a weird feeling of uneasiness.
Queen Coral took a deep breath, then
turned to blister with outstretched arms
and wings spread wide.
Queen blister.
My friend, she said, you got my message.
I'm so glad you came.
I knew you'd want to hear right away that
we found the dragonettes.
She waved her tail at tsunami and her
friends.
Tsunami squashed a flare of irritation.
Blister clasped Coral's front talons in
hers and quickly let go.
I was thrilled to hear it, she said.
And one of them was your beautiful
missing daughter, as we always
suspected.
I knew the talons of peace must have sent
webs to steal her.
Queen Coral said, Tsunami, say hello to
my ally, Queen Blister.
We've met, said tsunami.
She felt her friends behind her.
Starflight, frozen in fear, Sonny craning
her neck for a better view, Glory
studying her claws as if she wasn't that
interested.
Clay curious, but mostly trying to keep
his stomach from growling too loudly.
Then introduce your friends.
Coral ordered, smiling at blister again.
Clay, sunny, Starflight, glory, tsunami
said, flicking a claw at each of them as
she said their names.
Queen Cor frowned at her.
Marvelous, said blister smoothly.
All so brave and clever looking.
I heard you weren't a sky wing glory, but
that doesn't bother me.
Sky Wings are overrated.
Don't you agree?
Glory's wings twitched, and a ripple of
dark pink shifted across her stone gray
scales.
You heard?
Tsunami demanded.
How?
Nobody knew that except our 3 guardians.
They didn't even tell the other talons of
peace.
Anemone gazed at her from behind Coral's
wing, her blue eyes wide.
The sea wing guards shuffled on their
feet nervously.
Hmm, said Blister.
Her eyes flicked to tsunami and away.
Let's just say, I have friends.
Nightwing, friends.
She slithered up to Starflight, and
brushed one claw slowly down his neck.
So I've heard a lot about you.
The Nightwing Dragonette really looked as
if he might turn to stone and never move
again.
Tsunami would have kicked him if she'd
been closer.
Don't be so impressed by her.
We're the ones with the power.
According to the prophecy, we choose the
next sandwing queen and she knows it.
Blister glanced down at Sonny, who was
frowning.
Sweet, she said, chucking Sonny under the
chin.
And you must be the burly one, she said
to Clay.
She reached out and squeezed one of the
muscles in his forearm.
I, I, I guess.
Clay stammered.
I'm sure you've heard things about me too
Blister said, returning to Queen Coral's
side.
Her tail slid across the cave floor like
a snake, the poisonous tip rattling on
the stone.
But you can't always trust rumors and
propaganda.
Especially when it comes to a big
responsibility like the prophecy.
So ask me anything you like.
I'd be delighted to help you make your
decision.
Although, of course, I hope you'll choose
me.
Her glittering eyes swept over all of
them again, and back to Coral.
So, Coral, what's for breakfast?
Let me guess, Glory muttered.
Fish.
Clay blinked at the queen, hopefully.
Yes, what a good idea.
Let's go eat, said Queen Coral, and then
you can tell me the latest updates from
the war.
We hear something odd is going on with
the Sky Wings.
Anemone, tsunami, come.
Tsunami's gills flared.
She was not a baby dragonette to be
ordered around.
And she had no intention of leaving her
friends alone again.
Let the others come too.
Blister said, before tsunami could speak
up.
I'd love to get to know them better.
Carl wrinkled her snout at the
dragonettes.
All right, she said doubtfully.
You can leave that here.
Blister said, nodding at the egg.
No, Coral and Sonny said at the same
time.
The sea wing queen gave the little
dragonette a surprised look.
Sonny hugged the egg closer.
No way, she said.
It stays with me.
Blister shrugged, and Tsunami suddenly
wondered how she felt about new
dragonettes, who might threaten her
allies life.
Maybe it was in Blister's best interests
to make sure no one survived to challenge
Coral.
She certainly seemed sinister enough to
be the assassin.
The blister couldn't breathe underwater
so she couldn't get to the royal
hatchery.
She might be involved, but she couldn't
actually be committing the murders.
It had to be a fellow sea wing.
The feasting hall was 2 levels above the
kitchens, so the smells of pickled fish
and roasting seagulls, in honor of our
sand wing guests, Queen Coral explained
surrounded them as they arranged
themselves around the long, low oval
table.
Queen Coral's seat was higher than
everyone else's, but blisters, right
beside her, was not much lower.
Starflight was seeded to blister's right
with tsunami next to anemone on her
mother's left, on tsunami's other side
was Whirlpool, who played with his hoop
earring, slurped loudly as he ate, and
droned on about Coral's latest book, even
when nobody seemed to be listening.
Seawing guards were arranged around the
perimeter of the floor. interspersed with
sandwing soldiers, who had arrived with
blister.
The sea wings stamped their talons and
swished their tails, casting dark looks
at the sand wings.
Tsunami spotted snail and herring among
the guards.
Their eyes darted anxiously from side to
side, as if they were wondering how they
were still alive.
Because mother wants to make a spectacle
of them, tsunami guest.
Coral was probably waiting for the right
moment to punish them in public, the way
she'd punished tortoise.
Well, 2 can play the spectacle game, Your
Majesty.
Mother!
Tsunami declared dramatically, as the
wait staff said bowls of soup in front of
each dragon, beside her, Whirlpool jumped
and nearly tipped his bowl onto himself
even Queen Coral looked startled.
I have something dreadfully shocking to
tell you, Tsunami announced.
She wanted this to be loud, so every
dragon could witness it.
Oh, said Coral.
Could we discuss it after breakfast in a
civilized fashion?
No, tsunami said, louder than before.
This is too shocking.
Even Sea Wings not invited to the feast.
We're starting to peer out of their caves
and poke their heads out of the lake to
hear what was going on.
Well, perhaps Carl started.
Would you believe, tsunami said, that my
friends, the dragonettes of destiny
remember, were chained up and starved in
your caves by your dragons?
What?
Carl said. flapping her wings.
She looked thoroughly alarmed.
So Navi couldn't tell whether that was
because the news actually surprised her
or because she was being confronted
openly with what she'd done.
I know.
Tsunami practically bellowed.
It's unbelievable.
I'm sure you didn't know anything about
it, of course.
Of course, Carl said in a hurry.
I would never treat any dragonettes that
way, especially my dearest daughter's
dearest friends, who are part of the
prophecy and everything.
And I'm sure you'll want to punish the
dragons who disobeyed you by treating my
friends so terribly, tsunami said.
Right?
Like, for instance, the one who lied to
you about keeping them well fed, She shot
a glare at Lagoon, who froze with a sea
snail halfway to her mouth, suddenly
realizing what was going on.
Absolutely, said the queen.
Guards, throw lagoon in one of the
underwater dungeons.
But, Lagoon said, but I was only, next
time you'll obey my orders, said the
Queen.
A stripe quickly flashed under her wings
but tsunami spotted it, and it was one
riptide had taught her.
Silence.
Oh, mother, tsunami thought sadly.
Can't I even?
Lagoon said, reaching wistfully for her
cauldron of soup as the guards pulled her
away.
No breakfast for you, the queen ordered.
Think about how that feels as you sit in
my dungeon.
Tsunami was fairly sure Lagoon wouldn't
actually suffer very much.
Queen Coral would have her back at
council meetings before long, but tsunami
wasn't done.
And guess who ordered your guards to
chain up clay?
Tsunami demanded?
She flung an accusing talent toward
Shark.
Commander Shark.
Of all the dragons who should obey you in
everything.
Is that not utterly shocking?
It is, Carl said.
Tsunami thought she might be grinding her
teeth, but she hit it well.
I find it quite hard to believe.
Imagine the distress the poor guards felt
tsunami said.
When I explained to them that you would
never have ordered those chains on clay
to have to choose between their commander
and their queen.
Naturally they chose you, of course.
That's why they gave me the key to Clay's
chains, because they understood that's
what you would have wanted them to do.
Right?
Queen Coral gave tsunami an appraising
glance.
Beside her, Blister was eating her soup
with an amused expression.
Very good, Carl said slowly.
It sounds like those guards are
practically heroes.
And Shark tsunami prodded her.
To the dungeon with him as well, the
queen said with a wave.
Shark didn't protest like Lagoon had.
He snarled at the guards who approached
him, shot tsunami a look full of hatred
and headed off to the dungeon without
another word.
Splendid, Tsunami thought to herself.
It didn't guarantee that Snail and the
other guards would be safe, but surely
that had to make it more difficult for
Queen Coral to punish them for last night
not only that, but with Shark in the
Dungeon, even for only a day or 2, Tsunami
felt like she and her friends and the egg
would all be a lot safer.
Such excitement, Blister said.
If we're quite finished with our morning
theatrics.
I would love to ask you brilliant little
dragonettes about the prophecy.
Starflight can recite it for you, Tsunami
said.
He's really good at memorizing things, and
then repeating those things over and over
especially when no one cares to hear
them.
She shot a grin at Starflight, wishing he
would relax.
He looked too petrified to eat.
How splendid.
How impressive.
Whirlpool said from beside her, in a
voice of sincere admiration.
Tsunami wrinkled her snout at him.
He probably would get along well with
Starflight, now that she thought about it
but Starflight was not even remotely as
awful or annoying as Whirlpool.
I assume you have a plan about how to
fulfill this prophecy.
Blister said.
I mean, you must, right?
A tense hush fell over the feasting
table.
Ears were pricked all over the palace.
Every dragon empirea wanted to hear the
answer to this.
Tsunami felt like bees were crawling
under her scales.
Of course, they didn't have a plan.
They'd only recently escaped from under
the mountain, and then the Skywing
Palace.
They'd barely had time to stop and think
or even a safe place to do that.
And nothing they'd ever been taught had
prepared them for what they had to do.
Thanks for that too, talons of peace, she
thought bitterly.
But they couldn't admit that to all these
dragons, especially the ones who were
counting on them.
We are working on it, she said.
Obviously we can't say too much.
This is the information gathering phase.
Glory offered unexpectedly.
Blister gave Starflight a significant
look.
Um, he blurted.
But, we think you, of course, I mean
obviously you er, you'd make a great, uh
queen of the sand wings, that is, the
other two, hardly any competition
really.
It's um, a clear, so to speak, sort of, um
choice.
Starflight, tsunami said sharply.
What are you doing?
You don't speak for all of us.
Oh, said blister.
She narrowed her eyes at Starflight.
Then who does?
We each speak for ourselves, Glory said
before tsunami could answer.
Yeah, Sonny piped up.
And we haven't decided anything.
Tsunami said firmly.
She wished she were close enough to kick
Starflight and make him shut up.
I'm just saying she'd be all right.
He mumbled, subsiding.
Blister looked mildly disgusted.
You're quite right, Nightwing.
Coral said, patting blister's talent.
She is an excellent queen.
Blister smiled, but tsunami noticed that
she moved her talent away as soon as she
could.
She also noticed that blister called her
mother simply coral, while the queen of
the sea wings kept referring to her ally
as queen blister.
Tsunami wasn't sure she liked the way
they acted around each other.
Tsunami wanted to trust her mother's
choices.
She wanted to like blister.
It would be uncomplicated to choose
blister as the sand wing queen.
Then the dragonettes could stay safely in
the kingdom of the sea and support the
sea wing side of the war.
So why didn't she want to do that?
What was it about blister that felt so
wrong?
Oh, Queen Coral said.
Queen blister.
I meant to tell you, the strangest thing
happened.
We found a dead sky wing in our territory
the other day.
Oops.
Tsunami still hadn't told the others
about Kestrel, something new for them to
be mad at her about.
She sighed.
Really?
Blister said.
That sounds like good news to me.
Carl laughed.
You're right, that's true, but what's
really strange is she's been poison
stabbed by a sandwing, why would a
sandwing and a skywing be fighting all
the way out here?
Tsunami had known about the sandwing
poison.
She only remembered the blood pouring
from Kestrel's neck, her tail uncoiled as
she realized.
I don't have to worry then.
Mother will know it wasn't us who killed
her.
None of us could do that, not with
Sonny's useless tail.
At the same time, questions began
pounding in her head.
What sandwing would want to kill
Kestrel?
She scratched her gills, puzzled.
Had Bern found her and punished her for
what happened to Queen Scarlet?
But why would either of them be in sea
wing territory?
Blister shrugged, resettling her wings.
That is very peculiar, she said.
I wonder who she was, said Queen Coral.
She had these odd burn scars on her
palms.
Tsunami reached over Whirlpool and
grabbed for Sonny's forearm, but it was
too late to stop her gasp of horror.
Oh no, Sonny cried.
That sounds like Kestrel. tsunami?
What if it was Kestrel?
She pressed her claws to her snout?
Her eyes welling with tears.
A heavy silence fell over the table.
Every sea wing in the entire palace
seemed to be staring at sunny and
tsunami.
Queen Coral was giving tsunami a
particularly intent look.
Across the table, Glory and Starflight
both had their mouths open in shock.
Tsunami?
Carl said slowly.
Is there something you want to tell us?
All right, tsunami said squirming.
Yes, I'm sorry.
I saw her.
It was Kestrel.
Sonny let out a sob and buried her head
in her talons.
Clay patted her on the back awkwardly.
Your sand wing seems surprisingly
distressed about this sky wing.
Blister observed.
Kestrel was one of the guardians who
raised us, Tsunami said.
Although she wasn't very nice, Sonny.
She doesn't deserve your grief.
Sonny's wings trembled and she didn't
look up.
So, Carl said, leaning towards tsunami
explain this to me.
You recognized this sky wing, a sky wing
I have now been wondering about for days
and you chose not to tell us who she
was.
Why is that?
I didn't think knowing who she was would
explain anything, tsunami said.
I knew her, but I have no idea why she
was out here, or who killed her.
She glanced at glory and Starflight and
clay apologetically.
And I wanted to tell my friends first.
Kestrel wasn't a good parent, but she was
one of the only parents we ever knew.
I thought they should know, and I just
haven't had a chance to tell them.
I understand perfectly.
Blister purred.
She stroked Coral's talon with one claw.
Forgive her coral.
It can be very shocking, saying the dead
body of a dragon you know, especially
when you've probably wanted to slash your
throat yourself once or twice in your
lifetime, right?
tsunami?
I know I felt that way about my mother
most of the time.
Tsunami looked up slowly, her green eyes
meeting blisters, cold, black gaze.
How did she know?
Queen Coral had only said that Kestrel
was stabbed by a sandwing.
Tsunami clenched her talons under the
table.
So how did blister know that Kestrel's
throat was slashed?
Chapter 20.
Tsunami didn't know what to do.
Should she accuse blister of lying, of
murder, in front of all these dragons?
How would Queen Coral react?
Stop yourself, she thought.
Think.
Don't lash out immediately the way you
want to.
She shot a glance at Starflight.
He was smart enough to have noticed
Blister's mistake, and sure enough there
was a puzzled expression on his face.
He met her eyes and shook his head a tiny
bit.
Tsunami took a deep breath and let it out
slowly.
Perhaps he was right.
She might put her friends at risk if she
picked a fight with blister right now
better to wait and watch, and hope that
Starflight could use that giant brain to
figure out why in the world blister would
have killed Kestrel.
Blister's dark tongue flickered in and
out of her mouth.
She leaned toward Coral, smiled at
anemone and said, how is our secret
weapon coming along?
Anemone dropped her head and stared
unhappily at the table.
Wonderfully, Coral said.
She patted Anemone's head, beaming with
pride.
Why don't we show you?
Whirlpool?
Come along.
Whirlpool puffed out his chest and stood
up.
Curious, tsunami got to her feet at the
same time, but Queen Coral shook her
head.
Her pearls dancing in the green light.
You can skip this, dear.
I'm sure it won't interest you.
I'd like her to come, Anemone piped up.
Please?
Coral and Blister exchanged a significant
look.
They don't trust me, tsunami guest.
They don't want me to know about any
secret weapon until they're sure I'm on
blisters side.
Well, too bad.
I'm sure it'll be very interesting
Tsunami said, with earnest enthusiasm.
Everything you do is interesting, mother.
She blinked her large green eyes at Queen
Coral.
Across the table, Glory snorted, and then
tried to hide it with a bout of
coughing.
Please, Anemone said again.
All right, Carl said with a sigh, but not
the others.
Her gaze flicked suspiciously to clay.
Tsunami followed coral, blister, anemone
and whirlpool to a high level of the
pavilion she hadn't visited before.
It was shaped like a bowl, with low walls
and a slight slope down to the center.
Weapons were lined up along one side
white, twisting horn spears, like the one
attached to coral's tail, battle armor of
chain link, or scales hammered over more
scales, gleaming metal claws like the
ones scavengers carried in all the
scrolls.
None of the weapons looked particularly
special or secret.
But tsunami looked sharply at the wall of
weapons again, that battle armor.
Surely that was what her attacker had
been wearing in the tunnel.
That was why she hadn't been able to claw
him, or her.
She remembered her claws scraping
uselessly against metal, and one of the
vests definitely had a nick in it.
So who had access to this level?
Probably everyone, she thought ruefully.
May I?
Whirlpool said officiously, gesturing to
one of the strands of pearls on Coral's
wings, she dipped her wings so he could
remove it.
He strutted to the center of the bowl, and
carefully laid the rope of pearls on the
floor in front of him.
All right, he said, rubbing his talons
together.
See if you can make it crawl over to the
wall.
Tsunami looked around.
Who on earth was he talking to?
Where was the secret weapon?
Anemone sat down next to tsunami inside?
Do I have to?
she said.
It seems like a waste.
Tsunami stared at her.
Practicing is never time wasted, Whirlpole
said, wagging a claw in a way that made
tsunami want to snap it off.
But I don't want to end up like albatross
Anemone said.
She flicked her wings and edged a little
closer to tsunami.
He made an entire pavilion grow from
stone before he went mad and tried to
kill everyone.
Whirlpool said patronizingly.
You have a way to go before that
happens.
Now, the necklace, please.
Anemone sighed again.
She held out her front talons and to
tsunami's amazement, the necklace began
to slowly wind toward the wall, moving in
curves like a snake.
Oh my gosh, tsunami blurted.
Suddenly everything made sense.
The magic in whirlpool's title, the self
adjusting harness in the deep palace.
Anemone.
You're an animus.
Anemone dropped her talons, and the
necklace stopped moving.
I know, she said, with an expression like
she would rather be descended from sea
cucumbers.
We've had a few animas dragons in the
royal family.
Carl said proudly, but not in several
generations.
Anemone was hatched just in time to help
us win this war.
Careful, Blister said with a hiss.
She doesn't have to know our whole plan
to guess. that an animus dragon would be
very useful in battle.
Coral said.
There are lots of marvelous things we can
do with this power.
Yes.
Watch this, Whirlpool said.
He picked up a metal armor breastplate
and flung it up in the air over the
edge.
Catch it with a spear, he called to
anemone.
None of the spears moved.
The breastplate plummeted toward the
lake.
Sorry, anemone said, not looking very
sorry.
You didn't give me enough warning.
Ow!
Someone yelled from below.
Anemone.
Whirlpool said with a sigh.
Battle is all about quick thinking.
How would you know that?
she said.
He frowned at her.
Try it again, Queen Coral said, clapping
her front talons together.
And this time, do as you're told
anemone.
Whirlpool flung another flat piece of
metal armor into the air, instantly, one
of the narwhal spears shot after it and
pierced it through.
Blister and coral applauded, but tsunami
thought it was more interesting that the
spear then carefully brought the armor
back to rest safely on the floor.
Impressive, Blister said, but not much
more impressive than what I saw last
time.
What about progress?
What about bigger objects?
How much longer must this training go
on?
I'm sure she's nearly ready, said Queen
Coral.
Years, lots more years, Anemone said at
the same time.
Blisters forked black tongue slipped
through her teeth, and she narrowed her
eyes at anemone.
Coral.
She said, tilting her head.
Stay here.
Coral ordered She slid as far away as the
harness would reach, and crouched with
her wings spread, whispering to blister.
Whirlpool strutted over to tsunami and
anemone, anemone gave him a glare, and
suddenly the pearl necklace he'd left on
the floor, whirled around, whipped under
his belly, and soared off the ledge.
With a yelp, the green dragon raced after
it, diving over the edge.
This is what you have to save me from
Anemone whispered quickly.
Boring lessons with Whirlpool?
Tsunami answered.
Sure, I'll get right on that.
No, not just that, Anemone said, wrinkling
her snout, although he is awful.
All he ever asked me to do is make things
move.
I can enchant any inanimate object to do
my bidding, and he's like, make this
spear dance.
Now make that chair walk from here to
here.
It's insulting, really.
What else could you do?
Tsunami asked.
She glanced at coral and blister, but
they both had their backs turned and were
sharing their own secrets.
According to blister.
I should be able to enchant the sky
kingdom's palace to cave in on all the
sky wings.
Anemone said softly, looking up at
tsunami.
She also wants me to curse a spear, so it
will search for Burns' heart and not stop
until it kills her.
Tsunami coiled her tail closer.
Try not to look as shaken as she felt.
If anemone could do either of those
things, she really was a secret weapon
power like that could end this war in a
week.
I don't know for sure if I can do any of
that.
Anemone said, I'm scared to try, I don't
want to try.
Every time an animus dragon uses her
power.
She loses a bit of herself.
Tsunami's sister held out her talons as
if they might not really be hers.
Albatross was a prince, and a hero at
first, but they didn't know about the
price of animus magic then.
Building the pavilion turned him evil.
She slipped one talon into tsunami's
grasp.
It felt colder than ice and hard as
stone.
I don't want that to happen to me.
How can I possibly save you?
Tsunami wondered.
Even she was tempted by the kind of power
that could bring peace so quickly.
But she couldn't ignore the fear in
Anemone's eyes.
First, I'll catch the dragon who's trying
to kill us, she said, curling one wing
around anemone.
Maybe then, mother will let you off the
harness and start to trust you more.
Maybe she'll listen when you tell her you
don't want to use your power.
Ha, Anemone muttered.
Tsunami didn't know what else to say.
She had no words of advice ready for
dealing with strange magical problems, but
she did have a lot of other questions for
anemone, and this might be her only time
to ask them.
Can I ask you a question?
she said.
If none of Coral's daughters survived, who
would be queen after her?
Anemone flicked her tail around and
studied the end of it.
Who knows?
I don't think a queen has ever died and
passed on the throne peacefully, at least
not in our kingdom.
And who else would challenge her?
I heard Uncle Shark say once that maybe a
son should inherit.
But I guess it would probably be our
cousin Moray, except she doesn't want the
job.
She wants Coral to be queen forever.
At least, that's what she says.
You don't believe her?
Tsunami asked.
There's just something weird about her
Anemone said.
Isn't there?
It's like, she must be faking, because
nobody could really act like that all the
time and mean it.
Maybe, tsunami said.
But I think the assassin is Shark.
I bet he wants Moray to be queen, and if
none of Carl's daughters survive, it'll
have to be her.
Anemone snorted.
Moray would rather die than challenge the
Queen.
Tsunami saw Queen Coral's wings flutter
closed.
In the meanwhile, she whispered quickly.
Keep acting like you need more training.
Make mistakes sometimes if you have to.
Make them think you aren't ready for as
long as possible.
Mistakes.
Anemone said with a sigh.
Why didn't I think of that?
Queen Coral slid back to them, twisting
our snout from side to side.
Where's Whirlpool?
she asked.
I think he lost something.
Anemone said innocently.
Queen Blister wants you to try.
Carl started, but stopped as the
Sandwings head suddenly went up.
Blister stared around the cavern, poised
in her eerie stillness, nothing but her
eyes moving.
Tsunami felt hypnotized by her.
Anemone and coral were equally silent
waiting.
Blisters gaze slowly lifted to the canopy
of leaves and vines overhead.
Then tsunami heard it too.
Something was moving around up there.
Something big.
Chapter 21.
Queen Coral hissed softly.
I'll call my guards, she said.
Wait.
Blister lifted one claw.
Her voice barely stirred the air.
We want to catch whoever it is, not scare
them away.
She flicked her tail.
Come.
Quietly, she slid over the side of the
pavilion, and flew to the cliff wall.
Coral and Anemone went after her, and
tsunami followed close behind.
She wasn't sure she'd been invited, but
she didn't care.
Blister landed on a ledge beside the
tallest waterfall.
The water spilled out of a hole high
above, nearly at the level of the
canopy.
It rushed in torrents down the cliff wall
dividing around boulders, and sending out
small clouds of spray.
And it was loud, loud enough to hide the
sound of their wing beats, as the 4 of
them flew higher, staying close to the
falls.
She is clever, tsunami thought, glancing
at blister.
Why does that make me more nervous about
her instead of less?
At the top of the waterfall, the sand
wing hovered for a moment, studying the
canopy with her glittering dark eyes.
From this high, the dragons far below
looked like lizards, scurrying around the
pavilion and swimming in the lake.
Tsunami spotted whirlpool, paddling
frantically in circles with his talons
outstretched.
He was still trying to catch the pearl
necklace as it twisted away from him.
The canopy was thick and green, with
vines twisted together over centuries, and
leaves the size of dragon talons.
Up close, tsunami could also see small
blue flowers shaped like broken eggshells
shining in the small sunlit gaps.
Something stirred the leaves.
Something was crawling through the vines
not far from the edge of the cliff.
Something the size of a dragon.
A spy, Queen Coral hissed under her
breath.
Suddenly blister darted up into the
leaves, quick as a cobra striking, she
sank her talons into the hidden dragon
and ripped it out of the canopy.
In the same movement, she whirled and
threw the dragon as tsunami.
Startled, tsunami reached to catch him
and found herself face to face with
webs.
Webbs, one of the guardians from the
talons of peace.
The trader who had stolen her egg from
the royal hatchery, who had never taught
her the underwater language.
She barely had time to register the
terror on his face before he slammed into
her, and they both crashed into the cliff
wall.
He flapped his wings, pulling back, and
she caught her breath as she righted
herself.
Oh, blister said, sounding disappointed.
It's just a sea wing.
Not just a sea wing.
Queen Coral seized Webbs by his neck and
shook him.
Her green eyes were sparks of rage and
triumph.
This is webs.
Our tribe's biggest traitor.
I've been looking for him for years.
Your majesty, Webbs croaked.
He scrabbled at his throat.
Please, I've come to beg for mercy.
Mercy.
Coral Hist.
After what you did.
She shook him again harder.
Mercy denied.
She flung him into the air and slammed
her tail into the side of his head with a
horrible sounding crack.
Webbs went limp.
His eyes closed, and he plummeted toward
the lake below.
Webbs, tsunami yelled.
She knew she should hate him too
considering the life he'd forced on her
but she found herself diving after him.
All over the summer palace.
Sea Wings stopped to look up, gaping at
the side of a dragon falling from the
sky.
None of them moved to help him.
Tsunami beat her wings desperately trying
to catch up.
Would he die if he hit the water from
such a height?
Clay, she shouted.
Clay, help.
Clay immediately burst out of their cave
blinking and befuddled, but ready.
Catch him!
Tsunami shouted, pointing.
Clay shot away from the cliff, banking
around to intercept Webb's body as he
fell.
The 2 dragons collided in midair, and
Clay tumbled, trying to hang on to the
heavier, larger dragon.
But he slowed him down enough for tsunami
to catch up.
She lifted webs from the other side until
his front half rested on Clay's back, and
his back half lay across her shoulders.
Carefully, she and Clay struggled over to
the pavilion, collapsing on the 1st level
they could reach.
The library, as it turned out.
Webbs sprawled across the black and blue
talon prints, his head lolling to the
side.
Blood trickled out of one ear.
Wake up, tsunami said, shaking him.
Come on.
You can't die, not before I get a chance
to yell at you.
Where did he come from?
Clay asked.
Bump, bump, bump.
The other 3 dragonettes landed around
them.
Glory looked down her nose at Webbs, dark
green, zigzagging through her wings.
Sonny crouched beside his head.
The egg was cradled underneath her, making
it hard for her to get too close, but she
reached out and touched his snout with
one front talon.
Webbs?
She said softly.
What are you doing here?
Search the area.
Tsunami heard Queen Carl's voice barking
orders.
Make sure there are no more talons of
peace lurking around.
She spat out the words talons of peace, as
if they tasted like rotten fish.
Tsunami glanced up uneasily at the canopy
overhead.
Where a dragon-sized gap now yawned in
the green leaves.
A bolt of sunlight shone through, and she
couldn't help but worry what else might
find its way through the protective cover
had blister thought about that at all
before she struck?
Surely she wouldn't deliberately endanger
her allies, but maybe she didn't care
about them enough to treat their defenses
cautiously.
Queen Coral swooped into the library, her
face majestic with fury.
She loomed over webs as blister, anemone
and moray all arrived behind her.
Why would you save his life?
The queen hissed at tsunami.
After everything he did to you.
I don't know, tsunami thought.
Why didn't she want Webbs dead?
It had been instinct that sent her flying
after him.
Maybe I want to give riptide a chance to
meet his father, like I never really got
to.
Or maybe I'm not ready to lose our last
guardian yet.
For most of her life, she'd only known 7
dragons, and 2 of them had died in the
last 10 days, that seemed like more than
enough to her.
I thought he might have information we
need.
She lied, maybe about the talons, or
blister interjected smoothly.
Perhaps now we can find out how he snuck
into the royal hatchery to steal the
egg.
Clever dragonette.
Tsunami must get her brains from you.
Queen Coral hissed and glared down at
Webbs.
I suppose interrogating him would be
useful, she said.
More, wake him up.
Morey dove over the edge and returned
with a large clamshell full of seawater.
She threw this in Webb's face with no
particular gentleness.
Sonny let out a little yelp and jumped
away from the splash.
Webbs coughed and sputtered, and snorted
water back out his nostrils.
He sat up slowly, holding his head, and
gingerly wiping his snout dry.
His gaze landed first on the dragonettes
and tsunami was surprised to see his
whole face light up with joy.
He stared from clay to glory to
Starflight, as if he couldn't believe
they were all alive.
He held out his front talons, and Sunny
clutched the one closest to her, smiling
back at him.
But the sky wings, he said.
I thought you were dead.
How did you?
We escaped.
Glory said coldly.
No thanks to the talons of peace, tsunami
added.
Or stupid, unhelpful morrow seer.
It was amazing, Sonny said.
You should have seen us.
We will tell you about it some other time
Clay interrupted.
Sunny looked up at him. then over the sea
wings, and snapped her mouth shut.
Webb saw Queen Coral and the thunderous
look on her face, and blister coiled
menacingly behind her.
He shuddered, then winced as if that had
made his head hurt even more.
Welcome back.
Coral snarled at him.
I thought you were too cowardly to ever
return here.
I know, I am not worthy of your mercy.
Your majesty, Webb said.
Staggering to his feet so he could kneel
in front of her.
But I heard, I hoped.
Why did you steal one of my eggs?
Queen Coral demanded.
You could have stolen from any other
dragon in the kingdom of the sea.
Tsunami's wings twitched.
And that would have been all right.
Are you only angry because he stole from
you?
Not because a dragonette's life was
ruined?
It had to be an egg due to hatch on the
brightest night, Webb said, in a wavering
voice.
And it had to fit the prophecy.
The sea wing egg of deepest blue.
I'd seen your eggs when I was guarding
them before I, before I left.
You mean ran away, Carl snarled.
In the middle of a battle.
Looking at webs.
Tsunami couldn't believe he was Riptide's
father.
Riptide was so much stronger and braver
than this shivering old dragon.
I remembered her egg.
Webbs pressed on, his wings drooping.
It was so blue.
It had to be the right one.
I'm so sorry, Your Majesty, he said in a
rush, but the prophecy is so important, I
would never have betrayed you for
anything else, but for peace.
How could I not do as the talents asked?
So how did you get into the hatchery?
Corals tell lashed threateningly.
I had guards posted at that door every
moment until the eggs hatched.
Tsunami leaned toward him.
If he knew of a secret way in, surely
that would point them to the Dragonette
killer.
Webbs hung his head.
I drugged the guards, he said.
I, I knew someone who helped me slip a
sleeping potion into their evening meal.
They were asleep when I crawled in and
out again with the egg.
It wasn't their fault.
Well, Coral said dismissively.
I killed them anyway.
As for the someone who helped you.
Your wife, I assume?
Webb flinched.
I wondered about that, Carl said.
Her expression was mildly pleased, as if
she was finally putting the pieces of an
old puzzle into place.
Stupid of her not to run away with you.
Of course, that's why she was reassigned
from the kitchens to active duty in the
war soon after.
Too bad that 1st battle was such a
bloodbath.
Webbs looked as if all the light had been
scraped out of his scales.
Sonny made a woeful, sympathetic noise
and edged closer, twining her tail around
his.
Even glory looked a little sorry for
him.
Tsunami had never thought about webs
leaving behind a family until she met
Riptide.
Even then, she hadn't pictured him
abandoning a wife and baby dragonette.
Maybe he really did care about the
prophecy more than anything, if he was
willing to give up so much for it.
She would not have made the same choice
herself.
Now I know the dragonettes are safe, Webb
said quietly.
So you can do whatever you like to me.
I will.
Coral rumbled.
We can start with you telling me where to
find the talons of peace.
Why?
Tsunami asked, as Webbs shook his head.
Why would you want to find them?
Coral showed all her sharp white teeth?
Revenge, dear?
They stole from me, and no one has ever
gotten away with that.
Now I must hunt them down and exterminate
them.
Don't you have more important things to
do?
Tsunami demanded.
I think they're awful dragons, yes, with
a really misguided sense of how to raise
dragonettes to fulfill a prophecy.
But all they want to do is end the war.
Isn't that what everyone wants?
We're not trying to end the war.
Blister said in her slithering voice.
We're trying to win it.
I hope you can see the difference.
But killing the talons at peace won't
help with that.
They haven't heard anyone but us 5
tsunami said, waving her talons at the
other dragonettes.
In fact, Starflight said, out of the
blue.
They almost certainly saved tsunami's
life.
The Nightwing froze as everyone turned to
stare at him.
Queen Coral hissed menacingly.
Even Webbs looked confused.
What?
Coral growled.
Well, Starflight stammered.
The, the, the other female dragonettes in
her hatching all died.
The same way every one of your potential
heirs has died.
Whoever is killing them.
Webbs took her egg away before the
assassin could get to it.
If her egg had stayed in a hatchery, she'd
be dead.
By stealing her, he, and the talons of
peace. actually saved her life.
Uh, right?
Tsunami felt like she was shape shifting
all of her bones being shoved from one
skin into another.
No.
The talents of peace ruined my life.
I've always known that.
It's the truest thing I know.
They didn't save me.
But she knew in her scales. that
Starflight was right.
They did save her.
By accident, but they did.
Webbs did.
She remembered all her dreams of how her
life should have been if she'd hatched
here and been raised by her own mother.
None of them would have happened.
She'd have been dead within the 1st week
her neck snapped, like the sad little
dragonette in the eggshell.
Your majesty?
The small messenger dragon from before
urchin tsunami remembered, tumbled out of
the air and skidded to a stop at Queen
Coral's claws.
He bowed as low as he could, covering his
head.
We found a suspicious dragon lurking
outside.
He must be working with webs.
Bring him to me.
Queen Coral growled, in a voice that rang
off the cavern walls.
Urchin pointed down at the tunnel, and
they all leaned over to see Piranha and a
troop of sea wing soldiers dragging
someone into the summer palace.
They heaved him out of the water to fly
him up to the queen.
His webbed talons flocked to the side.
His eyes were closed, and a claw mark
slashed along his sky blue scales was
bleeding heavily.
Tsunami's stomach flipped inside out like
a jellyfish.
It was riptide.
Chapter 22.
Webb's green scales paled nearly to gray
as riptide was tossed onto the floor
between him and Queen Coral.
No, he cried.
He had nothing to do with this.
He's never had any contact with me.
Moray tossed another clamshell of water
over riptide, and he groaned, shielding
his eyes.
It's true, tsunami said desperately.
Ribtide wasn't here with webs.
He's, he's been helping me.
Um, with my aquatic.
It was true, but it sounded like a lie
even to her own ears.
Whirlpool is supposed to teach you that
not this miserable creature, Queen Coral
said, with narrowed eyes.
Whirlpool is a horrible teacher, tsunami
flared.
I'd be better off taking lessons from a
barnacle.
Riptide pushed himself slowly up to
sitting.
He glanced around at all the faces
staring at him.
His gaze stopped on webs, and the 2
dragons looked at each other for a long
moment.
Admit your treachery.
Said the queen, betrayal runs in your
family after all.
She swiped at Riptide's snout, but he
stepped out of reach.
Pirana hissed and poked him in the side
with a narwhal spear.
Don't hurt him, tsunami said.
Please, he's not working for the talent
of peace, I promise.
She was surprised to see Riptide wince.
He looked down at his claws, avoiding her
eyes.
Was there something he hadn't told her?
Throw them both in the new prison?
Carl said with deep disgust.
We'll find out what we need to know about
the talents later, when I'm feeling a
little more violent.
Don't you have one more question for
them?
Blister interjected.
She'd been quiet for so long, it made
tsunami jump to hear her voice.
Carl swung her head to look at the sand
wing.
Why, they killed all of your heirs.
Blister purred.
I mean, obviously.
It was them, right?
Obviously, Coral burst out, she glared at
webs and riptide.
Working together.
Blister murmured, it's the perfect climax
to the story.
It is Coral agreed.
No, tsunami said.
That makes no sense.
Just like one of your brilliant
mysteries.
Blister went on, ignoring tsunami.
The claws of murder, for instance, or a
tale of blood.
That one was genius.
It was, Carl agreed, even more
fervently.
They're the perfect murderers.
It all fits.
No, it doesn't, Tsunami shouted.
Why would they do that?
There's no motive.
Of course there is.
Carl snarled.
Blister, explain it to her.
So that tsunami could return as the only
living heir, of course.
Blister said smoothly.
If they killed off all the other possible
airs.
She would become more and more valuable, a
bargaining chip, if they ever needed it, a
powerful tool when they wanted to use
her.
Nobody uses me.
Tsunami spat.
Wait, webs can't be the murderer, Clay
said.
His large brown head tilted to the side.
He hates killing other dragons.
That's why he ran away from you in the
1st place.
Nonsense, Queen Coral said, waving a
talon.
He ran away to protect his own scales.
Even so, I'm not sure that theory works
Starflight said, gazing vaguely into the
air as if he was trying to solve a math
equation.
The princess murders started 2 years
before they stole tsunami's egg, so the
talons, and especially webs, wouldn't
have known they were going to steal a
royal egg at that point.
Webbs didn't even know he was going to be
a talent at that point.
And Webbs has been underground with us
for the last 6 years.
He couldn't have flown here and back
every time he wanted to murder a
dragonette.
Starflight shook his head.
No, I'm afraid it doesn't.
His eyes met blisters, and he abruptly
slammed his mouth shut.
What he said, tsunami said desperately
exactly.
So, his allies in the talons of peace did
his dirty work, Blister said, unperturbed
you know it makes sense, Coral.
The talons have been your enemies for so
long.
Of course, it would turn out that they're
the ones behind the murders.
It's the ending that wraps everything
together.
Coral nodded.
Her talent twitched toward the nearest
scroll, as if she couldn't wait to write
all this down.
Why are you doing this?
Tsunami demanded.
Stepping closer to blister.
Why pin the murders on Webbs and riptide
unless you're covering your own tracks?
Blister gave a hoot of laughter.
It doesn't matter to me what happens to
sea wing princesses.
She said, except that I feel my poor
allies, pain, of course.
I'm merely pointing out the obvious to
her.
These 2 should be executed for their
crimes as soon as possible.
You want webs dead, tsunami thought, and
you killed Kestrel.
I'm sure of it.
But why?
Brilliant, just brilliant, Coral said
clapping her talons together.
Take them away, and we'll plan their
execution later.
Piranha and her guards closed around webs
and riptide.
Tsunami didn't have a chance to say
anything more to them before they were
dragged off, and riptide still wouldn't
meet her eyes.
She cleansed her talons and frustration.
You know what this means?
Coral went on, delighted.
We can return the egg to the royal
hatchery.
It's safe now.
It isn't, Sonny cried.
She wrapped her talons around the egg.
It certainly is, said the queen, with
webs locked up.
The egg can hatch in the royal hatchery
just like it's supposed to.
You're wrong, tsunami said.
I'm not risking a dragonette's life
because you've fallen for this crazy
story. blister has invented.
Blisters, obsidian black eyes glittered
malevolently at tsunami.
It will be perfectly safe, Coral said
waving her claws.
Besides, every queen in sea wing history
has hatched in the royal hatchery.
Silence prickled between them, Tsunami
was thinking, I didn't.
And surely Coral was too.
You'll eat those words when I'm Queen
tsunami thought.
But she wasn't sure she meant it
anymore.
Did she even want to be queen here?
Especially if it meant allying herself
with blister, or breaking away from her
and then dealing with the consequences.
Only one dragon could change Coral's mind
about the egg.
Tsunami glanced at blister and realized
at least one thing was true.
Blister couldn't care less what happened
to the sea wing airs.
She was studying her claws, looking
slightly bored.
Fine, tsunami said, squaring her
shoulders, but I'm staying with it until
it hatches.
Queen Coral tilted her head.
In the royal hatchery, she said.
All night.
I'll make sure she hatches safely, tsunami
said.
She glanced at the egg, glowing blue and
green below the white shell.
The dragonette was close to hatching
pressed against the thinning walls.
Every once in a while the egg rocked in
Sonny's arms.
But when I catch the real murderer
tsunami went on, I want you to promise
that you'll let riptide and webs go
free.
Ha!
Carl snorted.
Webbs will never be free again.
Even if I save your last air, tsunami
demanded.
Coral scraped your claws across the
rock.
You won't have to, she said.
We have the assassins now.
So it should be an easy bargain to make
tsunami said.
Blister stared at her coldly.
All right, Coral said, waving one talon.
I'll promise you riptide, but Webbs has
too much to answer for.
Tsunami noticed blisters settling back.
So it was definitely webs she wanted dead
not riptide.
That was the best she could do for now.
She'd have to think of another way to
save webs.
But tsunami.
We should stay together, Clay protested.
We can't protect you down there.
And whoever's coming after the eggs will
be just as happy to kill you too.
Glory pointed out.
Tsunami shook her head and flexed her
claws.
Not if I catch him first.
Part three.
Out of the egg.
Chapter 23.
It was pitch dark in the royal hatchery
dark, and horribly quiet.
Tsunami could see in the dark, of course
but everything was gray and a little
blurry.
The only flashes of color came from the
eggs when the dragonettes inside moved.
Across the cave, she could see the 3 male
eggs peacefully leaning against one
another, they had nothing to worry about
guards were stationed outside the door
but tsunami was the only one in the
hatchery.
As soon as the door closed behind her, she
prowled around all the walls, poking
everything that stuck out, and hoping a
hole would suddenly yawn open in the
floor.
She circled the statue of orcas several
times, shoving at its talons and tail and
pedestal, but nothing happened.
There was no sign of a secret entrance
anywhere.
Finally, she curled up beside the egg and
stared fiercely around the room.
All right, assassin, she thought, I'm
ready for you.
She had a narwhal spear lying on the
floor beside her.
Although she had no idea how to use it
but she wouldn't be taken by surprise
again.
The warm jets of water billowed silently
up through tiny holes in the coral
surrounding the eggs in a bath of heat
and small bubbles.
It was a little too hot for tsunami, but
she didn't want to move away from the
egg.
She poked her nose underneath it, checking
again for a secret trap door.
But the floor was smooth and polished
like the egg itself.
A flutter moved in the eggshell, like a
heartbeat, as the dragonette inside tried
to stretch her wings.
Tsunami rested her front talons on it for
a moment.
She wondered if Sonny was right that the
dragonette could hear them.
She pressed her snout up to the egg and
whispered through the water.
Don't worry, I'm here to protect you.
The tiny wings fluttered again.
Tsunami leaned closer, wishing for some
noise, some light in the hot, silent, dark
room.
Scrape.
Tsunami's head shut up.
Stillness, darkness.
And yet, she had a creeping feeling that
someone was suddenly in the room with
her.
Screw...
Her scales tingle between her wings as if
squirrels were scuttling down her back.
She stood up and flexed her claws.
The one door to the hatchery was closed.
The eggs were still.
The only movement in the room was the
blip of small bubbles rising from the
floor.
But wait, the statue.
Hadn't it been facing the door before?
She stared at it until her eyes hurt.
Had it turned its head?
Was it looking at her?
Tsunami's whole body was shaking.
She blinked through the darkness at the
statue of Orca.
The statue stared back.
Its eyes were sapphires, she remembered
but in the shades of gray here, they
gleamed as obsidian dark and vicious as
blisters.
She was sure the statue had been facing
the door when she came in.
But now, its head was turned toward her
and the egg, watching them darkly.
Impossible, she started to think, and
then scrape.
Scrape, scrape.
Stone claws curled around the top of the
pedestal.
A stone tongue flicked between jagged
shark like teeth.
Nobody's sneaking in Tsunami had a moment
to think.
The assassin's already here.
She's been here all along.
And then the statue hurtled off the
pedestal, talons reaching to snatch the
egg.
Tsunami flung herself between the statue
and her unhatched sister.
Green marble claws raked tsunami's neck
heavier and thicker than a real dragon's
like shards of rock stabbing between her
scales.
One caught in her gills and ripped a
wider hole, blood bubbled out as tsunami
shoved the statue away.
Sorry, broke the rules.
Blood in the hatchery.
Tsunami thought dizzily.
She staggered back, pressing one talon to
her neck.
How could she fight a statue?
How could anyone beat a dragon of solid
stone?
It attacked again.
Relentless as the tide.
The statue plowed into tsunami and
knocked her backward.
Its weight bore down on her, crushing her
against the floor.
She struggled, clawing at its snout, but
her claws scraped uselessly against
marble and sang with pain.
The statue was trying to walk over her
willing to trample her on its way to the
egg.
One foot came down heavily on tsunami's
chest, and she felt tiny crack, crack
cracks stabbing through her ribs.
You are not getting to that egg.
Tsunami reached up and wrapped her front
talons around the dragon's snout.
She yanked it down toward her, dug her
claws into the eye sockets, and popped
the 2 sapphires free.
They tumbled into her palms, gleaming and
heavy.
The stone dragon didn't roar in pain or
collapse, or any of the things tsunami
had been hoping for.
It stopped, swung its head from side to
side for a moment, and sat back on its
haunches, lifting its weight just long
enough for her to wriggle free.
She took a deep breath, thick with
gurgling blood, and yelled, help, as loud
as she could, even muffled by the water
surely a scream would be heard by the
guards outside.
Help, help.
If there were still guards outside.
Queen Coral, convinced of her own theory
might have promised them to tsunami and
then sent them away, certain they
wouldn't be needed.
Whether they couldn't hear her or weren't
there at all.
Nobody came.
The statue felt its empty eye sockets
curiously, then padded the floor around
it, as if it thought its eyes might have
accidentally slipped out.
Tsunami took a step back and dropped the
sapphires through 2 of the water jet
holes.
She needed all the advantages she could
get.
Carefully, she reached over the egg and
picked up the narwhal spear.
Would this do anything against stone?
The statue flicked its tongue in and out
tasting the water.
Slowly, it turned its sightless face
towards tsunami.
She knew an animus dragon must have
cursed the statue, but she didn't know
how these enchantments worked, would
blinding it stop it?
Or was it set to keep trying, to kill no
matter what, until all the royal heirs
and the hatchery were dead?
She guessed it was enchanted to kill only
when it was sure no guards were around, no
queen, no one to witness its crimes and
stop it from striking again.
But tsunami was an heir.
She wasn't a witness.
She was a target.
It stepped toward her.
The floor trembled a little at the weight
of each talon coming down.
Tsunami wanted to lead it away from the
egg.
If she could open the door, would that be
enough to turn it into a frozen statue
again?
Or if there was no one there, would it
chase her into the palace?
But she was afraid to leave the egg, even
for a moment, the statue was fast.
It could crush the egg with one foot and
keep chasing her without missing a beat.
And if she tried to carry the egg with
her, the statue could crash down on both
of them, shattering it easily.
It was safest in the nest, as long as
tsunami stood in front of it.
She hefted the spear and pointed it at
the dragon.
Normal fight rules didn't apply here.
She could try piercing the eye socket, but
there was no brain in there to skewer, no
heart to find through the scales, not
even the vulnerable spot on the tail all
dragons had.
The statue's snout lifted.
It's empty eye holes as dark as deep sea
canyons.
Was it smelling her?
Tasting her in the water?
Or could it hear her?
Whatever it was doing?
It seemed to know exactly where she was
eyes or no eyes.
The statue leaped straight at her.
She braced the spear against the floor
and the statue's chest slammed into it.
Jarring shock thrummed through tsunami's
talons as if she'd been stabbed in both
palms.
The statue ricocheted back, and tsunami
saw bits of dark green stone crumble away
into the water.
So maybe it can be smashed into little
pieces.
The statue came on again, fast, but this
time reaching out in front of it.
Tsunami tried to move the spear out of
its reach, but it caught the narwhal horn
in its front talons and yanked it sharply
out of her grasp.
It swung the spear around in an arc, and
tsunami had to duck and roll away to
avoid being skewered.
The only sound the statue made was the
scraping of stone against stone.
It didn't roar, or growl, or grunt like a
regular dragon in battle.
It was as horribly silent as the rest of
the hatchery.
Tsunami wondered if it could talk, or
hear, or communicate in any way.
Can you hear me?
She shouted at it, throwing caution to
the currents.
Who enchanted you?
Instead of answering, it tossed the spear
aside and leaped at her once more, tsunami
dove underneath it, grabbed the spear, and
whirled to put herself in front of the
egg again.
She couldn't smash the statue while it
was moving.
It was too fast and too strong.
But if she could trap it somehow.
The statue spun, and crashed its tail
into her side.
Tsunami was knocked off her feet, flying
through the water into the wall.
Crack, went something in her chest, and
stab, went another bolt of pain through
her whole body.
Breathless, she forced herself back to
the egg, jabbing at the statue with a
spear to push it away.
It reached for the spear again.
This time, she tilted the spear up and
stabbed it violently into the statue's
open mouth.
The spear lodged in the stone and stuck.
The statue's claws scrabbled along the
shaft of the horn and tried to yank it
out, but it was wedged in tightly.
Tsunami shook the spear from side to side
and the statue's head wobbled along with
it.
She leaped to an empty nest and jammed
the blunt end of the spear into one of
the crevices.
Now the statue was pinned like a sheep in
a dragon's claws.
It whipped its tail and beat the floor
with its talons, trying to push itself
free.
Its wings thrashed the water into wild
currents, so tsunami could barely stay
upright.
Tsunami fought her way back to the egg
and picked it up.
Just as she did.
Tap, tap, tap.
The egg cracked down the middle, and a
small green head poked out.
Dark green eyes blinked at tsunami.
Tsunami smiled, and flashed a few tiny
stripes along her snout to say hello.
The statue was writhing and smashing the
floor now.
Tsunami was afraid it would knock itself
free in a minute.
She clutched the dragonette and swam for
the door as fast as she could.
When she kicked it open, she found that
indeed, there were no guards outside.
But as the door opened, the statue went
still.
Tsunami turned in the open doorway to
look at it.
The enchantment only worked in secret.
It dropped away when the door was open.
Whoever had said the curse didn't want
anyone to look in and catch the statue at
its deadly work.
Tsunami guessed that the spell also
alerted the statue when someone was
coming down the passageway, so it
normally had time to return to its
pedestal.
And the statue would remain still, as
long as anyone else was around, like the
queen, or her guards.
This statue was meant to keep murdering
dragonettes for as long as it could.
Well, not anymore, tsunami thought
fiercely.
Even Queen Coral would have to believe
the truth.
Once she saw the statue as it was now
Marble Orca, once serene and regal on her
pedestal, was trapped by the spear in
battle position.
Her claws reached out hungrily, and a
snarl transfigured her face.
Coral would know for certain that this
was the killer who had been hiding in her
hatchery all these years.
Now the question was, who had enchanted
it?
An animus dragon of course, but it
couldn't be anemone, who hadn't hatched
yet when the princess murders began.
Tsunami had a new theory.
Animus power runs in the royal family.
But if shark or moray had this kind of
power, they would be using it for so much
more.
They would use it to fight battles, to
win the queen's favor, to be the secret
weapon she wanted so badly.
If Shark's goal was the throne for his
daughter, he'd have used his magic to get
rid of Coral herself instead of knocking
off her dragonettes.
And if the animus was Moray, she'd have
offered her power to the queen long ago
for coral to use however she wanted.
No, it was another royal dragon.
Tsunami was sure of it.
She stepped back into the room, leaving
the door open.
She remembered Coral's words.
My 1st daughter was a very talented
sculptor.
Tsunami settled the newly hatched
dragonette around her neck, wincing at
the pain from her gills.
Orca may have died years ago.
But she left a deadly gift behind.
Carefully, she stepped over the nests and
stared into the statue's face, empty
lifeless.
Just a statue now.
A statue that she and Coral would be
happy to smash and smash and smash until
it became a 1000000 of the smallest
pieces of rock in the ocean.
Orca's weapon would never assassinate
another dragonette or crush another egg.
Its killing days were over.
Chapter 24.
Bright morning light filtered through the
canopy, casting puddles of green sunshine
all across the Summer Palace.
Tsunami opened and closed her wings
grateful that she didn't have to be at
the council meeting with a blister that
was going on overhead.
After last night's battle in the hatchery
Tsunami just wanted a break from scheming
Dragon Queens and war plans for a little
while.
The little emerald green dragonette
romped on the beach, kicking up sand and
stopping in surprise when it drifted into
her nose, she sneezed hard enough to
knock herself backward, then sat up and
gave tsunami an indignant look.
Well, stop putting sand in your nose then
tsunami suggested.
Her little sister shook herself, spotted
a tiny crab digging in the sand, and
pounced.
The crab vanished into its hole, and the
dragonette looked at her empty talons in
confusion.
What's her name?
Sonny asked.
She leaned into tsunami's side for a
moment, and tsunami felt a fizz of relief
in her chest.
Sonny had forgiven her, or forgotten she
was mad in the 1st place.
Either one was fine with tsunami.
I'm trying to think of the perfect name
Tsunami said, Mother said it was up to
me.
The dragonette glanced up from her
digging.
Sand covered her snout like a mustache.
Maybe you should call her walrus.
Glory offered, dissolving in giggles.
She's not a walrus.
Tsunami said.
She's much more dignified than that.
The dragonette jumped at an insect in the
air, lost her balance, and landed with
her head in the sand and her tail
sticking straight up.
She flailed her wings furiously until
Sonny gently lifted her free.
Very, glory said, very dignified.
She's awfully cute, Clay said, I think
she has your snout, tsunami.
Tsunami flicked her tail, pleased.
She looked around proudly and noticed
that Starflight was sitting a short way
from the rest of them.
He was staring up at the pavilion with an
anxious expression, running sand through
his claws.
Glory followed her gaze.
She leaned over and poked the night wing
sharply in the ribs.
What's going on with you?
Glory demanded.
Why are you crawling around licking
blisters talons?
I'm not, he protested.
You really are, tsunami said.
Starflight wouldn't meet their eyes.
I just think she'd be a good queen, he
mumbled.
No, you don't, Glory said.
Back under the mountain.
You specifically said she was kind of
evil and probably had sinister plans for
all of Pyria.
Oh, you did say that, Clay agreed.
He poked a hole in the sand for the
dragonette to climb into.
I remember that.
Starflight flashed him an annoyed look.
That, you remember?
So why do you suddenly love her so much?
Tsunami asked.
Her little sister rolled into the hole
and then jumped back out, flapping her
wings to shake off the sand.
Blisters smart, Starflight stammered.
She's, uh, she's better than burn or
blaze.
I don't like her.
Sonny said to tsunami's surprise.
Really?
Starflight said, his wings drooping.
Sonny shook her head.
She called me sweet, like that's all
anyone needs to know about me.
But you are sweet, Clay said, patting her
head.
It kind of does sum you up, tsunami
agreed.
Sunny scowled at both of them in a way
tsunami thought was pretty cute.
But I agree that I don't like her
either.
More than that, I don't trust her.
I think we need to meet Blaze.
Maybe all the stories about her
brainlessness have been exaggerated.
Doubtful, said Starflight glumly.
So, we can go?
Glory asked tsunami.
And look for Blaze?
You mean we're done here?
Even the baby dragon stopped digging for
a moment to look at tsunami.
She felt a stab of guilt at the hopeful
expressions on her friends' faces.
Jan realized they wanted to leave the
kingdom of the sea so badly.
Wing beats sounded in the air above them
and they all looked up to see Coral
Anemone, Blister, and Moray, circling
down from the Summer Palace pavilion.
The green dragonette scampered up to
Anemone as soon as she landed, and
tackled one of her talons, and Emone
laughed and flipped her over.
Their little sister yelped, struggled
upright again, and started clawing her
way up Anemone's leg.
Have you picked a name?
Anemone asked tsunami?
What do you think of Aucklet?
Tsunami said.
That's a kind of seabird.
Starflight said, in his know it all voice
to clay.
Oh, Clay said.
Cool.
I mean, I knew that.
Tsunami liked the look on her mother's
face watching the 2 sisters.
She looked proud, protective, happy for
them.
Tsunami was right about her.
Queen Coral wouldn't kill her own
daughters, even though one of them would
one day grow up to take her place.
She cared about them.
Perhaps a little too much, but tsunami
thought that was better than not caring
at all.
She wondered if blister or burn had any
dragonettes.
Starflight would know.
It must be in the scrolls somewhere.
Tsunami had a feeling blister would
happily kill off her own dragonettes if
she thought it was necessary.
Those glittering black eyes hid more
secrets and plans than tsunami wanted to
know about.
Orca's statue has been destroyed.
Queen Coral said with a sigh.
It was so beautiful too.
She was so talented.
I can't believe she hid her animus powers
from me.
She could have trained with Whirlpool
too.
Wow.
She really missed out, tsunami said
winking at anemone.
We'll have to examine all the things she
carved, coral mused, just to make sure
there aren't any other enchantments
lurking around.
We are sure it was Orca, right?
Tsunami asked.
No one else in the palace could be an
animus.
She wasn't able to stop herself from
glancing at Moray, who glared back.
Coral shook her head. before we destroyed
it.
Anemone reanimated the statue and made it
reveal who had enchanted it.
It said Orca, plain as day.
She sighed again.
Orca carved that statue, and dedicated it
to the hatchery shortly before she
challenged me.
I gather she expected to win, so she was
setting up a way to get rid of her
possible airs and challengers.
That explains her last words to you, Moray
hissed.
Yes, said Carl sadly.
She said, I did this all wrong.
You're going to rule forever, aren't you
Mother?
You should thank me.
No one can stop you now.
The queen looked down at anemone and
Aucklet, playing in the sand.
She stroked Anemone's head with a wistful
expression.
But, Clay said hesitantly.
But if Orca was the assassin, then who
attacked tsunami in the tunnel?
Queen Coral shrugged, We'll catch them
eventually, she said.
That's how stories work.
Anemone gave tsunami a frustrated look.
Tsunami still thought that her attacker
might have been shark.
He was already out of prison, patrolling
the summer palace with a bad tempered
expression on his snout, and he certainly
hadn't been pleased or supportive when
she staggered out of the hatchery with a
dragonette, blood pouring from her
gills.
She reached up and touched the seaweed
bandage on her neck.
Her ribs ached whenever she moved too.
But the healers said she just had to rest
and let the fractures fix themselves.
Rest?
The dragonettes of destiny have no time
for rest?
she thought ruefully.
Now that we know the real assassin
tsunami reminded Coral, you promise to
set riptide free.
I know I did, said the queen, but I'm not
quite sure what to do with him.
Clearly he can't stay in my kingdom.
He'll have to crawl back to those talons
of peace and see if they'll take him.
Maybe he can come with us, tsunami said
then snapped her mouth shut, but it was
too late.
Coral and blister were both staring at
her in a very uncomfortable way.
With you, Coral said slowly.
Are you going somewhere?
We, I, yes, I think we should, tsunami
said.
She felt her friend shifting closer
together behind her.
I don't belong here, mother.
I wanted to, but I'm only causing trouble
and I'm not doing what I was hatched to
do.
I don't speak the underwater language.
I don't understand the council.
You have 2 daughters now who could be
great queens one day.
She nodded at anemone.
But my destiny is somewhere else.
I have to go stop the war.
With my friends.
And how do you plan to do that?
Blister said softly.
I don't know, Tsunami said.
We'll figure it out.
We were thinking we should go meet
Blaze.
Clay suggested, just to be fair.
Acc, clay, shut up.
Tsunami thought with a wince.
But it won't change how we, I mean, that
we think your Starflight said hurriedly
to blister, then trailed off under
tsunami's baleful look.
No, said Blister.
The diamond patterns on her back writhed
as she stepped closer.
No one is leaving.
You can't tell us what to do.
Tsunami said.
I am your choice.
Blister hissed.
The nah.
The talons of peace want me.
Oh, Glory said.
Do they know that?
It's not their decision anyway, tsunami
said.
Your lives could be very easy from here
on. said blister.
All you have to do is tell everyone the
dragonettes of destiny have chosen me as
the next sand wing queen, and you can do
that from here, where I can keep an eye
on you.
Where you can keep us prisoner, you mean
tsunami said angrily.
We've had quite enough of that, thank
you.
Mother, tell her you wouldn't do that to
me.
Queen Coral gave blister an anxious
look.
My dear, I'm sure they will still choose
you after meeting Blaise.
No one would choose her in a 1000000
years.
Perhaps.
But 1st they have to survive that long
Blister said smoothly.
You know better than anyone how dangerous
it is out there, Coral.
Remember what happened to Gil.
We'll really be protecting the dragonette
by keeping them here.
Oh, that makes sense.
Coral said, sounding relieved.
She's right, tsunami.
Just stay here and we'll take good care
of all of you.
Tsunami looked back at her friends.
Starflight looked miserable, but the
others, they looked hopeful, as if they
trusted tsunami to get them out.
This isn't the right place for my friends
either, tsunami said.
Glory wants to go home.
Right, Glory?
And Sonny should find your parents.
It's not fair that I get to do those
things and they don't.
We just.
She squared her wings.
We have to go.
And if you try to keep us, you'll be no
better than the Talons or Queen Scarlet.
Blister glared at Starflight.
Don't you have something to say about
this Nightwing?
He stared miserably at his talents and
didn't respond.
She hissed, Useless.
There is something wrong with all of you
isn't there?
But you're the dragonets I have, and I'm
not letting you go.
Blister turned to Coral.
Throw them in your prison.
She wouldn't do that, tsunami said.
Mother?
Right?
You wouldn't do that.
It might help your decision.
Blister hissed.
If you knew exactly who killed your
husband in the Sky Wing arena.
Tsunami felt her scales turn to ice.
This was it.
The moment her secrets came out, and she
got what she deserved.
Coral's gills flared and her eyes
widened.
What are you saying?
You know he died in the arena, Blister
said.
But do you know who his opponent was?
The dragon who ripped the life out of
him.
Maybe you should also know, Starflight
said suddenly.
That blister killed Kestrel and is lying
to about it.
And that she wants Webbs dead for her own
reasons and doesn't care about your
daughters at all.
Blister arched her neck like a cobra and
hissed at him.
Starflight threw his wings over his head
as if he expected her tail to come
stabbing down, but all she said was
you'll be sorry for that, useless night
wing.
Coral wrapped her wings around anemone
and Aucklet, and took a step back toward
the water.
She looked from blister to tsunami, like
she wasn't sure who to trust anymore.
Don't listen to them, Coral, Blister
said.
They're only dragonettes, and dragonettes
never know what's best for them.
I think we can be pretty sure prison
isn't at the top of the list, though
tsunami snapped, and from now on, blister
you show some respect, and address my
mother as queen coral.
Smoke curled from blisters, snout.
Tsunami wondered what coral would do if
the sand wing attacked the dragonettes of
destiny right in front of her.
I don't know what's going on, Coral said
signaling with her tail, a platoon of sea
wing guards appeared from one of the
caves, but for your own safety tsunami.
You're staying here for now.
Mother, Tsunami yelled.
She smacked a guard in the snout with her
tail and bared her teeth at another.
Think for yourself for once.
Let us go.
The Queen Coral turned away, avoiding
blisters gaze as well.
She curled Aucklet into one of her talons
and flew back to the pavilion with her
daughters.
Tsunami fought the guards, but there were
too many of them, and her ribs were still
screaming with pain from the night
before.
One by one, each of the dragonettes was
overpowered and dragged off to the same
prison cave where riptide and webs had
disappeared the day before.
Seawings watched from all over the
pavilion.
Tsunami had never been so humiliated.
Some dragonettes of destiny they were
tossed around like lumps of treasure to
be hoarded.
They'd come to the kingdom of the sea
looking for safety, and instead, they
were prisoners once again.
Chapter 25.
The prison cave was high on the cliff
wall, not far from the canopy, overlooking
the pavilion below.
Tsunami hadn't paid much attention to it
before, except to notice that riptide and
webs had been taken there.
But as the guards flew them up to the
cave, she realized that it glowed with a
weird blue light, and she could hear
strange crackling sounds coming from
inside.
Sharp spears prodded her into the cave
entrance, and she felt damp stone under
her claws.
As her eyes adjusted to the dim light, she
saw a path winding into the huge cavern
ahead of them.
This wasn't the underwater prison, lagoon
and shark had been sent to.
This was where Queen Coral kept the real
threats, including Tsunami realized, as
she was shoved along the stone floor
several prisoners of war.
She saw at least 3 Sky Wings, hissing
short blasts of flame at their captors.
An ice wing lay with his wings spread out
gasping faintly from the heat he wasn't
used to.
Two sand wings were caged together.
One of them curled in a ball with his
eyes pressed shut, the other pacing and
snarling.
There was even a giant mud wing with
chains around her ankles, like the ones
that had been on clay.
She tilted her head curiously at clay as
he went by.
But the strangest thing about the prison
wasn't the dragon prisoners, or even the
staggeringly large size of the cavern.
It was the cages.
There were no bars, no doors.
Instead, a channel of water as wide as 2
dragons encircled each prisoner, trapping
them on islands of stone, some large
enough from multiple dragons, some with
barely room for one.
More water poured from grooves in the
ceiling down to the channels, creating
cascading walls around the islands.
And all the water walls, and all the
moats glowed the same bright blue, and
gave off the same fizzing, crackling
sound.
The imprisoned dragons flinched away from
any stray droplets that splashed toward
them, and they kept their tails carefully
tucked up on dry land.
The path wound around and between the
islands like a long bridge.
The ceiling above was covered in glow
worms, casting an eerie light over all
the strange prison cells.
Tsunami twisted to peer into the moats.
What were the prisoners so afraid of?
Iridescent purple jellyfish pulsed here
and there, adding their light to the glow
worms up above.
Tsunami knew that their tentacles could
sting, but surely not badly enough to
keep the prisoners in, if it were her, and
soon it will be, she thought, she'd leap
right through the water wall, splash
through the moat, and fight her way out
no matter how many jellyfish were in her
way.
Suddenly, she caught sight of a dark
green shape swimming in one of the
channels.
It was as long as a scavenger, and as
thick around as a dragon tail, with no
legs or arms or wings.
As she squinted at it, another one
surfaced not far away, and she caught a
glimpse of a flat head, with sunken dead
eyes.
Nostrils flared at the end of its snout
and then it sank into the water again.
Bubbles fizzed and snapped for a long
moment where it had been.
Sonny pressed close against clay.
Her gray green eyes enormous and
terrified.
Tsunami glanced around at Starflight and
saw him studying the cages as well.
Maybe he would understand what was going
on.
She didn't spot webs or riptide, but the
dragonettes were pushed along so fast, and
the water blurred the features of the
prisoners, so it was hard to distinguish
between the few imprisoned sea wings she
could see.
The guards finally stopped at one of the
largest prison islands.
There was the same moat around it, but no
water came from the ceiling here.
Tsunami couldn't see anything swimming in
the moat either.
Hop over, growled one of the guards.
All of you.
What if we don't?
Tsunami asked.
Then you'll be dragged off to separate
cages instead of getting to share one, he
answered.
Clay jumped over the moat immediately, his
talons scraped against the hard rock
floor as he landed with a heavy thud.
He turned and reached out to catch Sonny
as she leaped after him.
Starflight followed, and then glory, and
finally, reluctantly, tsunami flapped her
wings to lift herself over the chasm and
land beside her friends.
Another guard pulled on a chain that hung
along the wall.
Something clanked and groaned from within
the stone, as she drew the links through
her claws.
Tsunami leaned forward and saw a small
door opening in the underwater wall of
the moat.
Three of the thick green creatures
wriggled through it, their dead eyes
staring creepily up at her.
A whoosh sounded from above, and talons
yanked her back from the edge just as
water came sluicing down.
Tsunami looked up at the cave roof, then
around to see that it was Starflight who
had pulled her back.
He let her go, and twisted to watch the
waterfall that now surrounded them.
His claws tapped nervously against one
another.
What are those creepy things in the
water?
Tsunami asked him.
I think, I think they're electric eels, he
said.
Oh, Glory said, shaking out her wings as
if they were covered in bugs.
The scrolls about them gave me nightmares
for months.
Sonny twined her tail around one of
Clay's forelegs as if she was trying to
get even closer to him.
What's an electric eel?
she asked.
They give off a kind of shock.
Starflight explained.
Behind him, a blue fizzing light sparked
up the waterfall and vanished again
making them all jump.
It would feel like getting hit by
lightning.
Glory added.
And it can be strong enough to kill a
dragon. said Starflight, especially in
salt water, and when the eels are as big
as the ones down there.
So all this water around us, tsunami
started.
Could be charged with deadly force at any
time, Starflight said.
Not all the time.
It's not a constant current, but if
they're mad or hungry, they're probably
giving off shocks pretty frequently, and
then just touching the water could
transfer that to you, even if it only
stunned you.
It would hurt a lot.
Tsunami frowned at the cascade.
Through it, she could see the blurry
outline of the guards slithering away.
Evidently, they trusted their nasty
prison setup to keep the dragonets in.
I can't believe we're prisoners again.
Clay said with a sigh.
Why does this keep happening to us?
I know, Sonny agreed.
Doesn't anyone trust the prophecy?
If they believe in it, can't they have
faith that will do the right thing?
Everyone is trying to make sure the
prophecy turns out the way they want it
to, tsunami said.
She turned in a circle, but there wasn't
enough room to pace without brushing her
wings or tail into the water.
She sat back down with a growl.
It would be helpful if the stupid
prophecy had been a little more clear
about what was supposed to happen.
Why didn't you use your venom when they
grabbed us?
Starflight asked Glory?
Believe me, I will.
The rain wing said fiercely.
I'm waiting for the right moment.
I think that's smart, tsunami said.
Even with Glory's magical death spit, we
probably couldn't have fought off the
whole palace, and it would have given
away our best secret weapon.
Glory looked surprised.
Well, thank you. she said, although I'm
going to vote against calling it magical
death spit, please.
Maybe tonight. tsunami said, lowering her
voice, when most of the palace is
sleeping, maybe we can fight our way out
then.
Pass the water with the shocks that might
kill us?
Sonny asked, what good is magical death
spit against lightning eels?
Electric eels.
Starflight corrected her.
We are not calling it magical death spit
Glory said.
Or Tsunami remembered the guards who had
given her the key.
Maybe we can convince someone to let us
go.
I like that plan, Clay said, bombing his
head.
I like the one where we melt everyone's
eyeballs on our way out the door.
Glory said.
With magical death spit, Sonny said, then
buried her head in Clay's wings to hide
her giggles as Glory glared at her.
Three moons, Glory, said tsunami.
That's horrible.
Who are you?
Gloria asked.
What happened to the sea wing who'd fight
her way out of anything?
I'll still fight?
Tsunami said.
An image of Gil flashed in her mind, and
she shivered.
I'm just saying, there are a lot of these
guards who are really on our side.
I bet we can find someone to help us.
Sonny lifted her snout.
Did you hear something?
Like what?
Starflight asked.
The little Sandwing hesitated.
It's hard to be sure over the water
sounds.
Probably nothing.
Tsunami said.
Nothing helpful anyway.
Sonny frowned at her.
Someone's coming, Glory observed.
They could see a pale shape flitting
along the path toward them, although it
was blurred by the waterfall.
Is that what you heard?
Starflight asked Sonny.
She shook her head, looking perplexed.
As the dragon came closer.
Tsunami thought she recognized her
coloring, but surely it couldn't be?
Anemone?
She called.
There you are.
Anemone hurried over to their cage.
She stood as close as she could get to
the moat and the crackling water.
Tsunami wished she could reach over and
wrap her wings around her little sister.
You're unharnessed, she cried.
I know.
Isn't it wonderful?
Anemone stretched her wings wide and
beamed.
It's only for a little while.
She tugged at the web that was still
fitted closely around her chest.
I'll be snapped in again later.
But Queen Coral said I could go fly
around while she has aucklet fitted for
her harness, as long as I don't leave the
summer palace.
This would be the happiest day of my life
if I weren't so worried about you.
Can you set us free?
Clay asked hopefully.
And then come with us?
Tsunami suggested, we'll never make you
use your powers, I promise.
Anemone shook her head.
I wish I could, but coral and blister
will be furious enough about losing the
dragonettes of destiny.
Think about it.
If their secret weapon disappears too
they'll hunt you down like sharks after
prey.
That's a good point, Starfight agreed, in
his let's all be sensible voice.
I don't care, tsunami said.
I don't care if every Dragon Empire is
searching for us.
We'll keep you safe, a lot safer than you
are here.
Anemones shifted her wings, even through
the water, tsunami could see the mournful
expression on her snout.
I just, I just don't think I'm ready to
live my life like Webbs did, never able
to return home, she said.
I'd miss Aucklet, and I think the sea
wings need me here.
I think mother needs me.
So she's hearing another voice besides
blisters.
Tsunami knew that was all very logical
but it still made her scales itch to
think she'd have to abandon her sister
when she'd only just met her.
All right, Clay said.
You could still set us free though
right?
They'd know it was her, Glory pointed
out.
That's true, tsunami agreed.
It's too dangerous.
But there's something else I wanted to do
for you, Anemone said.
She lifted something in her front talons
and tsunami realized she was holding a
pure white narwhal spear.
Spear, anemone said solemnly.
Find the dragon who attacked tsunami in
the entrance tunnel and bring him or her
to us.
She let go, and the spear flew up the
path out of the cave.
The other dragonettes stared at her in
awe.
Is that really possible?
Clay asked.
That'll actually work.
We'll see, Anemone said, pressing her
claws together.
You didn't have to do that, tsunami said
worried.
Do you feel all right?
Just a little cold, Anemone answered.
She rubbed her tail between her talons
with a rough, scraping sound.
They waited.
And waited.
And finally, they saw someone stumbling
down the path toward them.
The spear seemed to glow in the dark as
it jabbed the dragon in the back and
wings and tail, driving it along.
Ow!
A voice echoed through the cavern.
What is the meaning of, why am I?
ow?
What?
Ow, stop.
Ow.
I will report you to the ow.
Well, that's not coral, said glory.
And it's not shark, said tsunami.
She scratched her horns, confused.
She'd been so sure it had to be shark.
Not Moray either.
Anemone stood up as he approached.
The spear prodded the dragon into place
beside Anemone, on the edge of the
electric moat.
It was Whirlpool.
Chapter 26.
Whirlpool?
Tsunami said, thoroughly astonished.
Why would you want to kill me?
She'd rather thought he was too boring to
be a suspect.
Rubbish, said the green dragon with a
haughty air.
I would never.
The spear poked him again.
A little harder this time.
Ow.
My goodness.
Anemone.
I had no idea you were capable of such
powerful magic.
I must be a brilliant teacher.
Of course, I'd be more impressed if it
weren't stabbing me, ow.
Anemone shifted on her talons
uncomfortably.
I didn't think it would be you, she
said.
We should tell Queen Blister.
How accomplished you are.
Whirlpool said, in his oozy voice, she'll
be so terribly pleased.
Don't you dare?
Tsunami snapped.
Do you really think I'll find you
threatening from in there?
He asked.
If you do, I'll tell mother you tried to
kill me, she said.
How do you think she'll feel about that?
He shrugged and reached up to play with a
gold hoop earring in his ear.
She may find it quite admirable
actually.
After all, I was merely trying to ensure
that anemone deer would be queen.
Me?
Anemone's wings fluttered open and
closed.
You don't even like me that much.
Why do anything for me?
Well, Whirlpool said, frankly, I don't
want to marry her.
He pointed at tsunami.
Wow, Glory said cheerfully.
That was totally on my list of reasons
why someone might want to kill you.
Don't worry, tsunami snapped.
I'd rather be torn apart by tiger sharks
than ever marry you.
But I do want to be king.
Whirlpool said.
He held out his talons, as if imagining
more gold rings looping around his
claws.
So I thought if I got rid of you, I'd
improve my chances of marrying a more
agreeable daughter.
I don't ever want to marry you either.
Anemone cried.
It's not really up to you, Whirlpool
said.
Taking a step back up the path to the
cave entrance.
Once I tell Queen Coral and Queen Blister
about what you can do.
They'll be so grateful, they'll let me
have anything I want.
But of course, then you'll be very busy
using your powers to win the war.
And you probably won't survive that.
So I should really ask for Aucklet
instead.
He tapped his snout thoughtfully, as if
he was musing to himself.
You can't tell them, tsunami shouted.
She was supposed to protect anemone from
being used like this.
It was the one thing her sister had asked
of her, and instead, now it would be her
fault if anemone became blisters pawn.
She lunged toward the waterfall, but Clay
jumped forward at the same time and held
her back, blue light crackled in front of
them, and down below, the eels clustered
menacingly like a sinister clump of
seaweed.
But at the same time, on the other side
of the waterfall, Anemone was moving
too.
She seized the spear from the air, spun
it around, and smacked the side of it
into Whirlpool's head.
He staggered forward, then crumpled
without a sound.
His wings tipped sideways, overbalancing
him, and in one sudden movement, his body
slipped over the edge into the electric
eel moat.
Anemone yelped with fear and dropped her
weapon.
She reached her talons toward the water.
But it was too late.
A blinding flash of blue sizzled up the
cascading waterfall, tsunami jumped back
and all 5 dragonettes huddled close in
the center of the island.
The water in the moat, churned and
seethed around the spot where Whirlpool
had disappeared.
Thick green tails thrashed through the
bubbles, and sparks flew, as if several
bolts of lightning were striking at
once.
Sunny covered her eyes, and Clay put his
wing around her.
Tsunami wished she could do the same for
anemone on the far side of the moat.
Her little sister looked petrified in
place.
Slowly, the flashes calmed down until
only an occasional zap appeared in the
wall.
And then they all stopped.
The waterfall was quiet, and so was the
moat.
Tsunami could see the eels, still
clustered around a large, dark shape at
the bottom of the pool, but their frenzy
had subsided, and she guessed she was
lucky she couldn't see any details of
what they were doing now.
Anemone, she called.
Are you all right?
Anemone didn't answer.
Her blurred outline was motionless, as if
she were one of Orca's statues.
I'm not sure I should tell you this
Starflight said, but you might be able to
go through the water right now.
Tsunami whipped around toward him.
Really?
Why?
He pointed to the eels.
After a burst like that, they'll need a
while to recharge, I think, so they might
not be able to let off any shocks for at
least a minute or two.
Wait, he added, as tsunami flared her
wings, but I'm not sure.
I didn't read those scrolls as often as
the ones about dragons.
I'm sorry.
Starflight's black head drooped.
It's probably not worth the risk.
I wouldn't listen to me.
But Starflight.
You know everything, Sonny said.
I'm sure you're right.
I could go through and turn off the
waterfall.
Tsunami said.
Then it would only be me risking it.
Starflight looked miserable.
But it was my idea, he said, and if I
might be wrong. shouldn't I?
Poor Starflight.
Tsunami twined her tail around his.
She knew he wanted to be brave and
helpful, but this was the kind of thing
she did, not him.
Don't be silly, she said.
This is my kingdom.
I'm responsible for doing the crazy
things here.
Do you remember what the scroll said
about electric eels?
Clay asked glory.
The rain wing lifted her wings slightly.
I don't think it was specific, she said.
They can run out of charge for short
periods of time, but I don't know if this
is definitely one of them or how long it
might last.
Think it through.
Be more like Starflight.
Don't be impulsive.
Tsunami thought.
But then, what if this is our only chance
to escape?
She glanced over at anemone.
And I have to help her.
But if I die, what happens to the
others?
She clansed her talons.
An image of her mother's counsel flashed
through her head.
All right, she said.
Let's vote.
Holy moons, Glory said.
Seriously, what have you done with a real
tsunami?
Quickly, tsunami said, shooting a glance
at the quiet waterfall.
I believe Starflight, Sonny said.
I think you can make it through.
Definitely.
I don't, Starflight said glumly.
I vote that nobody tries, just to be
safe.
Well, I want to get out of here, Glory
said.
And I'm willing to risk tsunami's bossy
scales to do it.
She shot tsunami a toothy grin.
Clay shook his head slowly.
I don't know.
You're too important to all of a
tsunami.
I don't think you should do it.
Well, that doesn't help, Tsunami said
with a snort.
Now I just have to decide for myself
anyway.
Some council you guys are.
But those were pretty much the votes
she'd been expecting, and she'd listened
to all of them, and she knew what she
wanted to do.
She took a deep breath, spun around, and
launched herself at the wall of water.
It felt like leaping into a freezing
hailstorm, icy drops pelting her snout
and closed eyes, slicing into her gills
through the seaweed bandage, hammering
the fractures in her ribs.
She braced herself for a lightning sharp
pain, but a moment later, her talons
thumped onto solid rock.
Tsunami opened her eyes as she skidded to
a stop.
She'd made it to the other side of the
moat, and her scales were still intact.
She grabbed Anemone's shoulders and shook
her until the pale little dragon looked
up to meet her eyes.
You have to get out of here.
Tsunami said.
We're going to escape, and I don't want
it to look like you were involved.
Go find mother and hang around where she
can see you so you have an alibi.
All right?
Are you listening?
But look what I did.
Anemone whispered, pointing to the pool.
You didn't mean to do that, Tsunami
said.
She knew way too clearly how anemone felt
right now.
Anemone?
It was an accident.
You didn't push him into the moat.
And if it hadn't happened, think how many
dragons you might have had to kill with
your powers.
Now you can tell mother that with no
trainer, your powers seem to be getting
weaker.
Mess up all the time.
Make sure she thinks you aren't ready and
won't be for a long time.
But one day, anemone started.
One day, very soon, this war will be
over.
We're going to end it.
Trust me.
Tsunami squeezed Anemones front talons in
hers.
Now get out of here.
Good luck, Anemone whispered.
Tsunami wrapped her wings around her
sister.
Good luck to you too.
Anemone fled out the cave path.
Her pale wings fluttered like moths as
she disappeared around the bend.
Tsunami hurried to the chain on the
wall.
The guard had yanked it down.
Could she pull it back up?
She tried hauling the chain in the
opposite direction, and felt it slide
jerkily through her claws.
Clanking noises rattled from the ceiling
and she stopped for a moment, glancing up
the path where the guards had gone.
Were there guards at the entrance?
What if they heard her?
Hey, kid, a raspy voice croaked.
Tsunami jumped and looked around.
A scrawny sandwing was watching her from
his prison island, even through the
waterfall, Tsunami could see the dark
glitter of his eyes.
You could do the same thing for me, he
hissed.
Set me free.
Tsunami turned back to the chain and kept
pulling.
She didn't know what was in store for
Coral's prisoners, but she also didn't
know why they were here, or whether they
deserved it.
Except for 2 of them.
Somewhere in this cavern, riptide and
webs were trapped, possibly awaiting
execution, she had to find them too.
What sounded like an enormous metallic
groan echoed overhead, and then suddenly
the cascading water around her friends
shut off.
There was a beat of silence as they all
stared up at the ceiling.
Sunny leaped off 1st, flapping her wings
to clear the moat, and the others
followed her quickly.
Tsunami pushed past them to lead the way
up the path.
What about me?
yelled the imprisoned Sandwing.
I have to find riptide and webs, tsunami
said to her friends, did anyone see them
on the way in?
I did, Clay said.
They're on one island together, not far
from the entrance.
The 5 of them hurried along the path.
Tsunami kept her wings curled in and
tried not to look at the fizzing blue
water walls or the lurking eels.
They rounded the last corner, and saw the
greenish light of the summer palace up
ahead.
Tsunami spotted the guards 1st and pushed
her friends back into the shadows.
Only three, she thought.
Three guards stood on the ledge outside
the prison, chatting, and tossing their
spears from talon to talon.
They didn't look very threatening, and
perhaps they were secretly on the
dragonette's side, if they had allowed
anemone through to see tsunami.
She didn't want to fight them if she
could avoid it.
She didn't want to shed any more sea wing
blood ever again.
There.
Clay whispered in her ear.
He pointed over her shoulder.
That island, just inside the entrance.
Tsunami spotted the 2 blue shapes moving
beyond the wall of water.
She also saw a chain running along the
stone beside their island, if she could
get to it without the guards noticing, and
then move the mechanism without the
guards hearing it.
Riptide and webs would be free to escape
with the dragonettes.
There it is again, Sonny whispered.
Don't you all hear that?
Hear what?
Clay whispered back.
I don't know, Sonny said.
I keep hearing.
I think I'm hearing wing beats.
There are sea wings flying all over the
palace, Glory pointed out.
I know, Sonny said.
This is bigger, higher.
I'm not sure.
Don't worry so much, tsunami said.
I'm sure you're imagining things.
Sunny stamped one of her feet and craned
her neck toward the outside.
No, I'm definitely sure, she said
firmly.
I hear wing beats above the canopy.
Lots and lots of them.
Sunny, tsunami started, but then Clay's
head shot up, and so did Starflights.
I think she's right, Clay said.
Tsunami inhaled sharply, realizing what
that meant.
You don't think?
Starflight lashed his tail.
I smell fire too.
Tsunami didn't have time to think, or
come up with a safe, logical solution.
She burst out of their hiding spot and
ran toward the guards.
Look out, she yelled.
Warn the palace.
All 3 guards jumped, and 2 of them
accidentally dropped their spears over
the ledge.
They stared at tsunami as if her horns
were blazing columns of fire.
Move!
she shouted.
Tsunami shoved them aside, stood on the
ledge and yelled, Sea Wings, Mother, look
out!
We're under attack.
And then the 1st fire bomb crashed
through the canopy.
Chapter 27.
Panic.
Screaming, for a palace surrounded by
water.
It was surprising how much caught on fire
so quickly.
Large sections of the canopy collapsed
carrying flaming branches and leaves and
debris down onto the summer palace.
Tsunami saw dragons spiraling toward the
lake, their wings alight with flames
shrieking with pain.
The fire bombs were just logs set on fire
but they caused terrible damage as they
crashed through the pavilion and knocked
sea wings out of the air.
The Skywings found us, said one of the
guards, looking skyward in terror.
As he said it, they all saw a wing of red
and orange dragons soar overhead, dropping
more bombs and breathing more fire down
on the canopy.
But how?
said the 2nd guard.
Tsunami thought of the hole left in the
canopy when blister ripped webs out of
it.
Would that have been enough to lead the
sky wings here?
So quickly?
What were the chances?
A scout had spotted the hole, reported
back, and gathered the forces for an
attack only a day later.
It had to be something else.
She looked down and saw the lake water
churning as frantic dragons tried to
shove their way into the exit tunnel.
Only one way in meant only one way out
and it wasn't big enough for everyone at
once.
She felt sick at the thought of all those
dragons crammed into the small space
together.
There was one other way, but flying out
through the canopy, into the claws of the
sky wings, could be suicide.
Tsunami searched the mass of dragons for
her mother, but she couldn't see ropes of
pearls or wings the exact shade of her
own anywhere.
At least Coral wasn't one of the shapes
with charred wings floating limply in the
water.
Blister was nowhere to be seen either.
Shark swooped past, yelling order.
Most of the dragons seemed too panic
stricken to listen to him, but a few
rallied around and followed him up into
the sky.
Surely they would be outnumbered, tsunami
thought.
Surely they didn't stand a chance.
She took a step toward the edge and felt
someone grab her tail.
Don't do it.
Clay said, pulling her back.
I know you want to fight.
But we can't lose you like that.
Tsunami stopped.
Every muscle in her body wanted to be up
there. clawing at Skywing snouts and
smashing them out of the sky with her
tail.
The impulsive thing to do.
She thought.
Or she could listen to her friends.
She turned to the guards, who were all 3
trembling with fear, their eyes fixed on
the fiery canopy up above.
Go, she said.
Defending the palace is more important
than guarding the prisoners.
But one of them started.
But we can't let you, you have to save
yourselves, tsunami said.
And so do we.
Trust me, fate wants the dragonettes of
destiny to survive this.
The guards didn't stick around to argue.
They launched themselves off the ledge
and tsunami saw one fly down to join the
crush of dragons around the tunnel, but
the other 2 flew up to fight alongside
Commander Shark.
She spun and ran back to the prison
island, where webs and riptide were
trapped.
Clay was already there, fumbling with a
chain on the wall.
Tsunami showed him which way to pull it.
Can you hear me?
She called to the prisoners.
We're getting you out of there.
Get ready to fly.
Tsunami?
Riptide's voice was lost in the creaking
and clanking and rumbling of things
moving in the ceiling.
Abruptly, the water stopped flowing, and
tsunami found herself standing across
from the sky blue sea wing.
He smiled at her.
Hey there, she said.
The dragonettes of destiny specialize in
dramatic rescues, you know.
Are you impressed?
Very, he said. hopping over the moat to
land beside her.
Webb staggered after him, landing
unevenly on the stone.
It didn't seem like a good sign that a
thin line of blood was still trickling
from his ear.
Another pair of fiery logs crashed past
outside. and more screams echoed from
below.
Riptide flared his wings, looking
startled and horrified.
The palace is under attack, tsunami
explained.
It'll make escape tricky, but wait
Riptide said, catching one of her
talons.
Tsunami.
I have to tell you something.
I, I do work for the talons of peace.
Tsunami stared at him.
Her mother was right about riptide?
He was working with the dragons who'd
ruined her life.
She'd always hated the talent of peace.
How could she have fallen for one of
them?
Please, listen.
I joined them because I wanted to find
out more about my father, but they
wouldn't tell me anything except that he
was safe.
He looked down.
I've been working with them for a few
years now, passing them information about
the sea wings.
Sounds like betrayal to me.
Tsunami thought, although she wasn't sure
whether she felt more betrayed for her
tribe or for herself.
You have a very bad habit, she said, of
not telling me some critically important
things.
I know.
I'm sorry.
I was meeting with one of their agents
right before I met you.
Tsunami remembered the dragon with the
black spirals on his scales.
He told me to keep an eye out, in case
the dragonettes of destiny showed up in
the kingdom of the sea.
Tsunami pulled her talon out of his
grasp.
Riptide had acted surprised to hear the
talons even existed.
He'd pretended not to know anything about
the dragonettes of destiny.
Clearly, he was a good actor, hiding a
secret like this while living in the
tribe all these years.
So could she believe anything he'd said
to her?
Blood trickled from the gash on his side
as he moved?
I stayed close to make sure you and the
other dragonettes were safe.
He spread his wings and held out his
talons to tsunami.
I'm sorry, I couldn't tell you the
truth.
I didn't think you'd trust me if you
knew.
He was right about that.
But she didn't particularly trust him now
either.
An enormous crash sounded outside as
something smashed into the pavilion.
We have to go, said Glory from behind
tsunami.
For once, she didn't add anything snide
and tsunami wondered if she'd overheard
Riptide's confession.
Um, Clay's voice said behind them, Tsunami
Webbs, do we know this dragon?
They all turned and saw a large mud wing
looming in the mouth of the cave.
Her brown wings were creased with soot
and a horrible scar pulled down one
corner of her mouth into a strange
grimace.
Webbs flicked his tail in surprise.
I do, he said.
She's with the talons of peace.
She saved my life.
Crocodile.
What are you doing here?
The Medwing chuckled.
Poor webs.
So wrong in so many ways.
She stepped into the cavern and gave the
dragonettes an appraising look.
These are the brats the talons are so
obsessed with.
Scrawny.
She lashed her tail, but the sky wings
want you back anyway, for the next queen
to play with, I assume.
Queen Scarlet is dead?
Glory blurted.
For sure?
You're not working with the sky wings?
Webbs cried at the same time.
Of course I am, Crocodile said.
Who knew that infiltrating the talons of
peace would be so useful.
I never thought I'd get the chance to
follow an idiot seawing back to the
secret palace we've been searching for
all this time.
Webbs blanched, and his wings drooped
heavily, as if a whole new mountain of
guilt had just landed on him.
Plus, bonus dragonettes of destiny
crocodile said, I am so getting a
promotion.
Is Queen Scarlet really dead?
Glory asked again.
Nobody knows, Crocodile said with a
shrug.
She seems to have vanished.
Nobody can even tell the same story about
what happened to her.
Well, lucky you, said Glory.
You're about to find out.
She snapped her mouth open, and shot her
black venom straight into crocodile's
eyes.
The mud wing bellowed in agony and fell
back, scraping her wings against the cave
walls.
She clawed at her snout, but the acid was
already eating into her scales.
With another shrieking roar.
She shot out of the cave and dove for the
lake below.
Let's go, tsunami shouted, spreading her
wings.
The 5 dragonettes, riptide, and webs
burst out of the cave.
Below them.
Dragons were still trying to shove their
way into the tunnel, and the churning
mass of wings and scales around the exit
didn't look any smaller than it had
before.
We can't go that way, Starflight said.
We'll have to go out through the canopy.
Tsunami said.
They all looked up and saw 3 red dragons
shoot by, breathing fire.
I don't really love that plan either
Starflight said, in a smaller voice.
Tsunami spotted her mother at last.
Queen Coral was standing on the library
level, casting one last look at her
scrolls.
They weren't on fire yet, but they were
the most flammable things in the palace.
If they went up, the smoke would fill the
palace and kill even more dragons.
Her littlest dragonette was wrapped
tightly to the queen's chest, Anemones
stood on the edge of the pavilion
unharnessed, waiting.
As they watched, Queen Coral began
flinging her scrolls over the edge into
the water.
After a moment, Anemone joined her, and
the queen paused to touch her daughter's
head affectionately.
She can be a good mother.
Tsunami thought sadly, and a good queen.
She wondered if there was any version of
Pyria where they could have grown up as a
family.
She and Coral, and Gil, and Anemone, and
Aucklet, normal and happy, with no one
trying to kill anyone.
Too late now.
She had this other family.
Not at all normal, and they needed her
more than anyone.
She soared up toward the tattered remains
of the canopy.
Another flaming log came barreling down
toward them, and tsunami yanked glory out
of its path.
It plummeted toward the lake, careening
off the pavilion and setting another
dragon on fire as it fell.
Sonny, tsunami called.
Starflight, stable O'Clay's wings.
Clay stretched his fireproof wings out
and the 2 dragonettes ducked underneath
on either side of him.
Tsunami surged ahead to scout the sky
outside.
She flew out past the smoking leaves and
nearly collided with a sky wing.
He held a log in his claws, and was about
to breathe his fire onto it before
dropping it into the palace, but tsunami
sent him swerving out of the way, and
when she saw what he held, she slammed
her tail into his side.
The law flew out of his claws into the
ocean, and he tumbled after it.
Five more sky wings were flying around in
formation to make another pass.
Off to her left.
Tsunami spotted a wing of huge mud wings
carrying extra logs.
The sky wings zipped up to them, took a
log apiece, and flew back to the palace
to set them alight.
She hissed with anger.
This was a brutal, carefully planned
attack on a palace full of dragonettes
and innocent civilians.
There was nothing fair or honorable about
this bite.
Shark and his sea wings were fighting
another set of sky wings in the sky to
her right.
Fire blazed, and talons clashed against
scales.
She wanted to join them.
She itched to be over there, slashing and
clawing, and battling the intruders who'd
dared attack her family's palace.
That was the kind of fighting.
She wouldn't feel guilty about
afterward.
But the other dragonettes were flying up
beside her now, and she couldn't leave
them.
That way, she said, jerking her head at
the biggest swath of clear sky.
From the sun she guessed it was south
south toward the continent, which was
where they needed to go.
Glory shot past her immediately, and as
she reached the sky, her scales turned
pale blue and white and gold, and she
shimmered into nothingness.
Tsunami couldn't even see a ripple in the
air as the rain wing flew away.
Clay went next, spreading his wings to
shield Sonny and Starflight.
A sky wing in the battle spotted them and
swerved in their direction.
Tsunami lunged at her, grabbed her snout
and kicked her underbelly as hard as she
could.
The Skywing kicked her back, sending
bright arcs of pain along tsunami's
fractured ribs.
Tsunami lost her grip, and the sky wing
roared a blast of flame at Clay's
departing back.
He shuddered as the heat licked along his
scales, but beat his wings and flew on
the other 2 dragonettes safely
protected.
The sky wing blinked with astonishment as
clay's wings faded back to brown instead
of turning black or twisting into painful
burns.
Surprise, tsunami said, and punched her
in the snout.
The sky wing crumpled, and fell toward
the ocean, landing with a splash and
banishing instantly below the waves.
Riptide soared up out of the canopy
twisting around to make sure Webbs was
safe behind him.
Tsunami turned to fly south and heard
riptide call her name.
I have to help them, he called, lashing
his tail toward the fighting sea wings.
But they'll put you back in prison
tsunami protested.
They'll punish you because we escaped.
Maybe, he said.
Probably, but I have to help if I can.
This is my home.
She knew exactly how he felt.
Tsunami.
He paused.
I really am sorry.
I hope next time.
Well, I hope there is a next time.
When things are better for everyone.
She hoped so too.
She wasn't sure she'd forgiven him, but
she wanted the chance to decide.
She wanted him to survive the war, and
she wanted to meet him again in a world
with no talons of peace, or destinies, or
secrets to worry about.
But there wasn't time to say all that.
Tsunami flashed one of the patterns he
taught her.
All right.
Then she added, Squid Brain, and Riptide
smiled before turning to fly away into
the heart of the battle.
Webbs and tsunami swerved south together
wings beating side by side.
But other wing beats were close behind
them.
Tsunami twisted just in time to see
blister, lunge out of the canopy and
seize webs by the tail.
She yanked him back toward her, and
stabbed her poisonous barb toward his
heart.
With a yell, tsunami barreled into them
knocking the sandwing off of webs.
Blister fell back toward the palace
hissing.
Tsunami grabbed webs by his front talons
and towed him after her.
A few wing beats later, Webbs groaned
softly.
Did she get you?
Tsunami demanded.
She missed my heart. he said He lifted
his wing to show an oozing graze near his
tail.
It's still poisonous, he said.
We'll find a way to fix it, Tsunami
said.
Just keep flying until we get to land.
She looked back again, and saw blister
hovering in the air, watching them go.
Her cold, glittering black eyes seemed to
follow tsunami all the way to the edge of
the sky.
Chapter 28.
Tsunami was on a beach again.
This time it was dark, long after sunset
and small stars shone in the sky, like
the silver scales on the underside of
Starflight's wings.
Tsunamis stared down at the waves, lapping
over her talons.
She wondered if she'd ever see riptide
again.
Or anemone, or Aucklet, or her mother.
I know it's dark, Starflight said
uncomfortably behind her.
But tsunami sighed.
But we should stay under the trees.
She stood up and followed him into the
woods, shaking the sand off her talons.
I am trying to be more like you, you know
she said to him.
I'm trying to stop and think and use my
head, and all that smart stuff, but it
drives me a little crazy sometimes.
Starflight stumbled on a tree root and
turned to stare at her.
Be more like me?
he echoed.
Why would you want to do that?
I wish I were anything like you
especially brave.
Tsunami brushed his wing with hers.
You're all right the way you are, she
said.
Someone has to be the thoughtful, careful
one, and you've made blister pretty mad.
That took some courage.
Besides, I don't think this group could
handle 2 of me.
In the moonlight, she caught a half smile
flitting across his face.
Webbs lay on a patch of moss, breathing
in a nasty shallow way.
Sonny was curled up beside him, so her
scales could give him a little warmth.
Clay was peering at the scratch near his
tail, which was still oozing, and
starting to turn black around the edges.
We need help, Clay said.
I have no idea how to fix this.
His expression was woeful.
Who would know how to cure someone of
sandwing venom?
Sonny asked.
Sandwings, I guess?
She answered herself, but I don't know
where we'd find one we could trust.
The talons of peace?
Starflight suggested doubtfully.
I can't go back there.
Webb said, and you shouldn't either.
Tsunami tilted her head at him
curiously.
After all of these years of being a good
talent foot soldier, obeying their every
command, suddenly he'd changed his mind.
If crocodile was an infiltrator, he said
catching her look.
There could be others.
I don't know who's safe for you, and
who's not?
Seriously.
Even the good dragons all seem to have
plans for us, tsunami said, thinking of
her mother.
Gosh, I hope Blaze is better than the
other two, Sonny said fervently.
Starflight winced, but didn't argue with
her.
We can probably find her with the ice
wings, he said, but we'll have to be very
very careful this time.
Yeah, Clay agreed.
I vote for not getting locked up ever
again.
Maybe we should try a different approach
Glory suggested.
Maybe this time we could not barge in
yelling, we are the dragonettes of
destiny.
We're awesome and special.
We'd make terrific prisoners.
Just an idea.
Do you know what we're supposed to do?
Sonny asked Webbs, hopefully?
Did the talents have any plans about how
we could fulfill the prophecy?
If they did, Webb said.
They didn't share them with me.
Awesome, Gloria muttered.
Tsunami glanced at her.
The rain wings scales were shades of
black and dark green, blending in with a
dark forest around them.
An idea struck her.
I know who might help Webbs with a poison
tsunami said.
Who?
Clay asked.
The rain wings, she said.
Glory twisted around to give her a sharp
look.
Think about it.
Tsunami went on.
They have Venom too, obviously.
They must know something about what to do
when you poison the wrong dragon.
True, Starflight said, even if it's a
different kind of venom, that's still a
good point.
And then we can look for Glory's family
Tsunami said, which I think is only
fair.
Glory's face was expressionless, but
small puffs of rose pink were blooming in
her scales.
Tsunami guessed that meant she was happy
since it wasn't a color they saw very
often on her.
Are you?
Are you sure?
Glory said.
That's what we should do next?
Absolutely, Sonny said.
We should definitely go find your home
Glory.
I bet it's beautiful, Clay said, in his
sweet, earnest way, and your family will
be so happy to see you.
Webb let out a small groan, but when they
turned to look at him, he closed his eyes
as if he'd fallen asleep.
Tsunami was sure he was pretending, but
what they did next wasn't up to him
anyway.
It's also closer to here than most of the
other tribes.
Starflight pointed out.
We have to cross the outskirts of mudwing
territory, but the rainforest should be
basically due southwest of here.
I know that, Glory said crossly.
You're not the only one who can memorize
Maps, Starflight.
Perfect, tsunami said.
That's what we'll do.
After we rest?
Sonny asked hopefully.
Tsunami thought she could keep flying all
night as she had to.
She wanted to put as much distance
between them and blister as possible.
She wanted to shove all the other
dragonettes ahead of her all the way to
the rainforest without stopping.
But she looked at Sonny's tired eyes, and
Starflight's drooping wings, and she
settled herself close to Webb's tail.
After we rest, she agreed.
Sonny lay down again with a relieved
sigh.
A few moments later, tsunami saw her back
rising and falling in deep sleep.
Clay flopped down next to tsunami, his
tail draped over hers.
I'm sorry about your mother. he said, and
the palace.
And blister, and whirlpool.
And riptide.
And, all right, I get it.
Tsunami said, cutting him off with a
nudge.
I hope they all make it through the
attack, he said quietly.
Me too, she said.
But they'll be safe in the deep palace.
At least they have somewhere else to go.
She thought for a moment.
And I think anemone will be a good queen
one day.
She has Coral's good qualities, but she
thanks for herself, and she's still
young.
She'll get stronger and more independent
as she gets older.
If she's anything like you, independent
will be an understatement, Glory said.
She tucked herself along Clay's other
side, and he put one wing over her.
Starflight had tentatively nosed in
beside Sonny, and now his eyes were
closed as well.
The kingdom of the sea wasn't the right
place for me anyway, tsunami said, partly
to convince herself.
What about your great royal destiny?
Glory teased.
What about how you'd be the greatest
queen of all time?
Well, tsunami said with a shrug.
I guess I'll have to settle for being the
boss of you guys.
Ha, Gloria said, but not in her usual
sarcastic way.
Amused yellow bubbles floated through her
wings, and she reached over to nose
tsunami's shoulder.
You can certainly keep trying.
I will. tsunami thought, but not because
I think I'm the greatest, and everyone
should listen to me.
I'll keep trying to lead you because it's
the only way I know to keep you all
safe.
And maybe sometimes I'll have to listen.
The way mother listens to her counsel.
And sometimes I won't be able to do
exactly what I want.
But even when she was mad at her friends
she knew she could trust them.
And she had to be the kind of dragon
naked trust as well.
She glanced up at the moons, 2 of them
glowing pale and ghostly beyond the
trees.
There were more important things than
becoming queen.
Stopping the war was one of them.
If the 5 of them were the only ones who
could, then maybe that was what they had
to do.
Whether tsunami believed in destiny or
not.
She wriggled closer to her friends.
All of them were sleeping soundly now.
So the kingdom of the sea wasn't home
after all, she thought.
I wonder if anywhere ever will be.
Epilogue.
Well, Maro Sears said.
So that didn't go as planned.
You neglected to mention a few things
said Blister calmly.
Such is the fact that your 5 dragonettes
are remarkably annoying.
She draped her barbed tail pointedly over
her talons and folded her wings back.
Yes, said the night wing.
True.
But you might have tried to be a little
less sinister at them.
He stared down at the charred ruins of
the summer palace.
Fires were still smoldering on a few
floors of the pavilion.
Three days after the battle, nothing
remained but smoke and corpses.
At least Webbs is dead, he said.
Should be by now, she answered, flipping
her tail up and down.
Queen Coral survived, he asked.
And both her brats as well, said
Blister.
It wouldn't be convenient for me if she
died.
She bared her teeth and hissed softly.
Of course.
Now she's hiding in her deep palace where
I can't get to her, and she insists that
my secret weapon will be no use to me for
years still.
She's gotten all squeamish about anima's
powers since finding out about her 1st
daughter.
Like she'd rather waste that little one's
magic just to keep her from turning
homicidal.
Blister sighed a small burst of flame.
It's not been my favorite week of the
war.
She batted away a piece of smoking
foliage.
So, Nightwing, I hope for your sake, that
you bring me news I want to hear.
There is another option, Morrissier
said.
But I'm not sure you'll like it much
better.
He spread his wings and beckoned to a
green shape circling in the sky
overhead.
The sea wing landed carefully on the
cliffside, vines crumbling to ashes below
his claws.
He glanced down at the palace and
shuddered.
Morosier noticed that he stayed well away
from blister.
Perhaps he'd heard, or guessed, what had
happened to Kestrel.
This is Nautilus, Marosir explained, one
of the leaders of the talons of peace.
Nautilus, explain your backup plan to the
queen.
Possible, future, queen.
Nautilus corrected, then jumped back
nervously as blister raised her poisonous
tail.
Err, he said quickly.
We have a set of alternatives.
Blister's black eyes glittered with
interest.
Alternatives, she said.
Really?
My, my.
I had no idea the talons of peace could
be so devious.
Nautilus frowned.
We prefer to think of it as planning for
every contingency, he said.
We have to do whatever's necessary so the
prophecy will come true.
Or true ish, Maro Seer interjected.
Of course, Blister said.
Dragonettes can be so unpredictable.
You are very wise.
Well, Nautilus said, pleased.
It was my idea.
Of course it was, she said.
Very clever.
We are talking about false dragonettes
yes?
But, rumbled Mars Zear.
Yes, Nautilus said, his tail twitched.
But they're, uh, not quite perfect.
Hmm, said blister.
Worse than the originals.
Is that possible?
Well, different.
Or else they'd be plan A?
Nautilus said.
Obviously.
All I want to know is whether they'll do
as they're told, Blister said.
Um, Nautilus wrinkled his snout and
stared at the sky.
Maybe?
This does sound promising, Blister said
dryly.
I can't wait to meet them.
Perhaps we can take the best options from
each group, Maro Seer said.
Kill the rain wing, obviously.
We can probably work with the original
mud wing.
Your night wing is useless.
Blister said.
Worst traitor I've ever seen.
Marosir shook his head.
That is very disappointing.
We don't often kill off our dragonettes
but, he sighed.
If we must.
Ah, said Nautilus.
You might want to meet our other option
first.
I mean, not to interfere.
Just a suggestion.
And we'll definitely kill the sea wing.
Blister snarled.
Nautilus flapped his wings, backing away
in a hurry.
Not you, she said impatiently.
Well, not right now.
I thought tsunami had some potential.
Maru seer muttered.
Potential to annoy my tail off, blister
growled.
No, she definitely has to go.
We have dragons working on it as we
speak.
Marasia promised.
Recruiting assassins is surprisingly easy
in the middle of a war.
Good.
Blister flicked her tail menacingly.
Those dragonettes need to know, they're
not as valuable as they think they are.
Anyone can be replaced.
She smiled with all her teeth.
After all, there's more than one way to
fulfill a prophecy.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 2, The
Lost Heir, by 2ET Sutherland, a Nightwing
Guide to the Dragons of Pyrea, read by
2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Sebastian Zettin.
Executive producer Paul R.
Gagne.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2012 by 2ET Sutherland.
Production copyright 2016 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.
Hi, this is Tooey Sutherland.
A Nightwing Guide to the Dragons of
Pyrhea.
Sandwings.
Description, pale gold or white scales
the color of desert sand.
Poisonous barbed tail, forked black
tongues.
Abilities, can survive a long time
without water.
Poison enemies with the tips of their
tails like scorpions, bury themselves for
camouflage in the desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the death of Queen Oasis, the tribe
is split between 3 rivals for the throne
sisters burn, blister, and blaze.
Alliances.
Burn fights alongside Skywings and
Mudwings.
Blister is allied with the sea wings, and
Blaze has the support of most sand wings
as well as an alliance with the ice
wings.
Mudwings.
Description, thick armored brown scales
sometimes with amber and gold
underscales.
Large flat heads with nostrils on top of
the snout.
Abilities can breathe fire if warm
enough.
Hold their breath for up to an hour, blend
into large mud puddles, usually very
strong.
Queen, queen moorhen.
Alliances, currently allied with burn and
the sky wings in the Great War.
Sky Wings.
Description, red gold or orange scales
enormous wings.
Abilities, powerful fighters and flyers
can breathe fire.
Queen, Queen Scarlet.
Alliances, currently allied with burn and
the mud wings in the Great War.
Sea wings.
Description, blue or green or aquamarine
scales, webs between their claws, gills
on their necks, glow in the dark stripes
on their tails, snouts, underbellies.
Abilities can breathe underwater, see in
the dark, create huge waves with one
splash of their powerful tails.
Excellent swimmers.
Queen, queen coral, alliances, currently
allied with blister in the Great War.
Ice Wings, Description, silvery scales
like the moon, or pale blue like ice.
Ridged claws to grip the ice, forked blue
tongues, tails narrow to a whip thin
end.
Abilities, can withstand subzero
temperatures and bright light.
Exhale a deadly, freezing breath.
Queen, Queen Glacier.
Alliances.
Currently allied with Blaze and most of
the sand wings in the Great War.
Rain wings.
Description, scales constantly shift
colors, usually bright like birds of
paradise, prehensile tails, abilities, can
camouflage their scales to blend into
their surroundings.
Use their prehensile tails for climbing
no known natural weapons.
Queen, queen dazzling.
Alliances, not involved in the Great
War.
Night Wings.
Description.
Purplish black scales and scattered
silver scales on the underside of their
wings, like a night sky full of stars
forked black tongues.
Abilities can breathe fire, disappear
into dark shadows, read minds, foretell
the future.
Queen, a closely guarded secret.
Alliances, too mysterious and powerful to
be part of the war.